Caption: originally called this
Caption: refactoring components and then one of
Caption: my co-workers pointed out that that was
Caption: pretty boring and i was missing out an
Caption: opportunity to go
Caption: getting on the refactor tractor
Caption: so that's what we're going with
Caption: um
Caption: my name is erin i work for the company
Caption: formerly known as square
Caption: which is now known as block and i
Caption: specifically work building a product
Caption: called cash up which you may not have
Caption: heard of because it's not currently
Caption: available in australia but our aim is
Caption: basically to fix the truly atrocious
Caption: situation that is the banking sector in
Caption: the us you think we've got it bad here
Caption: um but we do have offices here in
Caption: australia and we are very remote
Caption: friendly so if you're looking for a
Caption: change maybe come have a chat
Caption: um like i said i will have my knitting
Caption: needles around i i'll be knitting socks
Caption: because
Caption: this year i decided for some reason i
Caption: was going to knit everyone's socks for
Caption: christmas um so now i'm going to knit
Caption: like 10 pairs of socks by the end of the
Caption: year and there's no like
Caption: no going back from that yet right
Caption: i'm stuck
Caption: um and if you would like to follow along
Caption: uh at home these slides are available at
Caption: refactortractor.ez.codes
Caption: and they really are there this time not
Caption: like at the last talk i gave
Caption: all right so today we're going to talk
Caption: about refactoring we're going to start
Caption: with factoring is and when we might want
Caption: to do it
Caption: we're going to look at some occupational
Caption: health and safety so
Caption: some tools that we can use to ensure
Caption: that our refactoring happens safely
Caption: we're going to look at some additional
Caption: tools we've got available for working
Caption: with jsx
Caption: and we're going to do lots of live
Caption: examples because i like living
Caption: dangerously
Caption: all right so what is refactoring uh
Caption: refactoring is when we change the
Caption: implementation without changing the
Caption: functionality right so we're changing
Caption: the code but we're not changing what it
Caption: does
Caption: there's a few reasons we might do that
Caption: we might want to make the code easier to
Caption: understand
Caption: we might want to wait want to make it
Caption: easier to test
Caption: or mostly we want to make it easier to
Caption: change
Caption: um so
Caption: some things that we might do while we're
Caption: refactoring are things like renaming
Caption: variables right maybe the variable names
Caption: we've got out of sync with what's
Caption: actually going on and the cut the code
Caption: is hard to understand rename the
Caption: variables make it a bit easier to
Caption: understand
Caption: we might take long functions and split
Caption: them up into smaller functions which
Caption: also makes the code easier to understand
Caption: because it's easier to reason about the
Caption: smaller pieces
Caption: as well as making it easier to test
Caption: because we can test the parts
Caption: independently
Caption: and we might do things like we've got
Caption: some repeated code we might
Caption: factor it out so it's just in one place
Caption: which makes it easier to change right
Caption: it's going to have to change it in one
Caption: place later
Caption: if you're interested in this kind of
Caption: nitty-gritty details of refactoring i
Caption: highly recommend that you check out
Caption: martin fowler's book refactoring um he's
Caption: got like a whole taxonomy there like the
Caption: different
Caption: always like the different moves that you
Caption: can make in refactoring and like how to
Caption: do them and all like when you might want
Caption: to do those different things but we're
Caption: not going to get into quite that
Caption: nitty-gritty detail today
Caption: okay so now we know what refactoring is
Caption: when should we do it um and my sort of
Caption: cop-out answer is
Caption: when the benefits outweigh the costs um
Caption: and i say that's a common answer because
Caption: that's when you do anything right when
Caption: the benefits outweigh the costs
Caption: so what are the benefits and the costs
Caption: of refactoring
Caption: so the benefits of refactoring uh most
Caption: importantly the biggest benefit you're
Caption: going to get from it is faster future
Caption: development
Caption: right if you spend some time refactoring
Caption: your currencies it's easier to build
Caption: chain to build things change things fix
Caption: bugs later on that's a huge benefit of
Caption: refactoring
Caption: refraction also often leads to less bugs
Caption: if we're making code that's easier to
Caption: test then it's easier to find the bugs
Caption: that we do put in there but also if
Caption: we're making our code easy to understand
Caption: we're less likely to put the bugs in
Caption: there in the first place
Caption: and finally
Caption: refactoring is a lot of fun
Caption: i don't know about you but i get a real
Caption: thrill
Caption: out of um taking some code that's a huge
Caption: big mess
Caption: and cleaning it all up
Caption: um but maybe that's just me i don't know
Caption: there are some costs though the biggest
Caption: cost of refactoring is time
Caption: if we spent a day refactoring our code
Caption: and that's a day that we're not spending
Caption: building new features or fixing existing
Caption: bugs right so we need to take that into
Caption: account we need to make sure that that
Caption: trade-off exists
Caption: and there's also some risks with factory
Caption: so i found this delightful haiku on
Caption: twitter by another person named erin i
Caption: was pretty happy to see
Caption: um and she says
Caption: this courage used to work
Caption: hey i should refactor it
Caption: now
Caption: it does not work
Caption: which i found very relatable
Caption: um
Caption: she was a woman on twitter so obviously
Caption: what she got was a bunch of men telling
Caption: her that she should just different
Caption: better tests
Caption: um
Caption: which is easy to say but it can be quite
Caption: difficult right it's it's hard to write
Caption: tests for code when you don't
Caption: know what it was intending to do in the
Caption: first place right it's quite tricky to
Caption: write those tests
Caption: and also when you are writing those
Caption: tests often you'll pick up existing bugs
Caption: in the code and sort of you can't just
Caption: go around fixing them
Caption: because often
Caption: like if you've got bugs in your code
Caption: your users might have workarounds that
Caption: they've built to deal with those bugs
Caption: when you fix the bugs you're going to
Caption: break those workarounds um the best sort
Caption: of example i can think of with really
Caption: regards to that is internet explorer
Caption: which was basically
Caption: one big bug but
Caption: the way that it was written if microsoft
Caption: had gone in and fixed all of the bugs in
Caption: internet explorer it would have broken
Caption: millions of websites around the world
Caption: right so
Caption: ie had its issues but they their hands
Caption: were tied to some degree about the buggy
Caption: behavior
Caption: okay so as an example of some code that
Caption: i did not refactor this piece of code
Caption: comes from a code base that i was
Caption: working on last year um it was in this
Caption: component it's like a huge component
Caption: like a thousand lines long
Caption: favorite
Caption: and i was working in a different part of
Caption: the component that this particular
Caption: function now i hate this function this
Caption: this upsets me immensely this should be
Caption: like three lines of code there is no
Caption: need for any of this but it also worth
Caption: refactoring it like i wasn't doing
Caption: anything with a bit of code but also it
Caption: works
Caption: it's easy to understand it's easy to
Caption: test
Caption: apart from the way that it annoys me
Caption: there's not really anything wrong with
Caption: it so i never didn't didn't touch it
Caption: resisted the urge as far as i know it's
Caption: still in the code base but i don't have
Caption: to look at it anymore
Caption: okay so as a general rule i only
Caption: refactor code if
Caption: i'm doing some change some other change
Caption: at the same time or someone else in my
Caption: team is doing some other change so that
Caption: has the advantage that first of all i
Caption: know that
Caption: the refactor is going to be worthwhile
Caption: because it is going to speed up the
Caption: feature work that i'm doing
Caption: but also it means that there's a bunch
Caption: of people with their eyes on this code
Caption: at the moment right the other people in
Caption: my team our product managers our
Caption: designers everyone's looking at
Caption: what's going on in this part of the code
Caption: base our users are expecting a change
Caption: anyway there's a better chance that if i
Caption: do accidentally break something or
Caption: accidentally fix something that
Caption: somebody's get somebody's going to
Caption: notice and we can deal with it
Caption: appropriately
Caption: okay
Caption: so
Caption: we've sat down we've made our decision
Caption: and we've decided we're going to
Caption: refactor some code
Caption: the particular effect of the specific
Caption: refactor we're going to do is our code
Caption: base is using moment.js for handling
Caption: date times
Caption: moment.js was an absolutely fantastic
Caption: library for managing dates and times in
Caption: javascript when it was invented i think
Caption: 10 years ago but these days it's a
Caption: little bit heavy weight it's got uses
Caption: mutable dates which sort of result in
Caption: bugs and the managers at moment also
Caption: suggest that perhaps moment is not the
Caption: library to be using for you so we've
Caption: decided that we're going to switch to
Caption: date functions date fns
Caption: and the specific code
Caption: is this function here
Caption: so it's a function which formats a date
Caption: takes a date if the date is falsy it
Caption: returns an empty string
Caption: otherwise it's user's moment
Caption: behavior is
Caption: then we're going to refactor the code
Caption: and then we're going to write our
Caption: feature and we're not going to do step
Caption: three today because i'm assuming you are
Caption: all already really great at writing new
Caption: features and we're just going to
Caption: concentrate on the first two steps
Caption: so the way that we're going to determine
Caption: the current behavior is using something
Caption: called characterization tests so
Caption: characterization tests come from a book
Caption: called working effectively with legacy
Caption: code by michael feathers
Caption: if you do work with legacy code and you
Caption: would like to do it effectively this
Caption: could be the book for you
Caption: but
Caption: today we're just going to talk about
Caption: characterization tests
Caption: so characterization tests work a little
Caption: bit differently to the tests that you
Caption: would normally write when you're
Caption: building a feature so when you're
Caption: normally building a feature what you
Caption: would do
Caption: is you would write a test with some
Caption: expectations
Caption: and then you write the code to make the
Caption: test pass
Caption: assuming you're doing tdd i don't know
Caption: if you don't do tdd i guess you write
Caption: the test you write the code then you
Caption: write the test and you realize the
Caption: code's wrong you go back change the code
Caption: wonder why you didn't just write tests
Caption: first i don't know
Caption: a characterization test though is the
Caption: other sort of way around i guess we
Caption: write a test with no expectations
Caption: and then we change the test until the
Caption: expect we change the expectations until
Caption: the test passes
Caption: so with feature tests the code changes
Caption: but the test stays the same with
Caption: characterization tests the tests change
Caption: but the code stays the same the most
Caption: important thing is that we're only ever
Caption: changing one or the other right you're
Caption: either changing the code or you're
Caption: changing the test never both at once
Caption: so what does that look like
Caption: oh wrong way
Caption: uh here we have can everybody see that
Caption: because
Caption: yeah cool because i can't make it any
Caption: bigger than that i don't think
Caption: so that's lucky
Caption: so we have our function here and we're
Caption: ready to write some tests for it so
Caption: we're going to describe our format date
Caption: function
Caption: now uh when i'm writing tests i like to
Caption: start with the very simplest case
Caption: so when we pass in nothing
Caption: and what's going to happen then
Caption: it's and this is a characterization test
Caption: right so we don't know what it's going
Caption: to do i guess it's going to return
Caption: something returns we don't know
Caption: and then we can write the actual test is
Caption: going to be
Caption: expect
Caption: format
Caption: date
Caption: passed in nothing
Caption: to be
Caption: and again we don't know
Caption: so what happens when we run the test we
Caption: can see that it fails because i guess
Caption: unsurprisingly
Caption: our date function doesn't return two
Caption: question marks
Caption: and we can see that what it does return
Caption: is an empty string so now we can update
Caption: our test and say it returns an
Caption: empty string
Caption: and
Caption: the test and now the test passes
Caption: okay so then we can do that for our
Caption: other
Caption: scenarios
Caption: so the next one is going to be when we
Caption: pass in
Caption: uh date so the things that we can pass
Caption: into this function are sort of
Caption: determined by what you can pass into the
Caption: date constructor so it's going to be a
Caption: date a string or a number
Caption: so we can pass on a date
Caption: um again we don't know what it's going
Caption: to return
Caption: um we'll pass a new date when i'm doing
Caption: this kind of thing i like to use dates
Caption: that i like have all the numbers below
Caption: 10 so that we can see where the padding
Caption: is going to end up
Caption: and we can see that fails because it
Caption: returns this formatted string
Caption: so we can say it returns a formatted
Caption: date i guess
Caption: um cool so that's our date scenario and
Caption: then we have the strings
Caption: so when we pass in a
Caption: so with strings there's kind of three
Caption: scenarios that we can have here the
Caption: first is that we can have a valid date
Caption: string
Caption: which is just going to look like
Caption: our date and i'm just going to like go
Caption: out on a wild limb here and say that
Caption: this returns the same thing as the
Caption: previous one which it does
Caption: we can also pass in
Caption: a string that
Caption: looks like a date but isn't
Caption: so an invalid
Caption: pass in an invalid date string so that's
Caption: going to be something like
Caption: the
Caption: 31st of february
Caption: right so we don't know what that's going
Caption: to return
Caption: oops
Caption: um it turns out that it actually formats
Caption: the date for us and turns it into a
Caption: valid date so again it returns a
Caption: formatted date
Caption: um apparently the 31st of february is
Caption: just the 3rd of march
Caption: makes sense i guess
Caption: um the other thing that we can pass in
Caption: is a string that just isn't
Caption: a date at all so um it returns we don't
Caption: know
Caption: um and a thing that isn't a date
Caption: would be like say a banana that's a
Caption: completely different kind of fruit
Caption: and what's that going to return
Caption: it is going to return the string invalid
Caption: date
Caption: so we can stick that in
Caption: and we're going to expect it to be
Caption: invalid
Caption: excellent so that just leaves one more
Caption: scenario which is the case where we pass
Caption: in a number so again there's sort of
Caption: three
Caption: number scenarios to consider
Caption: so when we pass in a
Caption: number so when we pass a number to the
Caption: date constructor what we're passing in
Caption: is the number of milliseconds that have
Caption: passed since midnight on the first of
Caption: january 1970
Caption: because of course it is
Caption: um
Caption: so we can get that value just by pulling
Caption: get time on an on a valid date
Caption: oh no it didn't work
Caption: because you have to put
Caption: oh it has to be a new date you have to
Caption: put all of the things in right you have
Caption: to actually make it a date you can't
Caption: just call get time on a string doesn't
Caption: work
Caption: all right have all the brackets lined up
Caption: yes
Caption: okay so then the other two cases well
Caption: the first of the other two cases for a
Caption: number is if we pass in a negative
Caption: number
Caption: uh so in this case a negative number is
Caption: going to be one that was before the
Caption: first of january 1970
Caption: i don't know if anybody can imagine a
Caption: date that long ago but
Caption: so that's just going to format that's
Caption: the way that you would expect
Caption: this um this kind of testing really gets
Caption: you to exercise those copy and paste
Caption: skills it's
Caption: exactly what we've been training for
Caption: um cool and then the last case that i
Caption: always used to like to test with numbers
Caption: is the number
Caption: zero so when we pass in
Caption: zero
Caption: um
Caption: it's going to return i don't know it
Caption: could be anything
Caption: let's just pass in zero here
Caption: is the suspense really getting to
Caption: everyone yes
Caption: okay so this has failed and what it's
Caption: actually returned is an empty string
Caption: right so this is a bug in our code
Caption: and the reason that this bug is there is
Caption: because we've got this test right at the
Caption: start that says if the date is falsy
Caption: return empty string and zero is of
Caption: course a falsie value
Caption: and we could go ahead and fix this but
Caption: like i said we try not to do that when
Caption: we're refactoring so instead we're just
Caption: going to document the fact that it has
Caption: this odd behavior
Caption: in our test here and the reason that i
Caption: wouldn't fix this even though it would
Caption: be low risk um it's unlikely to break
Caption: anything if i fix it but there could be
Caption: people in our code base who are using
Caption: this function
Caption: and who have written some work around
Caption: code and their work around code isn't
Caption: going to make any sense once we fix the
Caption: bug so it would sort of just be you know
Caption: saving a bit of tech that if before we
Caption: fix this bug we go and check who else is
Caption: using it so we'll write up a jira card
Caption: stick it on the board someone else's
Caption: problem for later
Caption: all right so that's all of the tests
Caption: that i would write for this um we could
Caption: keep going right it's javascript so we
Caption: could write a test for what happens if
Caption: you're passing a boolean and the result
Caption: of that would actually be kind of
Caption: interesting because if we passed in
Caption: false or we get into empty string but if
Caption: we passed in true we'd get invalid date
Caption: um but i'm not going to do that for two
Caption: reasons first of all if this was
Caption: production code i just use typescript
Caption: the only reason i'm not using typescript
Caption: here is because it's real long and it
Caption: takes up too much space but yeah just
Caption: use typescript and the other reason is
Caption: that if if you're in your code base
Caption: you've got to the point where people are
Caption: passing booleans into date formatting
Caption: functions you've got bigger problems
Caption: um maybe
Caption: deal with those
Caption: okay so now finally we're ready to do
Caption: our
Caption: refactor um so like i said we're going
Caption: to use the date fns i feel like it's
Caption: pronounced date functions so
Caption: date fins
Caption: um
Caption: format from date fins
Caption: um we're going to replace moment with
Caption: that so date functions the format
Caption: function is going to take a date um just
Caption: like moment did and it's going to take a
Caption: formatting string as a second argument
Caption: but it's a slightly different library so
Caption: obviously it needs to use a slightly
Caption: different rendering formatting string
Caption: because it wouldn't be javascript if we
Caption: didn't
Caption: and we can see that all of our tests
Caption: have passed except for one and the one
Caption: that's failed is the invalid string
Caption: you can see that there it is actually
Caption: throwing an error rather than returning
Caption: a string this is i would argue that this
Caption: is actually better behavior but
Caption: like i said we're not trying to change
Caption: anything here we're just trying to keep
Caption: it all the same so we can just wrap this
Caption: in a try catch
Caption: and instead return
Caption: invalid date is it capital letter
Caption: we'll find out
Caption: no
Caption: okay so that's our refactor done now you
Caption: might ask
Caption: was this really worth the effort right
Caption: this is like eight tests or something
Caption: for four lines of code
Caption: and the answer to that is
Caption: um just like with everything else in
Caption: software development it depends
Caption: uh if this function was used by like one
Caption: component and we always knew what was
Caption: going to go into it no of course i
Caption: wouldn't write all these tests just
Caption: maybe write one
Caption: maybe cover it by the component test but
Caption: if this was like the formatting function
Caption: that's used across our entire code base
Caption: um so i made a change like this in a
Caption: real live code base recently and the the
Caption: function in question was used in over
Caption: 300 places
Caption: um so to me it's seven eight tests for
Caption: 300 usages that seems like pretty fair
Caption: um so yeah you're always going to have
Caption: to make that that call for yourself and
Caption: work out
Caption: just how many tests you need
Caption: okay so that's how characterization
Caption: tests work
Caption: um but the next question here is how do
Caption: we do this with jsx right jsx works a
Caption: bit differently
Caption: how is that going to work so imagine we
Caption: have this component here it's a user
Caption: info component it's going to take in
Caption: some user details
Caption: and it's going to print out the username
Caption: was born on and then the date formatted
Caption: using our format date function we just
Caption: refracted and also the day of the week
Caption: right so bob was born on the 1st of 1st
Caption: january 19th 8th 1990 um which was a
Caption: monday
Caption: okay so how does that work so we have
Caption: our function here
Caption: we can describe
Caption: user
Caption: info component
Caption: and we just say it
Caption: does something we don't know what
Caption: um so we can render the components
Caption: oh you got to put all the brackets in
Caption: and the user is going to have a name
Caption: and a birthday
Caption: which we can say is the 1st of january
Caption: 1990.
Caption: um okay so how can we test this well the
Caption: first thing that we can do is we can
Caption: grab a reference to the container
Caption: so the when we
Caption: render a component with test library it
Caption: gets rendered inside a div and this
Caption: container just points div
Caption: and then we can expect the text content
Caption: of that container to be something so we
Caption: can expect container
Caption: to have text content
Caption: and we don't know what it's going to be
Caption: so we can run our test
Caption: and just like with our standard
Caption: javascript
Caption: and the test will fail but it tells us
Caption: what to expect
Caption: so we can pop that in there
Caption: and we can say that it renders the user
Caption: details
Caption: okay so that works great um
Caption: so it works well in cases where you can
Caption: just expect the text content to be a
Caption: specific thing
Caption: um if you've got large complicated
Caption: components it can get a bit messy or if
Caption: you're expecting different kinds of
Caption: behavior this perhaps isn't going to be
Caption: an easy way to do things
Caption: um so the good news is we do have
Caption: another tool available to us
Caption: and that tool is snapshot tests
Caption: so snapshot tests if you're not familiar
Caption: with them and i'm guessing you are
Caption: because you seemed very happy about them
Caption: uh if you're not familiar with snapshot
Caption: tests the way that they work is that
Caption: when you first run your test uh it
Caption: generates a snapshot and a snapshot is
Caption: just a text representation of your
Caption: component
Caption: and then you go ahead and you make your
Caption: changes do whatever you need to do and
Caption: then when you run the test again it's
Caption: going to generate another snapshot and
Caption: it's going to compare the original one
Caption: with the new one and it's going to tell
Caption: you if they match or if they're
Caption: different
Caption: so let's try that
Caption: so here we can grab
Caption: the same test again
Caption: um and the test that we're doing now is
Caption: we're just going to say that it matches
Caption: the snapshot
Caption: that matches the snapshot
Caption: and then instead of testing whether it
Caption: has text content we can just say we can
Caption: expect it to match
Caption: snapshot
Caption: cool and now when we run this you see
Caption: the test passes you can see down the
Caption: bottom here one snapshot written
Caption: and we can see we've got this new folder
Caption: here called underscore underscore
Caption: snapshots underscore underscore
Caption: um and a
Caption: file that has the same name as our test
Caption: file with dot snap on the end
Caption: and in here you can see this is the text
Caption: representation of our component that's
Caption: been generated
Caption: if we jump back into our test and change
Caption: something so we say actually it turns
Caption: out bob was born on the second january
Caption: we rerun the test this time it fails it
Caption: says that the snapshot failed
Caption: um and it shows us what the difference
Caption: is right it was rendering the first now
Caption: it's rendering the second it was
Caption: rendering monday now it's rendering
Caption: tuesday now we know that that's actually
Caption: correct because we just changed value so
Caption: we can just hit u and update the
Caption: snapshot and now if we look at our
Caption: snapshot you can see it says tuesday
Caption: everything's happy our test is great we
Caption: know we haven't broken anything
Caption: all right cool so snapshot tests are
Caption: very handy for this kind of thing but
Caption: they do have some limitations
Caption: so the first is that you lose a lot of
Caption: clarity when you're using a snapshot
Caption: test so imagine that we have this
Caption: component called the increment that
Caption: we're testing we've got a snapshot test
Caption: on the left
Caption: um and all we do is we render the
Caption: component and then we
Caption: expect it to match the snapshot then we
Caption: click a button and we expect it to match
Caption: the snapshot but there's not really
Caption: information there about what's going on
Caption: whereas if we wrote a more traditional
Caption: kind of test what we get is we render
Caption: the components and then we expect it to
Caption: have the number four which just so
Caption: happens to be that same as that initial
Caption: number that we passed in so that's
Caption: probably a good hint that it's rendering
Caption: out the number we passed in
Caption: then we click the button and we expect
Caption: it to have five which is a good hint
Caption: that probably this component called
Caption: increment incremented the number that
Caption: um so there's just a lot more sort of
Caption: detail for the next person who's looking
Caption: at this component in a more traditional
Caption: test
Caption: which can you know have pros and cons
Caption: um also snapshots don't render all of
Caption: the information about the component that
Caption: you might expect them to
Caption: so
Caption: imagine this component this is called
Caption: clicky magic
Caption: clicking magic renders a text box onto
Caption: the screen when you click the text block
Caption: the checkbox it waits two seconds and
Caption: then it unchecks the checkbox
Caption: i can't imagine any situation where this
Caption: would be useful
Caption: but
Caption: i wrote a test for it anyway
Caption: so this test is using snapshots it's
Caption: going to use fake timers because we need
Caption: to handle that two second delay it's
Caption: going to render our components we're
Caption: going to check the checkbox
Caption: we're going to check that it matches the
Caption: snapshot then we're going to wait two
Caption: seconds and then we're going to check
Caption: that it matches the snapshot again and
Caption: this test will pass
Caption: and this test will pass even if we take
Caption: out the weight for two seconds
Caption: this test will pass even if we break the
Caption: component so that it does do anything
Caption: other than render a checkbox
Caption: and the reason for that is that the
Caption: snapshot that gets rendered looks like
Caption: this
Caption: right it just says that there's an input
Caption: with a checkbox we've got no information
Caption: about the state of the checkbox in there
Caption: so it's just something to be careful of
Caption: i've run into similar issues with
Caption: snapshot tests where people had written
Caption: the snapshot
Caption: but the component loaded everything
Caption: asynchronously so there were all these
Caption: tests but all they were was like this
Caption: empty component and
Caption: they weren't really testing anything so
Caption: just make sure that your snapshots do
Caption: contain the information that you need
Caption: them to
Caption: uh and the third limitation of snapshot
Caption: tests is that you can't do tdd with them
Caption: you might say i don't care i hate tdd
Caption: and that's fair enough
Caption: um or why do we care about tdd we're
Caption: refactoring at the moment and yes that's
Caption: true but we're refactoring remember
Caption: because we're intending to make change
Caption: and when we go to make that change the
Caption: snapshot tests aren't going to provide
Caption: us a good basis for those new feature
Caption: tests that we're going to write because
Caption: they do like that clarity that's not to
Caption: say that they don't have a place
Caption: but it's probably worth considering
Caption: whether you need other kinds of tests as
Caption: well
Caption: okay snapshot tests are really excellent
Caption: in two situations though
Caption: and the first is when you have those big
Caption: thousand line components and you don't
Caption: want to test every single thing that's
Caption: going on in there snapshot tests are
Caption: excellent for that
Caption: um and the other place i quite like them
Caption: is things that have got a lot of
Caption: presentation logic i don't know if
Caption: you've ever tried to write tests for a
Caption: table
Caption: but they're a mess they're brittle um
Caption: and they don't really have that good
Caption: information in them right so this is a
Caption: good use to just use a snapshot test
Caption: instead it's simpler
Caption: okay so that brings us to the example
Caption: part of the whole thing so we're going
Caption: to look at an app called the old farm
Caption: shop the older farmer shopper
Caption: the important thing to remember here is
Caption: that letter at the start isn't a y
Caption: it's a thorn and it's pronounced
Caption: so in english we used to have this
Caption: letter thorn then the dutch or whoever
Caption: it was came along with their printing
Caption: press and they were like we don't have
Caption: that letter you don't get to have it
Caption: anymore get rid of it
Caption: um and it sort of looks like a lot of
Caption: why so people started using the letter y
Caption: and then we ended up with this situation
Caption: but it is legitimately pronounced the
Caption: older farmer
Caption: it's important okay what does that look
Caption: like
Caption: this is our app we're selling farm
Caption: produce so you can buy plants
Caption: you can buy
Caption: seed packets or seedlings
Caption: and you can pick different numbers don't
Caption: buy zero that would be weird
Caption: um
Caption: and you're going to get
Caption: sort of the unit price in this little
Caption: label here
Caption: um a subtotal a postage cost and a total
Caption: and we're all good with that it's not
Caption: too complicated cool
Caption: we've got some new requirements so we
Caption: want to add a third product type so we
Caption: want to add a new radio button that says
Caption: plants
Caption: and we're going to show the unit price
Caption: and the total price for a plant and
Caption: we're going to calculate the postage for
Caption: a
Caption: plant um so it'll start looking like
Caption: this
Caption: now we could in theory implement these
Caption: requirements in the order that they were
Caption: given but we're not going to do that and
Caption: the reason for that is that if we
Caption: implement that radio button first
Caption: then we've got to do the whole thing in
Caption: one go right we can't we can't stop
Caption: halfway
Caption: whereas if we start with the label we
Caption: can just implement the change we need
Caption: for the label we could merge that in it
Caption: can go to production without the rest of
Caption: it and it'll be fine
Caption: um so it's sort of like a cheating
Caption: feature flag i guess
Caption: um you could argue that this is a very
Caption: small change and you could just do it
Caption: all in one go and you're absolutely
Caption: right but like we've got time limits on
Caption: this talk and i'm not confident that i'm
Caption: going to get through the whole thing so
Caption: we're just going to start with the label
Caption: all right
Caption: now
Caption: here is the component
Caption: that
Caption: renders this page
Caption: it's not
Caption: an amazing bit of work
Caption: but it's what we're working with
Caption: so the bit that we care about is this
Caption: label here except actually it's these
Caption: two labels here because we've just
Caption: repeated all this code
Caption: for both this is actually some
Caption: production code that's had its identity
Caption: changed to protect the innocent but this
Caption: this was real code in production
Caption: um so we don't want to write another
Caption: block like this right
Caption: um because we don't want to have more
Caption: repetitive code in there but also
Caption: because we can't write a test for
Caption: changing the label with the code all
Caption: glommed into one component like this
Caption: right we need to separate it out
Caption: so we're going to start by creating a
Caption: new label component that is separate to
Caption: everything else
Caption: before we do that though we're going to
Caption: write some component tests uh some
Caption: characterization tests
Caption: so
Caption: this is going to be the product
Caption: test
Caption: dot jsx do not accidentally write tsx
Caption: because yes code will be like oh it's a
Caption: type project like actually it's not
Caption: um and it'll lead to sadness
Caption: okay so we're gonna test our product
Caption: component now we've got four scenarios
Caption: that we need to test not seven or eight
Caption: like the last one this is four so that's
Caption: going to be when we've got seed packets
Caption: selected and we've got no amount entered
Caption: when we've got seed packets and an
Caption: amount when we've got seedlings and no
Caption: amount and seedlings and an amount it's
Caption: going to be a lot of copy and pasting i
Caption: promise
Caption: so when
Caption: seed
Caption: packets is selected and no amount
Caption: is entered
Caption: it's now this we've got a great big
Caption: component we only compare about care
Caption: about a small part of it this is an
Caption: excellent use for snapshot tests so it
Caption: matches the snapshot
Caption: all right so we need to grab a reference
Caption: to our container
Caption: screen.get
Caption: no not screen we want to render the
Caption: component first
Caption: um product
Caption: product which takes a
Caption: proper product we're going to do because
Caption: why not
Caption: um we need to import that
Caption: yep import it
Caption: yeah all right
Caption: okay
Caption: no not that one okay we got there no
Caption: thanks to uvs code
Caption: uh we want to grab a reference to that
Caption: radio button so that's gonna be seed
Caption: packets equals screened okay by roll
Caption: and the roll of a radio button is radio
Caption: nice and easy but there's a couple of
Caption: radio buttons on the screen so let's
Caption: pass it in a name as well
Caption: um and then you want to
Caption: click
Caption: that radio button
Caption: all right um we need to import screen as
Caption: well
Caption: and that's it then we can expect our
Caption: container
Caption: to match the snapshot
Caption: and we do that we get a snapshot
Caption: generated and everything is great
Caption: okay so then we've got our second
Caption: scenario
Caption: which looks a lot like the first one
Caption: um except an amount is entered
Caption: so we're going to grab a reference to
Caption: the
Caption: well i think it's called number or count
Caption: or something like i remember
Caption: um i'm going to do screen.get by roll
Caption: now this time the it's an input of type
Caption: number so as everybody knows the aria
Caption: rule for that is
Caption: yes spin button
Caption: there's only one on the screen so we
Caption: won't worry about a name
Caption: and we're going to pass in four say
Caption: all right now the snapshot written
Caption: excellent
Caption: then we just need to do the same thing
Caption: all over again but with the seedlings
Caption: so if we
Caption: when see links is selected and no
Caption: amounts then grab
Caption: seedlings i guess we should rename this
Caption: too
Caption: and when seedlings seed
Caption: lings is selected and an amounts this is
Caption: going to be seedlings
Caption: seed kings
Caption: and seedlings
Caption: all right we're going to run the
Caption: snapshots oh something failed
Caption: the name
Caption: the next one
Caption: this one
Caption: ah well spotted especially when it
Caption: wasn't on the screen
Caption: all right so we got all of our snapshots
Caption: written everything looks great except
Caption: actually we have this warning that's
Caption: being thrown
Caption: and if you've spent much time writing
Caption: test react you've probably seen this
Caption: morning before
Caption: this morning is a lie
Caption: it has nothing to do with anything being
Caption: wrapped in an act and it's very
Caption: misleading but important
Caption: so what's good what what causes this
Caption: warning is when the component state is
Caption: or the component state is updated after
Caption: the test has finished so in our case
Caption: we change the number
Caption: of things which changes
Caption: which cause this state which calls this
Caption: use effect which causes calculate
Caption: postage function
Caption: and when it's
Caption: seed
Caption: links and it's not zero it gets down to
Caption: this postage calculation which causes
Caption: asynchronous function so we call this
Caption: asynchronous function it goes off and
Caption: does its asynchronous thing then our
Caption: test finishes
Caption: then the asynchronous function returns
Caption: then the state is updated and then react
Caption: is like oh my god i'm going to tell you
Caption: lies about act
Caption: um so that's what's causing the warning
Caption: like it's a little a legitimate warning
Caption: it's just that it's not very helpfully
Caption: worded
Caption: um so the way that we can deal with that
Caption: is we can just kind of wait for
Caption: um
Caption: it not to be zero
Caption: so we look at the snapshot for instance
Caption: we can see
Caption: uh
Caption: let's see
Caption: postage
Caption: total note the next one
Caption: we can see that the seed no that seed
Caption: packets oh my god when ceilings are
Caption: selected and an amount that's the one
Caption: okay we can see the number is eight but
Caption: the postage is zero
Caption: so we can say
Caption: uh the postage equals
Caption: screen dot get by
Caption: text
Caption: um let's just do a quick regex because
Caption: nothing ever goes wrong when you do that
Caption: and then we can uh await
Caption: i wait for
Caption: um
Caption: and then expect
Caption: postage
Caption: but to have text content and i
Caption: whatever it's going to be we can just
Caption: run the test and see
Caption: oh you have to make it an async function
Caption: all the time
Caption: okay so we can see the postage is
Caption: actually 32
Caption: so we can change that
Caption: and this is a slightly hacky way of
Caption: doing this but you get get the idea so
Caption: now snapshots failed because instead of
Caption: zero dollars it's 32 instead of 32 the
Caption: total is now 64. that's what we were
Caption: expecting so let's update the snapshot
Caption: okay so now we've got our
Caption: characterization tests we can do our
Caption: refactor
Caption: now i'm just going to write the new
Caption: component sort of inside here because
Caption: it's going to make it easier to copy and
Caption: paste
Caption: um but in the real world you'd probably
Caption: put it in its own file and it could have
Caption: its own like independent life and be
Caption: happy
Caption: so we're just going to return the same
Caption: value we have here now in this case you
Caption: can see we've got two bits of text that
Caption: are essentially the same thing so rather
Caption: than having it all repeated
Caption: let's kind of parameterize it
Caption: so we can pull out those names and we
Caption: can say seed packets
Caption: is going to be
Caption: seed packets
Caption: and seedlings
Caption: is going to be seedlings
Caption: and we can get rid of all of
Caption: that and we can just say number of
Caption: uh names
Caption: product type
Caption: oh don't put a dollar sign there you're
Caption: out of control
Caption: um and again here instead of this being
Caption: seed packets it can just be
Caption: product type
Caption: um oh then we need to pass in product
Caption: type
Caption: and we need to pass in count
Caption: because we're using that here
Caption: and we just change this one more
Caption: product type
Caption: and then we get rid of all of that we
Caption: put one more closing bracket we wish
Caption: we'd set up prettier so that it
Caption: reformatted everything
Caption: um oh and it does doesn't do anything
Caption: okay so now we can replace all of this
Caption: with our new label component
Caption: which takes a product type
Caption: and account
Caption: and we run our snapshot tests again they
Caption: all fail but the only reason they fail
Caption: is that the the white space has changed
Caption: because we've added in all of those
Caption: interpolations
Caption: so we can just update that and it's fine
Caption: cool so this is looking pretty good
Caption: except there is one more little
Caption: dependency in here that's not super
Caption: obvious but this id on this input uh
Caption: needs to match
Caption: the html4 on this label
Caption: um and we like we need those two things
Caption: to be the same there's a couple of ways
Caption: we could deal with that we could just
Caption: hope
Caption: that no one changes it
Caption: uh we could pass the id into the label
Caption: um which could work but what i would
Caption: suggest that we do is we kind of accept
Caption: that these two this label and this input
Caption: are very tightly coupled and probably
Caption: the best thing to do is just to put them
Caption: all into the component together
Caption: so now instead of this being a label
Caption: component it's going to be a number
Caption: input component
Caption: and we're going to wrap it in div
Caption: get rid of that bracket
Caption: and paste all of that in
Caption: um and the closing div
Caption: oh don't you wish i'd installed prettier
Caption: okay so this is now just missing this
Caption: handle count change um how to handle
Caption: count change is kind of a weird name for
Caption: a prop so let's just call it on change
Caption: all right so now that's all good we can
Caption: go back up here we can change this to
Caption: our number input we can pass it the on
Caption: change
Caption: um and then we can get rid of all of
Caption: this
Caption: this is my
Caption: more favorite thing than refactoring is
Caption: deleting code
Caption: um and our snapshot test will pass so
Caption: that's all good everything
Caption: is great um and now we're actually ready
Caption: to write our feature
Caption: um except one small thing before i did
Caption: that like i said i don't like having
Caption: snapshot tests as the basis for my
Caption: feature tests um we could go with that
Caption: but what we have here is sort of
Caption: snapshot tests that cover the whole
Caption: product component we don't have any
Caption: tests that are specific
Caption: to our new number input component so i
Caption: would start by actually replicating our
Caption: snapshot tests into like a specific set
Caption: of tests for the number
Caption: the number input i'm not going to make
Caption: you watch me do that though
Caption: um i have a set of tests here already
Caption: um you can see they're the same
Caption: scenarios that we wrote before
Caption: for the two different types and the
Caption: amount and no amount and then one
Caption: additional test which checks that will
Caption: be on change handler because now that
Caption: these two things are separated out we
Caption: just need to test that integration is
Caption: working
Caption: um
Caption: now you might argue that this is a waste
Caption: of time we already had these tests i
Caption: don't need to do all this and i look i
Caption: don't know how busy you are but i did
Caption: time myself when i wrote this test
Caption: initially and it took four minutes
Caption: so it's like just gotta those copy and
Caption: paste fingers going fast
Caption: okay so now we've got these tests here
Caption: we're ready to write the test for our
Caption: new feature
Caption: which honestly is going to look just
Caption: like
Caption: the existing ones except we're going to
Caption: replace
Caption: everything with plants so when the
Caption: product type is plants
Caption: it's going to be plants
Caption: it's going to show the number of
Caption: plants
Caption: and plants as i'm sure you all remember
Caption: from the spec cost 15 each
Caption: and again we're going to make plants
Caption: we're going to have 12 of them we're
Caption: going to make plants
Caption: and 15 times 12 is of course
Caption: anyone no
Caption: 180 yeah
Caption: um we run those tests they fail because
Caption: we haven't written that code
Caption: but now when we actually go to write our
Caption: feature it's going to be
Caption: so easy
Caption: all we need to do is add plants to our
Caption: little names here
Caption: and then there's a little config file
Caption: here that has the prices in it and we
Caption: can add the plants here
Caption: and our tests will pass so how fast was
Caption: that after we did that refactoring so
Caption: this component is now super easy to
Caption: change super easy to work with
Caption: okay so what did we learn today some
Caption: important things we learned to think
Caption: about when we should refactor because
Caption: even though it's fun sometimes we maybe
Caption: shouldn't do it
Caption: we've learned how to write
Caption: characterization tests to ensure our
Caption: refractors are safe
Caption: um we've learned about snapshot tests
Caption: and how we can use those to write
Caption: refactoring tests and most importantly
Caption: of all we learned that this thing that
Caption: looks like actually pronounced the and
Caption: that's what a thorn sort of looks like
Caption: normally
Caption: all right i've been aaron zimmer if you
Caption: would like to see the co other slides
Caption: are available here
Caption: don't know why firefox hates rendering
Caption: the ps in this font but
Caption: some reason
Caption: the examples are up on github with a
Caption: completed example as well
Caption: and thank you all very much
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: [Music]
Caption: um
Caption: bye
Caption: [Music]
Caption: mark where are you mark open you turn
Caption: your camera on
Caption: um
Caption: okay you can you can see me yeah
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerds nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our pockets
Caption: this is like my dream come true i've
Caption: always wanted to join
Caption: someone's
Caption: what do you
Caption: want god
Caption: [Music]
Caption: let's go
Caption: we got a little problem
Caption: as you know our motto is you need a
Caption: professional bodyguard delivered to your
Caption: door in less than half an hour you've
Caption: got it buddy but without an app ain't no
Caption: bodyguard getting delivered nowhere so
Caption: where are we with that uh the app is
Caption: almost ready uh we just need
Caption: three
Caption: more days we need it asap
Caption: okay team what's the status on the app
Caption: we're good to go except our login
Caption: experience is a disaster
Caption: we need something to keep our users data
Caption: private
Caption: and to keep the hackers out
Caption: and it needs to work flawlessly because
Caption: because i don't want to lose one single
Caption: customer i hear you so let's use off
Caption: zero off what now off zero it's an
Caption: identity platform fast easy logins just
Caption: what the boss wants can we make our own
Caption: authentication service come on the
Caption: ultimate key master you know we don't
Caption: have that kind of time we need to
Caption: confirm identities with passwords
Caption: fingerprint scans whatever the users
Caption: like to use observer can do that yeah
Caption: but it needs to be secure we can't have
Caption: our app compromised by breaches not a
Caption: problem and it needs to scale if we get
Caption: hit with a ton of traffic and if it
Caption: stalls or freezes up i will get fired we
Caption: can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: could you guys stop that's really
Caption: distracting
Caption: we did it it's done already yep i think
Caption: our customers are gonna love it i got a
Caption: real app now folks
Caption: know what i want a bodyguard
Caption: hey we got a customer
Caption: cool app
Caption: my name's steven
Caption: what's up steven
Caption: we can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: goodbye
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: so
Caption: [Music]
Caption: bye
Caption: so
Caption: [Music]
Caption: mark where are you mark open you turn
Caption: your camera on uh
Caption: okay you can you can see me yeah
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerd's nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our pockets
Caption: this is like my dream come true i've
Caption: always wanted to join scott hanselman
Caption: what do you want
Caption: [Music]
Caption: ambition is a fearless hunger for
Caption: success it drives us to challenge the
Caption: way things are to pursue what seems
Caption: insurmountable to keep going when others
Caption: would stop ambition is how a global
Caption: manufacturer is using ai to empower
Caption: employees with disabilities ambition is
Caption: how a company managed an overnight
Caption: transition to remote work for 100 000
Caption: teammates ambition is how a children's
Caption: hospital built an app to reduce stress
Caption: for families ambition is how a law firm
Caption: rallied against a malware attack to
Caption: reclaim control and prevent a
Caption: devastating breach of client confidence
Caption: at insight we know the power of ambition
Caption: we've grown from a small technology
Caption: provider founded by two young brothers
Caption: to a fortune 500 company offering i.t
Caption: services and solutions for all
Caption: for more than 30 years people have
Caption: trusted us to turn ambitious projects
Caption: into meaningful outcomes
Caption: what will your ambitious story be
Caption: now is the time to do big things
Caption: together now is the time to be ambitious
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: my name is carol i'm a test engineer
Caption: my call sign is special case you might
Caption: be familiar with it you see it in cereal
Caption: boxes it's my call sign because i like
Caption: eating i eat a lot when people see me
Caption: they always see me eating and they
Caption: always ask me carol why are you eating
Caption: and
Caption: i think that just when they see when
Caption: they see the cereal box they say okay
Caption: that's carol
Caption: hi i'm joshini i'm a test engineer they
Caption: call me gesture because i always have a
Caption: smile on my face whatever situation i'm
Caption: in
Caption: my name is jaden i'm an automation
Caption: engineer here at planet my call sign is
Caption: digit because i'm a huge huge math nerd
Caption: it is it is it is my primary major um
Caption: but i often get called out
Caption: on how i never never ever ever stop
Caption: talking about maths
Caption: i just love maths
Caption: i am cassandra i am a test automation
Caption: especially
Caption: pink beret uh as you can tell by the
Caption: accent i am french very very permanent
Caption: accent
Caption: so the direct completely makes sense as
Caption: for the pink no matter the client no
Caption: matter where i was working it always was
Caption: a ping background with
Caption: hello kitty riding a unicorn
Caption: it does not reflect who i am outside
Caption: clearly but i think it brings a little
Caption: bit of
Caption: sparks and enjoy and so yeah so being
Caption: better it is
Caption: my name is kong i'm a consultant here at
Caption: planet it's when people ask me how to
Caption: pronounce my name i always say
Caption: i'm not the king but the kong
Caption: but after joining planet
Caption: i am the king and i'm the kong
Caption: work to inspire is very something that
Caption: we live by i believe we definitely see
Caption: how much passion we are for quality and
Caption: how much we want to convey this as a
Caption: client we don't just go for
Caption: target we always try to go a little bit
Caption: further and we try to inspire each other
Caption: by learning new skills having new
Caption: challenges and taking them and i think
Caption: it's very inspiring we better build
Caption: better personally i always try to be
Caption: better than yesterday
Caption: that's always been me so i'm better than
Caption: yesterday and i'll be better tomorrow i
Caption: also get a lot of training opportunities
Caption: and planning because there's a vast
Caption: library of training courses available
Caption: that i can just access anytime before i
Caption: join planet like when you want to learn
Caption: something google first right and then
Caption: when you google something you always
Caption: have to pay for something and that's not
Caption: that's not what i want to do so it's
Caption: really it's really good that planet
Caption: offers these free courses for me and i
Caption: don't have to feel pressured about
Caption: buying something just so i can improve
Caption: my skills and use them for work
Caption: planet always encourages learning and
Caption: learning is a good way to just
Caption: accelerate your career growth top-notch
Caption: testing is um it's awesome
Caption: it's it's
Caption: really cool to be around people who are
Caption: so passionate so driven
Caption: to do what they do
Caption: and who always want to want to learn and
Caption: get better um i think that's really
Caption: important and i think it's going to be a
Caption: driving factor
Caption: going forward in in the it industry in
Caption: general
Caption: top one is the best of the best and for
Caption: me it's
Caption: uh if you want to grow up in your
Caption: carrier you are at the right place
Caption: because we have got all the training
Caption: materials right people and write
Caption: opportunities yeah whatever you need to
Caption: progress in your career you have got
Caption: everything in here
Caption: to boost your experience and boost your
Caption: personality everything
Caption: in a compact pack that's what planet is
Caption: for me
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: good night
Caption: [Music]
Caption: hi
Caption: foreign
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what mark where are you mark open you
Caption: turn your camera on
Caption: um
Caption: okay you can you can see me yeah
Caption: yeah we can see you
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my
Caption: this is office nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our poses
Caption: like my dream come true i've always
Caption: wanted to join scott hanselman's
Caption: what do you want
Caption: [Music]
Caption: tell me the best thing that's happened
Caption: while i was gone i made your dad ate
Caption: healthy like you said he even tried the
Caption: broccoli eat it
Caption: then i helped him make his work much
Caption: better
Caption: and we found the perfect outfit to wear
Caption: to my party
Caption: but i really needed to wind down before
Caption: bed so i turned my hand into a starfish
Caption: my best thing is you being back
Caption: [Music]
Caption: by applying market leading technology
Caption: solutions through our lifecycle services
Caption: we help clients realize business
Caption: outcomes through our advice integration
Caption: and operational services
Caption: moq digital helps clients to fully
Caption: understand their it needs adopt the
Caption: right solution and provide ongoing
Caption: support to maximize their investment
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: hi
Caption: [Music]
Caption: hey good morning welcome back everyone
Caption: to jacqueline nagar uh
Caption: we have up next a
Caption: speaker
Caption: who is going to be running us through
Caption: inclusive storytelling with dynamic data
Caption: loren lagassic is the head of technology
Caption: at intopia a microsoft mvp in
Caption: accessibility and a community manager of
Caption: tech leading ladies australia
Caption: she specialises in building full stack
Caption: applications with accessibility and
Caption: inclusion at front of mind she's an
Caption: international conference speaker and a
Caption: guest university lecturer on digital
Caption: accessibility and software architecture
Caption: she's one of the core members of the
Caption: dart of his alley group formed in 2020
Caption: and her and other accessibility
Caption: advocates and experts came together
Caption: virtually to solve for a lack of
Caption: resources and guidance for mating garter
Caption: visualization inclusive of people with
Caption: various disabilities with the goal of
Caption: raising awareness and providing
Caption: guidelines and solutions
Caption: please welcome lauren to the stage today
Caption: thank you so much
Caption: thank you so much david thank you
Caption: everyone for coming
Caption: i hope you're having a wonderful day so
Caption: far
Caption: um
Caption: so hi yes my name is loren legassic uh
Caption: it's so wonderful to be here in perth uh
Caption: i usually live and work in miangian or
Caption: also known as brisbane uh and they are
Caption: the it is the home of the terrible and
Caption: the younger peoples
Caption: um
Caption: and i pay my respects to their elders
Caption: past and present as well as those of the
Caption: noongar peoples of majorco perth and all
Caption: the elders of communities of anyone
Caption: traveling here or watching online today
Caption: uh my
Caption: notes are not synced up to my slides but
Caption: thank you so much to uh to all the
Caption: amazing sponsors of ddd perth and as
Caption: well as the organizers and the other
Caption: speakers and of course everyone uh
Caption: coming along to hang out it is a huge
Caption: huge pleasure to be here um
Caption: okay
Caption: so
Caption: a little bit about me
Caption: oh it is synced up uh sorry i had a bit
Caption: of a family emergency this morning so
Caption: i'm a bit bit scattered at the moment so
Caption: please forgive me if i seem a little bit
Caption: unprepared
Caption: um a little bit about me i am a software
Caption: engineer and i work at a company called
Caption: intopia as david mentioned we had
Caption: digital accessibility consultancy
Caption: if you end up enjoying this talk
Caption: and would like to talk about
Caption: accessibility
Caption: at work all day please also consider
Caption: checking out checking out our work with
Caption: us page we are hiring it is very scary
Caption: but we'd love to work with you i think
Caption: julie's in the room as well hey julie uh
Caption: please feel free to come chat to one of
Caption: us if uh if you are interested in
Caption: hearing more about working accessibility
Caption: um
Caption: so
Caption: my name is pronounced loren um it's a
Caption: tough one my parents were not kind when
Caption: they chose my name i am not at all
Caption: french even though my name is fully
Caption: french
Caption: i'm half chinese and half australian my
Caption: pronouns are she and her and my twitter
Caption: handle is loren lg
Caption: and i already went through that bit so
Caption: um
Caption: and something related to the talk that
Caption: i'm giving today is a lot of the content
Caption: has come from an article that i've been
Caption: writing uh for a non-for-profit company
Caption: on database um that is coming out in
Caption: december i'm very excited to share it
Caption: with you all
Caption: um
Caption: so a bit of the story behind this talk
Caption: uh
Caption: so in the before times february 2020 uh
Caption: i did a talk at the brisbane data
Caption: science meetup one of my favorites hi
Caption: enrique if you're watching online um
Caption: and i also gave a version of this talk
Caption: with kind of a speed
Caption: chart redesign
Caption: uh
Caption: that is on youtube as well at a
Caption: conference called data edge bytes you
Caption: might have heard of it
Caption: really really cool conference also not
Caption: for profit and community run
Caption: um
Caption: and i admit uh i i did give it give a
Caption: talk on uh inclusive presentations uh at
Caption: uh fenders on wednesday um
Caption: those talks were uh not the most not the
Caption: most accessible talk so i'm always
Caption: learning along the way
Caption: um and uh so
Caption: um
Caption: i won't be covering a whole lot of very
Caption: in-depth kind of accessibility data vis
Caption: basics today
Caption: but if you want to kind of learn more
Caption: and find out kind of the details please
Caption: i've got a bunch of resources at the end
Caption: um
Caption: that
Caption: that you can go and have a look at if if
Caption: this is interesting to you and helpful
Caption: to you
Caption: um
Caption: so the talk that i did the meet up in
Caption: brisbane was called inclusive
Caption: storytelling with data and it only
Caption: focused on static charts or images of
Caption: charts so i didn't talk about the
Caption: interaction at all and i made a big
Caption: promise that i would do a follow-up one
Caption: about dynamic charts and here i am two
Caption: years later
Caption: and so this is a bit of a reprise of
Caption: that talk and i'm very very excited
Caption: uh
Caption: i think i have internet but um
Caption: so
Caption: uh the big kind of trigger for this
Caption: topic and the big light bulb moment for
Caption: me was reading a book called
Caption: storytelling with data um
Caption: by cole nassbaumer netflix
Caption: amazing amazing
Caption: database
Caption: expert who worked at google um and ended
Caption: up
Caption: her whole job being teaching people how
Caption: to communicate better with data at
Caption: google um
Caption: and i really really recommend reading
Caption: that book before anything else uh really
Caption: a really awesome book on the kind of
Caption: basics of design
Caption: and data communication
Caption: and
Caption: [Music]
Caption: if you want to make accessible data
Caption: visualizations as that book will mention
Caption: you do need to learn a little bit about
Caption: design
Caption: a well-designed data visualization is
Caption: easy to interpret and understand and
Caption: good design takes into the account
Caption: it takes into account the needs of users
Caption: and some of those users will have
Caption: disabilities
Caption: and
Caption: so accessible design is inclusive design
Caption: and inclusive design is the key to good
Caption: design uh where it considers not only
Caption: disability but language culture gender
Caption: age and other forms of human difference
Caption: if you haven't heard of inclusive design
Caption: before
Caption: there's a
Caption: very often uh very very popular diagram
Caption: that i've got on the screen at the
Caption: moment
Caption: about inclusive design from microsoft
Caption: you may have seen it before or you may
Caption: have known of it before so it's a table
Caption: with three column and four rows
Caption: and the columns
Caption: refer to examples of permanent temporary
Caption: and situational disability
Caption: uh and the rows refer to sensors such as
Caption: uh human senses such as motor vision
Caption: hearing and speech
Caption: so an example in the in the diagram is a
Caption: permanent motor disability is maybe an
Caption: amputee with a missing arm
Caption: and while a temporary motor disability
Caption: is having a broken arm and a situational
Caption: disability is perhaps a parent carrying
Caption: a newborn
Caption: um and you can come up with your own
Caption: examples for the others uh the goal of
Caption: this graphic is to illustrate that if
Caption: disability is viewed as a mismatch
Caption: between a person that disability's views
Caption: can be viewed as a mismatch between a
Caption: person and their environment the
Caption: environment is actually just disabling
Caption: the person
Caption: and designing for disability actually
Caption: benefits everybody
Caption: so to design a chart accessibly
Caption: accessibly will help your database be
Caption: understood by more and more people um if
Caption: you want to learn more about inclusive
Caption: design please please do check out
Caption: microsoft's
Caption: inclusive design toolkit and i believe
Caption: they are also a sponsor of ddd perth
Caption: so uh
Caption: one thing i do want to note um and a
Caption: common misconception if you are new to
Caption: accessibility is accessibility is not
Caption: one size fits all it's not trying to
Caption: kind of craft uh everyone to go through
Caption: the same
Caption: ui flow
Caption: it is providing multiple pathways that
Caption: not every user might kind of take
Caption: so an example is
Caption: um uh brain freeze um so for for the
Caption: example of data visualizations uh
Caption: folks might prefer that visual folks
Caption: might prefer to look at a chart um or a
Caption: data visualization and maybe people who
Caption: prefer uh looking at the data and
Caption: understanding the data would prefer to
Caption: have a table presented to them instead
Caption: so that they can do their own analysis
Caption: on the data um so that is a that is an
Caption: example of being flexible and providing
Caption: multiple pathways for the same outcome
Caption: you want people to understand or to
Caption: consume your data
Caption: and so
Caption: one of the big
Caption: problems is that
Caption: and and the reason for kind of kicking
Caption: off this
Caption: talk and this uh
Caption: kind of meetup group in data
Caption: visualization is there's not a whole lot
Caption: of resources out there to
Caption: uh or there wasn't there is now actually
Caption: um
Caption: to learn how to make the interactive
Caption: dynamic database accessible and what i
Caption: mean by that is
Caption: most data visualizations
Caption: able to be accessed using a mouse
Caption: and
Caption: and for sighted folks but if it when it
Caption: comes down to people who cannot use a
Caption: mouse they only use the keyboard maybe
Caption: or people who use screen readers
Caption: they
Caption: are not able to look at the data at all
Caption: and so i have a video from
Caption: a
Caption: a talk kind of on a 101 data
Caption: visualization just to show an example
Caption: and hopefully it plays
Caption: of what it is like for a screen reader
Caption: user to access a an inaccessible chart
Caption: so
Caption: um a lot of this blew up because uh
Caption: when when kind of covered
Caption: began it was also the u.s election and
Caption: so there was an incredible amount of
Caption: data visualization and especially kind
Caption: of um the advancements and also data
Caption: visualization libraries kind of anybody
Caption: could kind of put together a um
Caption: a really shiny looking data
Caption: visualization
Caption: or something that's super interactive
Caption: and super cool which they were but
Caption: unfortunately
Caption: they weren't the best experience for
Caption: everyone
Caption: on internet
Caption: something else that's more technical is
Caption: making it work for a screen reader
Caption: screen reader such as for example
Caption: voiceover for mac
Caption: they will read what's displayed on the
Caption: page and unless you're using a database
Caption: library that already puts a lot of focus
Caption: in screen reader accessibility you will
Caption: have to do quite a bit of technical work
Caption: there yourself
Caption: let's take a look at an example
Caption: this is from fox news
Caption: during the elections they had a page
Caption: that live updated as the electoral
Caption: college votes given
Caption: and the progress bar underneath
Caption: would show
Caption: how many votes from each states each of
Caption: the candidates had gathered already and
Caption: how close they were to getting the 270
Caption: that they needed to win
Caption: however
Caption: let's listen to what it's like for a
Caption: screen reader
Caption: joe biden image 306 joe biden cam allah
Caption: harris donald trump image 232 donald
Caption: trump mike pence one votes one votes 20
Caption: votes four votes two votes eleven votes
Caption: ten votes ten votes sixteen votes six
Caption: votes fourteen votes four votes five
Caption: votes 29 votes four votes seven votes
Caption: twenty votes three votes thirteen votes
Caption: twelve votes ten votes eleven votes nine
Caption: votes fifty-five votes seven votes three
Caption: votes
Caption: i think you get the idea that goes on
Caption: for another five minutes so i'm not
Caption: going to
Caption: keep that one playing
Caption: oops
Caption: oh
Caption: apologies
Caption: okay
Caption: um so
Caption: as you could probably hear uh that was
Caption: not
Caption: a terribly good experience for screen
Caption: reader users uh it it was even kind of
Caption: lucky that that particular uh data
Caption: visualization or that website actually
Caption: had some labels on the data so that you
Caption: could hear votes votes votes how many
Caption: votes
Caption: often it's just image image image image
Caption: image or something else
Caption: so
Caption: how do we make an accessible html chart
Caption: so luckily in the last few years
Caption: one particular company has made it
Caption: really really easy
Caption: so
Caption: the
Caption: the advice that i have is
Caption: use the high charts javascript charting
Caption: library and add a couple of
Caption: accessibility modules that they include
Caption: in there and that's it that's the end of
Caption: my talk
Caption: but jokes aside unless you have a really
Caption: really giant development team
Caption: you probably don't want to be writing
Caption: your own database library
Caption: unless you really need to
Caption: especially if you want to make it
Caption: accessible it is quite easy to kind of
Caption: get it to the mouse hover point
Caption: where you can have tool tips showing on
Caption: mouse hover
Caption: but there is quite a bit more work to do
Caption: after that
Caption: um
Caption: and high charts isn't the only library
Caption: out there but is one of the most fully
Caption: featured and best developer experiences
Caption: i found other libraries that you may
Caption: have heard of such as am charts
Caption: couldn't quite
Caption: work out as easily how to get the
Caption: accessibility module going in that
Caption: and
Caption: so a few years ago i built a dynamic
Caption: chart when i worked for a logging
Caption: company so on the screen i have
Caption: a
Caption: column chart there and this chart is to
Caption: show effective log retention how
Caption: effective log retention policies are
Caption: um uh on keeping kind of disk space to a
Caption: maintainable level um
Caption: so uh it was a column chart that ended
Caption: up being at least keyboard accessible um
Caption: and uh this was kind of working with the
Caption: knowledge i i had at the time i was
Caption: still learning and still trying to
Caption: understand what makes an accessible data
Caption: visualization
Caption: a dynamic one
Caption: and i had a really good crack at making
Caption: it screen reader accessible
Caption: but it was probably a horrendous
Caption: experience for them
Caption: similar to kind of the
Caption: video that i just played and
Caption: unfortunately it wasn't tested with real
Caption: users which
Caption: is really really important and and
Caption: absolutely
Caption: must must do uh so on the screen as a
Caption: thing most of you all of you cannot see
Caption: because it's tiny font um
Caption: is
Caption: the accessibility tree of the chart that
Caption: i just displayed and
Caption: um i actually can't even read it
Caption: and what i'm trying to demonstrate in
Caption: this screenshot is um that i added aria
Caption: labels to each of those bars or each of
Caption: those columns
Caption: and it was really repetitive the first
Caption: the first part of the a
Caption: label was the same for every single
Caption: bar and so for a screen reader user
Caption: who's trying to cycle through
Caption: all of the data in the chart uh they
Caption: will just hear the same first five words
Caption: for the um
Caption: for the chart and then only the uh
Caption: only the numbers changed at the very end
Caption: of the sentence so uh past me was trying
Caption: to be descriptive
Caption: and but unfortunately it made it a quite
Caption: a bad experience so that's one example
Caption: of why it's so important to test with
Caption: actual screen reader users
Caption: um
Caption: apologies if the internet is going to
Caption: load um
Caption: so alternatively so i did that in d3.js
Caption: um i've completely forgotten how to use
Caption: d3.js and it keeps happening every time
Caption: d3js is like a library that helps you
Caption: build svgs uh
Caption: easier um
Caption: so alternatively a bunch of research
Caption: user testing has gone into the high
Caption: charts products and uh the head of
Caption: accessibility and another um co-worker
Caption: of his actually joined the database
Caption: accessibility group that we virtually
Caption: met up with once a month and they were
Caption: so cool so i'm a huge fan um
Caption: and so they've done
Caption: a bunch of work so that you don't have
Caption: to so if you're not already sold on
Caption: using high charts it's really
Caption: customizable they haven't paid me for
Caption: this
Caption: it's just they've made it really really
Caption: easy and nice experience and and it's
Caption: pretty accessible still do usability
Caption: testing
Caption: so
Caption: you do still have to do some
Caption: configuration but you don't have to
Caption: build it from scratch
Caption: all right so let's make a graph
Caption: but
Caption: first i wanted to talk to you
Caption: quickly just just through
Caption: graphs that are images just to start off
Caption: with
Caption: and then we'll move on into html charts
Caption: so on the screen i have an image of a
Caption: line graph
Caption: there's three lines three data series or
Caption: three lines on it
Caption: you might be able to see that there's
Caption: jaws nvda and voiceover so we're talking
Caption: about three different types of screen
Caption: readers and
Caption: there's a y-axis and an x-axis axis and
Caption: you're probably already picking up that
Caption: there are a few things missing from this
Caption: chart if you are into data
Caption: um
Caption: so um
Caption: there are a few steps to kind of begin
Caption: with to make the chart accessible
Caption: so a little quick checklist of checks
Caption: that we can do for a static image which
Caption: also kind of carry on to dynamic charts
Caption: or html charts so we've got to get these
Caption: ones right first and then we can make it
Caption: interactive
Caption: so
Caption: i've kind of split it into three
Caption: three different categories the first
Caption: test is content
Caption: and i usually do this first because uh
Caption: thinking about the content and how to
Caption: make the content accessible and uh cole
Caption: talks a lot about this in the
Caption: storytelling we've done a book you might
Caption: end up changing the chart completely and
Caption: you don't want to kind of work on all
Caption: the other accessibility parts of the
Caption: chart
Caption: and then end up changing the chart and
Caption: then having to go through and
Caption: work through all the rest of the visual
Caption: and non-visual accessibility needs of
Caption: the chart after that
Caption: um
Caption: so making sure that there's a title
Caption: uh a descriptive title even and axes are
Caption: labeled appropriately and uh one thing
Caption: uh is number formatting making it a nice
Caption: experience putting commas making sure
Caption: units are correct uh making the chart uh
Caption: and reducing the cognitive load for
Caption: anyone looking or
Caption: inspecting the chart
Caption: the next test after that is visual
Caption: testing so uh the things that probably
Caption: we're all
Caption: kind of think of first when we think of
Caption: accessibility of charts is contrast
Caption: making sure the contrast is okay meets
Caption: um
Caption: the kind of uh usual requirements
Caption: if you're familiar with wikag or the web
Caption: content accessibility guidelines um but
Caption: in in summary just has to kind of not be
Caption: bright yellow or a really light pastel
Caption: and
Caption: making sure that we're not relying
Caption: solely on color or giving the option to
Caption: be able to you know add patterns to the
Caption: chart
Caption: that's that alternative pathways again
Caption: if someone can use color then um
Caption: that's that's fine but making sure that
Caption: we provide the other the other
Caption: alternative
Caption: um and and a font is a big one is to
Caption: making sure that the font is legible not
Caption: using like very fancy arty fonts sans
Caption: serif or the uh the ariel or helvetica
Caption: or anything that doesn't have the little
Caption: extra bits on on parts of the font um
Caption: uh
Caption: more accessible to folks who may have
Caption: dyslexia
Caption: um
Caption: and uh and uh finally non-visual making
Caption: sure that the
Caption: uh chart has alternative text or an
Caption: image description um you might be
Caption: familiar with this in html is adding the
Caption: alt tag on the image element
Caption: so
Caption: um
Caption: writing uh so one of the hardest bits is
Caption: writing alt text for charts
Caption: but someone in the database community
Caption: has written an
Caption: incredibly awesome article on just
Caption: giving a simple template to be able to
Caption: just take this template fill in what you
Caption: need and that's a really really good
Caption: description of an image of a chart
Caption: and
Caption: usually folks are including images on
Caption: charts to complement an article that
Caption: might be um to support some sort of
Caption: factual point that they are making in
Caption: that article and the chart is not really
Caption: something that people are actually using
Caption: to kind of explore or get data from
Caption: so describing what the chart is and
Caption: something that is really really
Caption: important is making sure to have a link
Caption: to the data source that alternative
Caption: pathways again so a download to a csv
Caption: file or maybe a html table on another
Caption: page
Caption: so that
Caption: if a person is not able to
Caption: pass the
Caption: visual chart they can go and
Caption: inspect the data themselves
Caption: if they would like
Caption: so
Caption: even if you have an interactive chart uh
Caption: if you're not quite sure how to make it
Caption: accessible with all the keyboard and all
Caption: the javascript and
Caption: all the screen reader stuff what you can
Caption: do is kind of wrap this chart wrap the
Caption: chart in an image
Caption: um
Caption: image roll and give it
Caption: alt text and then make sure that you
Caption: have that uh absolutely make sure that
Caption: you have that um link to the data so
Caption: that they can download it or inspect it
Caption: in a table so that's that's a great
Caption: start if
Caption: you're not quite sure how to how to make
Caption: it
Caption: accessible in terms of screen readers
Caption: and things
Caption: all right and my favorite reminder is if
Caption: you are tweeting
Caption: and you're not aware that you can add
Caption: alternative texts to your dvd perth
Caption: tweets
Caption: um i
Caption: don't quite remember how to do it
Caption: but i think when you take a photo
Caption: there's a little alt button somewhere on
Caption: your phone and you can click on that and
Caption: you can
Caption: describe your image as well
Caption: so
Caption: you may have seen that twitter has also
Caption: brought out
Caption: the alt button feature so that you can
Caption: inspect other people's alt text uh so if
Caption: you are new to writing alt text it is
Caption: actually not that easy it takes a bit of
Caption: practice um
Caption: you can kind of cheat and look at what
Caption: other people are describing the images
Caption: as um on twitter without having to you
Caption: know switch on your screen reader um and
Caption: and try to inspect the image that way
Caption: all right back to database so
Caption: how to make accessible html charts
Caption: um
Caption: so what if we can't make do with an
Caption: image
Caption: so for example most people
Caption: here probably have
Caption: a banking or other finance app this is
Caption: the example that we're going to go with
Caption: it's quite
Caption: quite a simple one
Caption: so
Caption: have you ever thought about what the
Caption: html or javascript might be behind those
Caption: charts and i know combank uh
Caption: i actually haven't tested it but i'm
Caption: pretty sure combank's
Caption: kind of
Caption: income outcome that's not the right
Caption: words
Caption: incoming and outgoing expenses are quite
Caption: accessible yeah
Caption: and uh
Caption: um so
Caption: oh sorry um
Caption: yeah have you ever thought about like
Caption: what what is the html that is behind
Caption: those charts
Caption: uh
Caption: but first usually uh
Caption: we have a table of data whether or not
Caption: it's in excel or it's made possibly in a
Caption: json uh
Caption: payload that's coming back from some
Caption: service um you we usually have some data
Caption: in some sort of kind of tabular format
Caption: and
Caption: which is handy you should keep this
Caption: around
Caption: and now is actually a good time to ask
Caption: with this table of data
Caption: do we really need a chart for this
Caption: or can we just leave it as a table and
Caption: like that's that's pretty good
Caption: these are not real numbers or anything i
Caption: just made them up
Caption: so if the answer is yes then all you
Caption: need to do is make sure that the html
Caption: table is is accessible
Caption: and voila a accessible dynamic data
Caption: visualization
Caption: so on the screen i have
Caption: a table of data with um
Caption: two headers of incoming and outgoing um
Caption: and uh three rows of the months of july
Caption: august and september
Caption: and uh some dollar figures um in there
Caption: and so let's have a look at how
Caption: to code this successfully
Caption: oh that is very small
Caption: um
Caption: so i'll try to talk through it as best
Caption: that i can
Caption: so
Caption: just some things to remember is uh so
Caption: [Music]
Caption: oh firstly the um
Caption: the quickest way is to head to the wai
Caption: w3c site and have a look at the tables
Caption: tutorial has excellent every type of
Caption: table you can think of like where you
Caption: have like a header row and a header
Caption: column or you just have a header row or
Caption: you have some random
Caption: headers
Caption: here there and everywhere
Caption: but
Caption: the the one thing that i've noticed
Caption: folks forget the most is making sure to
Caption: add scope
Caption: um to use th when when uh a cell is a
Caption: header
Caption: um and using scope equals coal if the
Caption: header is along the top and it's
Caption: referring to the column
Caption: and
Caption: referring to scope equal and adding
Caption: scope equals row
Caption: when a cell is a th in the the header of
Caption: a row so this is a table with a row
Caption: header and a column header and column
Caption: headers
Caption: um
Caption: and
Caption: a little bit of kind of extra extra
Caption: niceties to make numbers easier to read
Caption: in this table we've also
Caption: added a class to make sure that we right
Caption: align the numbers because it is uh been
Caption: known and researched that it's easier to
Caption: read numbers that are that are right
Caption: aligned
Caption: um and have commas and and all that good
Caption: ux stuff
Caption: all right so
Caption: onto a
Caption: dynamic data visualize the data
Caption: visualization
Caption: so
Caption: we decided no we don't want a table we
Caption: want to go a little bit fancier uh so on
Caption: the screen i have an interactive chart
Caption: and um
Caption: you wouldn't know it but it's not
Caption: actually interactive yet
Caption: so what i've got is a link before the
Caption: chart and a link after the chart
Caption: i think julie is cringing because i
Caption: forgot to put underlines in the css to
Caption: show that they are links apologies and
Caption: i've got a big chart in the middle that
Caption: is a column chart that
Caption: is the chart uh chart representation of
Caption: the data uh that we just had in the
Caption: table on the previous slide and so i
Caption: will uh firstly do start off with using
Caption: keyboard to test
Caption: so hopefully
Caption: i can
Caption: the focus styles will come up
Caption: they will not
Caption: maybe if i get out of full screen mode
Caption: escape
Caption: all right
Caption: oh the focus styles are very faint
Caption: that is not great i'm going to switch to
Caption: chrome apologies
Caption: uh we will need safari later to test
Caption: with the screen reader and i will switch
Caption: to chrome
Caption: okay
Caption: and we're back and hopefully
Caption: there we go uh hopefully those that can
Caption: see the screen can see the focus outline
Caption: on the first link before the chart
Caption: and we are expecting to be able to tab
Caption: into the chart and kind of interact with
Caption: it so
Caption: uh if we hover over it with our mouse we
Caption: can see oh fantastic there's some uh
Caption: really cool kind of uh it fades out the
Caption: other data and and and fades in the data
Caption: that you are looking at all the columns
Caption: that you're looking at and there's
Caption: little tiny tooltips that you probably
Caption: can't read from back there
Caption: but they are
Caption: tooltips that have all the information
Caption: so that if you were someone who might
Caption: use screen magnification if you are
Caption: zoomed right into that tool tip you have
Caption: all the information that you need and
Caption: you don't need to kind of
Caption: scroll across to the axes to to kind of
Caption: guess what this uh what the what the
Caption: y-axis and the x-axis categories are so
Caption: everything you need is in that tooltip
Caption: which is great
Caption: and uh and we can uh click on the legend
Caption: to toggle on and off that's a nice
Caption: feature
Caption: um straight out of high charts uh
Caption: everything you ever wanted in uh data
Caption: visualization
Caption: um
Caption: so
Caption: let's try and see so i can't use a mouse
Caption: let's say uh let's try and interact with
Caption: that chart
Caption: oh
Caption: uh it skipped to the link straight under
Caption: the chart there is no way that i can
Caption: get to that chart the focus outline is
Caption: going up and down up and down so how do
Caption: we fix that uh so unfortunately um high
Caption: charts does not uh out of the box
Caption: um give you the accessibility straight
Caption: away uh i really wish that it did
Caption: so
Caption: i will add it uh i'm using a framework
Caption: called reveal.js for the slides um
Caption: and so i can just add that module
Caption: in the code that i've preferred earlier
Caption: um
Caption: so i will
Caption: you don't need to pay too much attention
Caption: to us i will just
Caption: uncomment out some javascript modules to
Caption: show
Caption: how few steps it is so i'm uncommenting
Caption: out i actually only need to uncomment
Caption: out one line of uh javascript modules
Caption: but i've added the other two so that i
Caption: can talk through them at the same time
Caption: as well
Caption: um all right
Caption: so i should probably save it
Caption: uh
Caption: and i'm back into safari i want to go
Caption: into
Caption: chrome
Caption: main chrome yes i'll do a refresh
Caption: all right uh
Caption: you may or may not have noticed
Caption: something change on the screen uh if you
Caption: didn't there's a little menu on the top
Caption: right hand corner now i'll talk about
Caption: that later but let's see if it's
Caption: keyboard accessible oh my goodness so we
Caption: are in so i've just tabbed from the link
Caption: before the chart into the chart and it's
Caption: focused on the first column
Caption: that is the incoming
Caption: the monthly income for july 2022
Caption: and if i press tab again it focuses on
Caption: the legend which has incoming as a light
Caption: blue kind of color and outgoing as a
Caption: very dark gray color and if i tab one
Caption: more time it focuses me to the menu
Caption: hamburger icon on the top
Caption: and then one last time uh to the link
Caption: after the chart
Caption: and so uh notice that um so i'm just
Caption: pressing tab and
Caption: um it doesn't actually take me through
Caption: each individual data point because if
Caption: there were a lot of those that would
Caption: take a person a very long time to tab
Caption: all the way through
Caption: um and uh and get to kind of the rest of
Caption: the article if they don't really care
Caption: about the chart
Caption: all the rest of the app
Caption: um
Caption: so
Caption: what they have added in here and
Caption: um this is all quite new and not really
Caption: uh
Caption: as several libraries have kind of done
Caption: different things there's also another
Caption: awesome accessible accessible chart
Caption: library from visa called the visa chart
Caption: components library i think
Caption: and so they have different kind of
Caption: keyboard behaviors
Caption: but i really really like the high charts
Caption: one it's really simple and um
Caption: and uh so
Caption: i've kind of used that one as a
Caption: reference if i was to build my own again
Caption: and when i built that one
Caption: way back when
Caption: so the way to get to different data
Caption: series is using the
Caption: data points is using the arrow key so
Caption: i've just hit right arrow it's gone to
Caption: the next
Caption: column of the same data series or
Caption: incoming
Caption: monthly
Caption: income i don't know why what word i'm
Caption: looking for um
Caption: and then
Caption: uh hitting right right arrow again is
Caption: focused on the third
Caption: column um
Caption: and so how do i get to the
Caption: next data series or the outgoings uh i
Caption: hit right arrow again just then and it
Caption: focused on the outgoing and if i keep
Caption: hitting the right arrow and the left
Caption: arrow i can go between all of those
Caption: columns
Caption: but i can also switch between series by
Caption: pressing up and down arrow so that's a
Caption: really really nice
Caption: kind of behavior that high charts has
Caption: come up with
Caption: i'm sure talking with lots of folks in
Caption: the accessibility and the disability
Caption: community
Caption: um
Caption: all right
Caption: so same thing with the legend i can
Caption: change between each
Caption: so i've just tabbed the legend using
Caption: left and right arrow to kind of switch
Caption: between toggling them on and off
Caption: and going to the button
Caption: i can press the space bar
Caption: or press enter
Caption: um i can press the space bar
Caption: and i use the arrow keys to scroll
Caption: through the menu but drop down uh menu
Caption: accessibility is a whole nother talk
Caption: but basically you can press space or
Caption: enter and escape to
Caption: get out of the slides not the menu
Caption: so
Caption: and there's a bunch of options that they
Caption: added in here in here in particular
Caption: being able to export the data in a
Caption: format that you like so they have csv
Caption: they have excel they have a viewer data
Caption: table which um
Caption: uh will actually show a data table i
Caption: can't show it in the presentation
Caption: because
Caption: it conflicts too much with the css of
Caption: the reveal js but i do have a code pen
Caption: if we get time at the end
Caption: but
Caption: a lot of
Caption: really awesome options so really really
Caption: fully featured
Caption: data visualization library
Caption: okay
Caption: so the screen reader experience
Caption: let's have a look at that
Caption: live screen reader demos are not my
Caption: forte let's see how this goes oh i gotta
Caption: swap this
Caption: application safari
Caption: safari inclusive storytelling with
Caption: dynamic data window inclusive
Caption: storytelling with dynamic data where
Caption: content has keyboard focus is that okay
Caption: yep
Caption: all right
Caption: uh so if i press tab
Caption: okay and then i'm going to press uh
Caption: control option and use the arrow keys
Caption: and so this is a common misconception uh
Caption: is that there is such a thing called a
Caption: virtual cursor for screen reader for
Caption: screen readers if you um are not
Caption: so familiar with screen readers so it
Caption: doesn't actually
Caption: send any focus or hover or or anything
Caption: to the chart itself so you won't see
Caption: the same
Caption: um focus
Caption: styles happening when i navigate around
Caption: using the screen reader
Caption: and that is the reason why it doesn't
Caption: send any sort of
Caption: actions to the chart and it relies
Caption: solely on having the correct aria rolls
Caption: or the semantic html in the back to
Caption: but you will see the
Caption: square blocks if you can see
Caption: the square box of where this virtual
Caption: cursor is so you can get a bit of an
Caption: idea of what's going on um and you will
Caption: notice that there is a lot more to this
Caption: chart when we navigate it with a screen
Caption: reader
Caption: okay so pressing right arrow monthly
Caption: income and expenses q1 2022 to 2024
Caption: image created with high chances one zero
Caption: two one bling the link up monthly and
Caption: common expenses q1 202 to 2024 image i
Caption: haven't refreshed reload page including
Caption: after adding modules
Caption: let's try that again all right august
Caption: 2022 1009 show incoming selected toggle
Caption: button list two items oops you are
Caption: currently on the table button displaying
Caption: something for the chart apologies i'll
Caption: just get back to the start all right
Caption: monthly income and expenses q one twenty
Caption: twenty two to twenty two twenty four
Caption: hundreds interrupted chart region
Caption: region it's now an interactive chart
Caption: with a roll of region
Caption: heading level three monthly income and
Caption: expenses
Caption: it's got a heading level three so uh
Caption: screen reader users often use headings
Caption: to as a shortcut to navigate to stuff on
Caption: the page uh so having a heading in there
Caption: is is nice
Caption: shot with two data series you are
Caption: currently on a text element
Caption: hitting level three monthly income and
Caption: experience with two data series so it
Caption: says bar chart with two data series
Caption: so it's describing the anatomy of the
Caption: charts which i think is really cool um
Caption: and super helpful um table monthly
Caption: income and expenses
Caption: to 2024 collapsed button you are
Caption: currently on a button
Caption: and uh it's going through some of the
Caption: options that might be preferable for a
Caption: screen reader user the chart has one
Caption: capital x axis displaying categories you
Caption: are currently on a text element the
Caption: chart has one y axis displaying amount
Caption: data ranges from 382 to 2310 you're
Caption: currently on a text element i'm just
Caption: going to move the uh transcript into
Caption: this screen so um as it might be a bit
Caption: tough to hear
Caption: july 2022 1293 australian dollars in
Caption: august 2022 1 120 australian dollars
Caption: incoming september 2022 1200 image you
Caption: end up incoming last series without
Caption: going last year is two of two three bars
Caption: july 2022 382 australian dollars august
Caption: 2022 to september 2022
Caption: so notice that the focus styles on the
Caption: charts uh the the data series don't
Caption: change august 2022 1 128 australian
Caption: dollars coming in september 2022 image
Caption: the end of incoming basketball going
Caption: last series two of two three july 2022
Caption: 382 australian dollars outgoing image
Caption: august 7. chart credits pictures.com
Caption: group you are currently in groups chat
Caption: credits heartships.com clickable end off
Caption: chart credits pictures.com group and off
Caption: interactive chart group created with
Caption: high chats one zero two one total series
Caption: visibility monthly income and expenses
Caption: q1 2022 to 2024 region you would list
Caption: two items ended list end of total series
Caption: visibility monthly income and expenses
Caption: new chart menu monthly end of
Caption: interactive chart end off monthly income
Caption: and playing the link after the chart
Caption: um so that is uh all the extra
Caption: kind of screen reader only accessible
Caption: content that is added to make sure that
Caption: the experience is
Caption: equivalent for those who may not be able
Caption: to see the chart as uh to those who are
Caption: able to see the chart
Caption: all right
Caption: so
Caption: f5 button voiceover off i'm going to
Caption: turn that one off and go back to chrome
Caption: okay so uh quickly to to kind of wrap up
Caption: um just speaking through kind of what's
Caption: under the hood of what's made this
Caption: accessible
Caption: and i do recommend to take the time to
Caption: kind of look at what's going on if you
Caption: do try out high charts inspect the dom
Caption: turn on the accessibility tree it's in
Caption: your developer tools you can google how
Caption: to turn on the accessibility tree in
Caption: either chrome or
Caption: uh
Caption: or firefox or whatever whatever browser
Caption: you use um if you understand the
Caption: accessibility tree um super helpful um
Caption: but uh in in kind of the the
Caption: step by step firstly using javascript to
Caption: add um mouse and keyboard interactivity
Caption: uh it is something that you have to
Caption: deliberately do extra um not for high
Caption: charts it's what's being done in high
Caption: charts um but if you were doing it
Caption: yourself and adding aria to the parts of
Caption: the svg to give it meaning so
Caption: for example and
Caption: we might have missed that with the demo
Caption: just now uh hijaz has actually marked up
Caption: the columns
Caption: as images
Caption: and then added an aria label to those
Caption: images
Caption: as it kind of represents what it is it
Caption: is an image on a screen
Caption: and then adding that non-visual content
Caption: to describe the chart for the screen
Caption: reader user
Caption: and it's also great for seo
Caption: and
Caption: and last but not least back to the start
Caption: of the talk when we're talking about
Caption: just working on accessibility for an
Caption: image of a chart don't forget about the
Caption: content and visual accessibility as well
Caption: um so that applies for both interactive
Caption: charts
Caption: um keyboard navigation is tabbing to the
Caption: main bits um so don't make them tab
Caption: through absolutely every data point
Caption: arrow keys between the data points or
Caption: space or enter for buttons
Caption: and for a screen reader front load the
Caption: info give them um
Caption: give screen reader users uh kind of as
Caption: much info as possible that they can pick
Caption: through
Caption: and but also make sure you give them the
Caption: choice to kind of skip all of that so
Caption: make sure you have your headings
Caption: on
Caption: or even a skip chart button is something
Caption: that we've used before as well
Caption: and don't get too creative with arya
Caption: the first rule of aria is don't use arya
Caption: a few accessibility folks
Caption: familiar with that um please
Caption: use the high charts or other frameworks
Caption: that have tested with real folks as a
Caption: reference
Caption: and if you do roll your own and i've
Caption: spelt roll wrong on the screen uh
Caption: please make sure you engage usability
Caption: testing with screen reader users and and
Caption: other assistive technology users
Caption: all right a note on color
Caption: this is a big one and i've
Caption: left it to kind of a little tiny gap
Caption: don't use color alone to differentiate
Caption: data or differentiate different data
Caption: series
Caption: so there's
Caption: lots of talks about using patterns
Caption: you can use different shape markers and
Caption: different patterns and stuff like that
Caption: but
Caption: high trust has also done research on
Caption: this and they say to use monochrome
Caption: palettes if possible and so this helps
Caption: everyone not just kind of red cream
Caption: color blind folks
Caption: and it's also got cool kind of
Caption: side effects like you can print tactile
Caption: charts if you make sure that you use a
Caption: monochrome palette
Caption: um
Caption: and also be careful with patterns they
Caption: can make it worse so
Caption: and um i i haven't noticed that myself
Caption: so don't just go stick a pattern on it
Caption: done um have a little take a little bit
Caption: time to think about it
Caption: all right and i have a whole bunch of
Caption: resources on there um
Caption: chartability i highly recommend it is
Caption: like a cag for charts or or a checklist
Caption: of tests that is really deep and really
Caption: really useful for charts
Caption: and accessibility of database but i will
Caption: go back to the first slide with the link
Caption: to the slides
Caption: so that you can go and find those and
Caption: click on them
Caption: thank you so much
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: [Music]
Caption: all right
Caption: so
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: mark where are you mark open you turn
Caption: your camera on um
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerds nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our poses
Caption: this is like my dream come true i've
Caption: always wanted to join scott hanselman
Caption: what do you want
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: [Music]
Caption: we got a little problem
Caption: as you know our motto is you need a
Caption: professional bodyguard delivered to your
Caption: door in less than half an hour you've
Caption: got it buddy but without an app ain't no
Caption: bodyguard getting delivered nowhere so
Caption: where are we with that uh the app is
Caption: almost ready uh we just need
Caption: three
Caption: more days we need it asap
Caption: okay team what's the status on the app
Caption: we're good to go except our login
Caption: experience is a disaster
Caption: we need something to keep our users data
Caption: private
Caption: to keep the hackers out
Caption: and it needs to work flawlessly because
Caption: because i don't want to lose one single
Caption: customer i hear you so let's use off
Caption: zero off what now off zero it's an
Caption: identity platform fast easy logins just
Caption: what the boss wants can we make our own
Caption: authentication service come on the
Caption: ultimate key master you know we don't
Caption: have that kind of time we need to
Caption: confirm identities with passwords
Caption: fingerprint scans whatever the users
Caption: like to use observer can do that yeah
Caption: but it needs to be secure we can't have
Caption: our app compromised by breaches not a
Caption: problem and it needs to scale if we get
Caption: hit with a ton of traffic and if it
Caption: stalls or freezes up i will get fired we
Caption: can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: could you guys stop that's really
Caption: distracting
Caption: we did it it's done already yep i think
Caption: our customers are gonna love it we got a
Caption: real app now folks
Caption: you know what i want a bodyguard
Caption: hey we got a customer
Caption: cool app
Caption: my name's steven
Caption: what's up steven we can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: bye
Caption: pretty much officially filled out
Caption: jakarta nagal
Caption: here today
Caption: next up
Caption: i'm pleased to introduce todd becker
Caption: who will be talking
Caption: about distributed databases why what and
Caption: how so please make him welcome
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: thanks hi i'm todd
Caption: i'm a principal software engineer at
Caption: family zone which is a local perth-based
Caption: company in the field of cyber safety for
Caption: children
Caption: and so first i'd like to thank the
Caption: sponsors of dg perth 2022 i'm grateful
Caption: to be up here to speak to you today
Caption: i'm going to be talking about
Caption: distributed databases
Caption: and first a distributed database refers
Caption: to a database that just uses more than
Caption: one network computer or a cluster of
Caption: computers
Caption: this allows them to scale up to handle
Caption: more work and more data than a single
Caption: computer can do
Caption: but why why talk about this well
Caption: the amount of data that's been collected
Caption: and managed has grown immensely over the
Caption: past couple of decades the rise of the
Caption: internet and the proliferation of
Caption: devices in that time has driven the
Caption: development of more advanced software to
Caption: handle that data
Caption: but as tech professionals we don't often
Caption: need to actually use this kind of
Caption: database system and the majority of
Caption: software just works well with a
Caption: traditional relational database
Caption: but if we do use a distributed database
Caption: we may not truly understand how it works
Caption: or what its strengths and weaknesses are
Caption: and how to use it most effectively
Caption: so distributed databases however are a
Caption: vast and complex subject and my short
Caption: talk can only barely skim the surface my
Caption: aim is to give you a little
Caption: understanding of some of the concepts
Caption: which may help evaluate a distributed
Caption: database for solving your problem
Caption: relational databases have been around
Caption: since the mid-1970s
Caption: and this model has proven incredibly
Caption: flexible and useful for solving any
Caption: number of problems and in my opinion
Caption: this tech has been a cornerstone of why
Caption: software now runs much of the world
Caption: a crucial feature of these databases
Caption: isn't apparent in the name and that's
Caption: acid transactions
Caption: i won't go through the full definitions
Caption: right now but to paraphrase these
Caption: properties provide guarantees on the
Caption: correctness and reliability of your data
Caption: and they prevent transactions from
Caption: interfering with each other
Caption: structured query language or sql was
Caption: also invented at the end of the 1970s to
Caption: make good use of relational databases
Caption: and still very popular today
Caption: so these dbs dominated the landscape for
Caption: 40 years and are still prevalent today
Caption: however towards the turn of the century
Caption: people started to find that they were
Caption: needing more and more powerful systems
Caption: they were reading sorry they were
Caption: reaching the limit of how much computing
Caption: power they could throw at any particular
Caption: data set
Caption: but data was still being produced at an
Caption: increasing rate
Caption: so some vendors did produce large
Caption: specialized computers like mainframes
Caption: but they're extremely expensive and they
Caption: require that big upfront investment for
Caption: your peak capacity
Caption: but some of the big companies that we
Caption: know today like google and amazon were
Caption: just just starting to experience their
Caption: rise so they needed to find ways to
Caption: scale up in a big way to cope with their
Caption: new demand
Caption: they didn't want to use expensive
Caption: specialized hardware if they were going
Caption: to scale they would need to do it with
Caption: the commodity hardware that was readily
Caption: available
Caption: so as the saying goes necessity is the
Caption: mother of invention
Caption: and the needs of these first internet
Caption: scale companies led to innovation in
Caption: this area and new systems were built
Caption: that could share the load across many
Caption: computers
Caption: so a wave of new databases appeared to
Caption: help solve the problem
Caption: in 2006 and 2007 google published the
Caption: big table paper and amazon published the
Caption: dynamo paper
Caption: and these seminal papers seeded the
Caption: generation of new systems that were
Caption: inspired by them
Caption: and they were pushing the boundaries of
Caption: what was possible at the time
Caption: most importantly they were very scalable
Caption: they all had some things in common they
Caption: didn't use sql for reading and writing
Caption: data and they didn't use the relational
Caption: model at all
Caption: there were lots of different approaches
Caption: to modeling the data
Caption: each originally targeted at solving a
Caption: specific problem
Caption: so for example key value databases graph
Caption: wide column and document etc
Caption: the era of the purpose-built data store
Caption: had begun
Caption: choose to suit your specific need rather
Caption: than a one-size-fits-all approach
Caption: the data modeling is denormalized and
Caption: flexible some were optimized for very
Caption: right-heavy workloads some are optimized
Caption: for read heavy workloads
Caption: and this shift away from the relational
Caption: model and from sql led to the term nosql
Caption: being coined to emphasize that they're
Caption: not in sql or not only sql systems
Caption: but they had real limitations as well
Caption: they didn't support asset transactions
Caption: generally and they did not replace
Caption: relational databases and some of the
Caption: reasons for that why i'll cover
Caption: computer scientists were a little ahead
Caption: of this need so in 1999 eric bureau
Caption: published the cap principle which became
Caption: the cap theorem and i mentioned it
Caption: because the cap theorem has heavily
Caption: influenced the design
Caption: of many distributed data stores since
Caption: that time
Caption: it says that any distributed data store
Caption: can only provide two of the following
Caption: three guarantees consistency
Caption: availability and partition tolerance
Caption: now consistency we're familiar with from
Caption: asset transactions
Caption: partition tolerance and availability are
Caption: concepts that only exist in distributed
Caption: systems with multiple separate computers
Caption: a cp system is one that gives up
Caption: availability to guarantee consistency if
Caption: you write value a
Caption: all subsequent reads will read value a
Caption: if there's network problem
Caption: it may prevent you from writing or
Caption: writing data that if it might cause
Caption: problems later
Caption: an ap system is one that gives up
Caption: consistency to be available you'll
Caption: always get an answer even if the data
Caption: could be stale
Caption: and if there's a network problem it'll
Caption: accept your rights and reads even if
Caption: there's a chance for it to be lost later
Caption: or even
Caption: stale
Caption: theoretically a ca system would give up
Caption: neither but it's generally considered
Caption: infeasible
Caption: this way of thinking became the de facto
Caption: way to categorize these distributed
Caption: databases because it answers the
Caption: important question if something starts
Caption: to fail can i rely on the database to
Caption: say consistent no matter what
Caption: or can i rely on the database to stay
Caption: available as much as it can
Caption: before distributed databases people are
Caption: already dealing with scale problems with
Caption: the concept of partitioning which you
Caption: may have heard of partitioning is the
Caption: name for just splitting up a data set
Caption: into smaller subsets or pieces
Caption: and this is for improved performance or
Caption: easier management of the data
Caption: for petitioning to work there needs to
Caption: be a way of deciding where a particular
Caption: piece of data belongs and this is
Caption: usually done by taking a key from your
Caption: data
Caption: and this is called the partition key and
Caption: the choice of partition key can be
Caption: crucial in determining the performance
Caption: of your workload
Caption: partitioning using a time field is a
Caption: good choice for data sets to continually
Caption: grow over time
Caption: by petitioning for the range of time
Caption: means that one partition can't grow
Caption: forever and if you need to prune off the
Caption: oldest times you can just drop the
Caption: oldest partitions
Caption: but for petitioning a regular string key
Caption: and imagine in this example that your
Caption: keys only start with the 26 letters of
Caption: the english alphabet if you wanted to
Caption: split this into three partitions you
Caption: could just simply take a to g for
Caption: partition one
Caption: h to p for partition two and q to z for
Caption: partition three
Caption: hash partitioning is another common type
Caption: where a hash function's used applied to
Caption: the key and the result is used to work
Caption: out what partition to use
Caption: this is similar to how hash table works
Caption: which you've probably come across but
Caption: good hash functions are excellent at
Caption: spreading your keys across out across
Caption: any range even if you have keys that are
Caption: very similar which might not have worked
Caption: in the alphabetical example for a
Caption: distributed database to spread the load
Caption: across multiple computers clearly you
Caption: need to spread the data across these
Caption: computers or nodes as well
Caption: if each node had a full copy of the data
Caption: it would limit the size of your database
Caption: somewhat defeating the purpose so what
Caption: makes sense is to divide the divider
Caption: sorry is to divide the data up
Caption: and share it across those multiple
Caption: computers
Caption: this sounds like partitioning well it is
Caption: there's also another name for this
Caption: sharding
Caption: they're often used interchangeably but
Caption: strictly sharding is partitioning data
Caption: across multiple computers or multiple
Caption: database instances
Caption: a common sharding technique is known as
Caption: consistent hashing
Caption: and this type of hash partitioning
Caption: is designed to avoid an awkward scaling
Caption: problem
Caption: if you take this simple approach with
Caption: the formula on screen
Caption: if we want to add a new node or remove a
Caption: node
Caption: the shard count in this formula changes
Caption: and what that means though is that most
Caption: of the keys now go to a different chart
Caption: number it means your data needs to be
Caption: moved from many nodes to many other
Caption: nodes essentially you can't scale up or
Caption: down
Caption: way back in 1997 akamai technologies
Caption: invented consistent hashing
Caption: so what it does differently is that it
Caption: instead assigns each node an equal range
Caption: of that hash space and this is
Caption: visualized as being distributed around
Caption: the outside of a ring which is where the
Caption: term hash ring comes from
Caption: you can imagine that each node is inside
Caption: an equal piece of the pi
Caption: and the output of the hash function is
Caption: mapped onto the ring and this maps it to
Caption: a node
Caption: the major advantage that this approach
Caption: has is that if a node is added or
Caption: removed then far less the data needs to
Caption: be moved between the nodes just the
Caption: overlapping sections of your ring
Caption: and this overhead is relatively low and
Caption: manageable
Caption: the process of moving this data around
Caption: is usually called rebalancing and this
Caption: is an important thing for a database to
Caption: do if it wants to allow scaling up or
Caption: down without rebuilding the database and
Caption: while data is being moved the db might
Caption: need to reroute requests internally
Caption: until the rebalance is complete
Caption: in a distributed data system there's
Caption: often several copies of the data on
Caption: multiple nodes as well to guard against
Caption: losing one of them
Caption: this gives the benefit of redundancy but
Caption: plus higher availability should one of
Caption: the copies become unavailable
Caption: because this this also reduces the need
Caption: for ultra expensive reliable hardware
Caption: because failures do happen anyway so if
Caption: they're embraced and handled this is a
Caption: win for reliability and cost
Caption: okay we've talked a bit about how data
Caption: is logically distributed but how do the
Caption: nodes actually know what's going on
Caption: elsewhere in the cluster and what what
Caption: makes them a team
Caption: they might need to know where a piece of
Caption: data belongs who's responsible for it
Caption: who else has a copy
Caption: are the other nodes healthy failing shut
Caption: down
Caption: there's been a node added or removed how
Caption: does it learn of all this
Caption: this needs to be shared and this can't
Caption: always be configured upfront and never
Caption: change
Caption: so i'm going to talk about two
Caption: techniques that are used for this
Caption: if you can tolerate a slight delay
Caption: before all of your nodes are in sync say
Caption: less than 10 seconds
Caption: then a common approach is to use a
Caption: gossip protocol
Caption: a gossip protocol is sometimes also
Caption: called an epidemic protocol
Caption: because it's similar to the way the
Caption: epidemic's spread
Caption: when a node receives a new piece of
Caption: gossip it randomly picks one or more
Caption: other nodes to pass it onto
Caption: and this piece of gossip spreads until
Caption: all of the nodes have it
Caption: this can happen surprisingly quickly and
Caption: large clusters can converge in seconds
Caption: why bother with this trouble though
Caption: can we just tell all of the other nodes
Caption: directly or maybe our network supports a
Caption: broadcast
Caption: the problem with that is that it doesn't
Caption: scale very well as the number of nodes
Caption: increases the amount of network traffic
Caption: goes up exponentially until the system
Caption: collapses
Caption: so gossip protocol instead keeps the
Caption: overhead on the network and each node to
Caption: a pretty constant level even for very
Caption: large clusters you just sacrifice a
Caption: little time
Caption: but you might also think why can't they
Caption: just be a coordinator or a leader and
Caption: the nodes stay in sync with this leader
Caption: absolutely that works very well for
Caption: mostly smaller clusters and there are
Caption: plenty of distributed databases out
Caption: there that operate with this model
Caption: but we've introduced a weakness what
Caption: happens when the leader becomes
Caption: unavailable
Caption: the system can't share any new
Caption: information until that's resolved
Caption: okay let's make the coordinators
Caption: redundant have three of them
Caption: but
Caption: how do they stay in perfect sync and how
Caption: do they decide on a leader so we've come
Caption: up against the problem of distributed
Caption: consensus
Caption: so one way to decide on something is to
Caption: have a simple vote a simple majority is
Caption: enough to decide on the outcome but
Caption: computers and networks can fail at any
Caption: moment and this can skew the voting
Caption: it's a pretty fundamental need to be
Caption: sure of what has happened in your system
Caption: in 1990 leslie lampert first wrote a
Caption: paper describing the paxos algorithm
Caption: which is the seminal work on distributed
Caption: consensus
Caption: but it turned out to be hard to
Caption: implement and hard to understand and
Caption: left a lot to be solved by developers so
Caption: much later in 2013 the raft algorithm
Caption: was published
Caption: it's based on paxos but but easier to
Caption: understand and to to work with and so
Caption: it's been popular since then
Caption: so consistency in a distributed system
Caption: needs global agreement on changes
Caption: but how does it work if instead we chose
Caption: to give up strong consistency to be
Caption: available
Caption: we can't just let changes be lost can we
Caption: so instead practical systems are instead
Caption: what's called eventually consistent
Caption: this means that the different nodes in
Caption: this system asynchronously replicate
Caption: data to each other and then converge on
Caption: one just just one value for any piece of
Caption: data
Caption: in the meantime it's sometimes possible
Caption: to read a value that's out of date
Caption: a new value has been written somewhere
Caption: else in the system but it's not yet
Caption: visible to me but if i wait it will
Caption: arrive
Caption: but how long is eventually
Caption: of course the answer is it depends
Caption: it's milliseconds or often seconds but
Caption: it could be hours when recovering from
Caption: complex failures
Caption: there also needs to be a way to decide
Caption: how to convert these conflicting changes
Caption: into one result
Caption: the simplest approach is just last
Caption: writer wins
Caption: and this is a common choice in
Caption: eventually consistent systems because
Caption: you just compare the time stamps and
Caption: take the latest one and discard the
Caption: others
Caption: it's intuitive enough but for it to be
Caption: practical it depends on servers having
Caption: fairly synchronized clocks
Caption: algorithms exist to detect conflicts
Caption: like logical clocks or vector clocks
Caption: but they don't automatically resolve
Caption: these conflicts necessarily and so a lot
Caption: of ap systems design decided not to use
Caption: them
Caption: the reality is often never as simple as
Caption: a choice between these two opposites
Caption: and this is true of cap the cp versus ap
Caption: trade-off is more of a spectrum and
Caption: databases exist somewhere in there
Caption: a very important real-world factor
Caption: that's missing from cap theorem is l for
Caption: latency
Caption: however how quick it is to read or write
Caption: your data is often very important
Caption: unfortunately there's a fundamental
Caption: trade-off between consistency
Caption: availability and latency
Caption: a big motivation for building these
Caption: database systems to begin with was scale
Caption: and performance
Caption: amazon designed dynamo to serve its
Caption: shopping cart
Caption: google built bigtable to serve and store
Caption: web search maps etc facebook built
Caption: cassandra to power its inbox search
Caption: linkedin and yahoo have similar examples
Caption: these systems needed scalability and
Caption: performance and this is a big part of
Caption: why they were ap systems
Caption: the potential trade-off you make as we
Caption: discussed is the chance of reading
Caption: inconsistent data
Caption: this may be a non-issue when your data
Caption: doesn't change much these systems will
Caption: be a great fit for collecting mostly
Caption: immutable data like telemetry events
Caption: messages
Caption: and they're also great for use cases
Caption: where you're okay with the occasional
Caption: glitch
Caption: i'm sure that on the rare occasion an
Caption: item has just mysteriously disappeared
Caption: from someone's amazon shopping cart
Caption: has this hurt amazon's reputation or
Caption: profits no
Caption: and not every business who made this
Caption: trade-off feels the same way though uber
Caption: is one example that i'll talk about
Caption: surely
Caption: after a while working with these
Caption: databases people were starting to
Caption: realize the cap theorem while
Caption: technically true and insightful wasn't
Caption: really nuanced enough for them
Caption: it's only an algorithmic property it
Caption: doesn't guarantee that ap systems are
Caption: actually up all the time
Caption: so the other other ways to think about
Caption: it
Caption: so rick houlihan introduced this tasty
Caption: concept called the pie theorem
Caption: you can choose two of these three
Caption: desirable properties of your data store
Caption: pattern flexibility infinite scale and
Caption: efficiency
Caption: and we called it the iron triangle of
Caption: purpose
Caption: so for some examples a relational
Caption: database is a pe system it's very
Caption: flexible to query it's usually quite
Caption: efficient but it definitely has a
Caption: scaling cap
Caption: a nosql database is an ie system
Caption: typically because it scales very well
Caption: it's got great efficiency but you can't
Caption: produce you can't do flexible queries
Caption: that you haven't planned for to begin
Caption: with
Caption: a queryable data lake might be an ip
Caption: system huge scale low efficiency
Caption: so when you next need to choose a data
Caption: store you should consider this model as
Caption: well
Caption: in addition people some people learnt
Caption: the hard way that eventually consistent
Caption: systems could be more troubled than
Caption: their worth for instance google
Caption: published this and i'll paraphrase it's
Caption: hard to build bug-free systems
Caption: when the database doesn't guarantee
Caption: consistency
Caption: the dynamodb offered by aws has the
Caption: option of strong consistency within a
Caption: region
Caption: azure's cosmos db has the option of
Caption: strong consistency google's three main
Caption: databases for internal and external use
Caption: they all offer some form of consistent
Caption: strong consistency
Caption: some no sql data stores have since been
Caption: extended or even custom built
Caption: to support full asset transactions
Caption: for example
Caption: apple open source foundation db which is
Caption: a highly scalable nosql database that
Caption: supports full asset transactions
Caption: and it powers apple's cloud kit service
Caption: and snowflake uses it to store their
Caption: metadata
Caption: research continued in big tech as well
Caption: as academia and a new generation of
Caption: databases has emerged in the recent
Caption: decade
Caption: and these have been dubbed new sql
Caption: it's a play on nosql but it represents
Caption: that they're a new generation of sql
Caption: databases they can provide much higher
Caption: scalability and availability
Caption: without giving up the advantages of a
Caption: relational database
Caption: and this was seeded again by more papers
Caption: released by google f1 and spanner
Caption: this was novel and it
Caption: inspired the creation of a number of
Caption: similar databases
Caption: some of these are cockroachdb thaidb and
Caption: gigabyte db
Caption: so i mentioned a little startup you
Caption: might have heard of earlier uber
Caption: uber handles billions of transactions
Caption: per day now on their core order tracking
Caption: system if you've ordered an uber or an
Caption: ubereats it's probably been through
Caption: there
Caption: and this was originally built on the
Caption: cassandra database and they embraced
Caption: eventual consistency in this system in
Caption: order to get the scale they needed
Caption: however they were still frustrated by
Caption: occasional consistency problems
Caption: and the complexity that's added to their
Caption: code
Caption: they've publicly talked about this and
Caption: how they've done a full rewrite now to
Caption: move to a consistent store
Caption: and they're using google cloud spanner
Caption: as the primary db
Caption: as more examples netflix have blogged
Caption: about how they're making use of
Caption: cockroachdb
Caption: and we're using cogrege to be at family
Caption: zone
Caption: this all sounds too complicated why
Caption: should i bother with the distributed
Caption: database
Caption: well if you don't have a need for high
Caption: scalability and high availability you
Caption: probably don't need one
Caption: however more and more apps find
Caption: themselves
Caption: needing to handle bigger and bigger data
Caption: sets and sometimes said that the common
Caption: app is becoming a big data app
Caption: the distributed databases that exist
Caption: today are the culmination of decades of
Caption: research and development so you can have
Caption: your cake and eat it too with scalable
Caption: transactional databases that support sql
Caption: and the relational model
Caption: and there are choices available out
Caption: there
Caption: in addition to what's offered up by your
Caption: cloud provider
Caption: beware of giving up strong consistency
Caption: or at least be sure why you don't need
Caption: it before you give it up
Caption: if you need to work around the database
Caption: then perhaps it wasn't the ideal choice
Caption: for your problem
Caption: despite these these breakthroughs
Caption: there's still no one-size-fits-all
Caption: distributed database solution
Caption: there are generally purpose-built data
Caption: stores that might be ideal for your
Caption: particular workload
Caption: perhaps an analytical database was what
Caption: you actually needed or even a graph
Caption: database
Caption: so do your research before you jump
Caption: and don't choose just based on the hive
Caption: for the marketing
Caption: thank you for listening
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: do we have
Caption: i think there's probably
Caption: a lot of nuance to that but
Caption: i think
Caption: if you're
Caption: if your organization justifies it so you
Caption: have a big enough need
Caption: for using more than one database because
Caption: you need people that understand the
Caption: different technologies you need to
Caption: maintain those different technologies so
Caption: if you need the scale yes if you don't
Caption: need the scale
Caption: that's where i'd consider just making do
Caption: with one but
Caption: absolutely if you
Caption: the point was that they're purpose-built
Caption: so if one suits your need very well
Caption: use it for that need
Caption: um but you know that's easy to say and
Caption: and reality usually dictates that only
Caption: if it it's got the money behind it to
Caption: justify it
Caption: okay
Caption: thank you very much todd uh we'll wrap
Caption: it there please give todd
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: uh
Caption: [Music]
Caption: mark where are you mark open you turn
Caption: your camera on um
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerd's nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our poses
Caption: like dream come true i've always wanted
Caption: to join scott held someone's
Caption: what do you want
Caption: yes
Caption: [Music]
Caption: we got a little problem
Caption: as you know our motto is you need a
Caption: professional bodyguard delivered to your
Caption: door in less than half an hour you've
Caption: got it buddy but without an app ain't no
Caption: bodyguard getting delivered nowhere so
Caption: where are we with that uh the app is
Caption: almost ready uh we just need
Caption: three
Caption: more days we need it asap
Caption: okay team what's the status on the app
Caption: we're good to go except our login
Caption: experience is a disaster
Caption: we need something to keep our users data
Caption: private
Caption: and to keep the hackers out
Caption: and it needs to work flawlessly because
Caption: because i don't want to lose one single
Caption: customer i hear you so let's use off
Caption: zero off what now off zero it's an
Caption: identity platform fast easy logins just
Caption: what the boss wants can we make our own
Caption: authentication service come on the
Caption: ultimate key master you know we don't
Caption: have that kind of time we need to
Caption: confirm identities with passwords
Caption: fingerprint scans whatever the users
Caption: like to use observer can do that yeah
Caption: but it needs to be secure we can't have
Caption: our app compromised by breaches not a
Caption: problem and it needs to scale if we get
Caption: hit with a ton of traffic and if it
Caption: stalls or freezes up i will get fired we
Caption: can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: could you guys stop that's really
Caption: distracting
Caption: we did it it's done already yep i think
Caption: our customers are gonna love it i got a
Caption: real app now folks
Caption: you know what i want a bodyguard
Caption: hey we got a customer
Caption: cool app
Caption: my name's steven
Caption: what's up steven
Caption: we can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: so
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: um
Caption: [Music]
Caption: well thank you everyone uh for coming
Caption: back to jacqueline nigal again
Caption: uh up next we have aaron who's going to
Caption: be talking about unleashing the power of
Caption: visual studio code probably one of the
Caption: more
Caption: industry changing editors of recent
Caption: times i would say so please everyone put
Caption: your hands together to welcome aaron to
Caption: the stage
Caption: thanks for having me um as you mentioned
Caption: my name is aaron uh i work for microsoft
Caption: as part of the cloud advocacy team um
Caption: i've been doing
Caption: uh software development and web
Caption: development for longer that i'm going to
Caption: admit to that in a session that's been
Caption: recorded and streamed out
Caption: but i like i've used a lot of editors in
Caption: my time like i i got started with like
Caption: pico and um and stuff like that on e-max
Caption: on linux machines when i was uh
Caption: first at uni and then uh obviously have
Caption: uh graduated to uh more complex editors
Caption: but yeah like vs code is
Caption: it's been huge like in like the way that
Caption: has changed how people
Caption: think about simple text editors because
Caption: at the end of the day that that's what
Caption: it is and
Caption: the fact that i i'm here and you're
Caption: stuck in a room with me for the next 45
Caption: minutes to hear me talk about a text
Caption: editor i think that's kind of a kind of
Caption: a big deal
Caption: but yeah if you if you want to uh get in
Caption: contact with me after the session uh ask
Caption: me any questions that i don't get a
Caption: chance to um
Caption: cover off during uh during the talk uh
Caption: that's my social media and uh website
Caption: and email address and all that kind of
Caption: stuff
Caption: but um before we jump into the talk i
Caption: want to thank the sponsors um i've been
Caption: doing ddd conferences in australia for
Caption: 12 years now and they can't happen
Caption: without sponsors um
Caption: like all the ones we've got here
Caption: particularly microsoft they're an
Caption: awesome sponsor you should really come
Caption: and see us at the booth afterwards um
Caption: yeah and that's where i'll be hanging
Caption: out for the rest of the day so if you do
Caption: want to come ask any other questions
Caption: find me there
Caption: but
Caption: we're here to to talk about the power of
Caption: vs code um so whether whether you're
Caption: brand new to the tech industry you're
Caption: looking to get into tech um or you've
Caption: been in it for
Caption: the nearly 20 years that i've been in it
Caption: um i hope that there's going to be
Caption: something in this session for you um i
Caption: i've put this together because
Caption: i'm i think that it's
Caption: while it seems so simple it's a text
Caption: editor there's so many hidden things in
Caption: it um but
Caption: to get started i'm going to just make
Caption: sure that you know for those of you that
Caption: haven't used vs code before or you
Caption: haven't had um i had much experience
Caption: with it let's just make sure that we're
Caption: all on the same page so i'm going to do
Caption: a quick lap around vs code so this is uh
Caption: vs code um i've got a project of mine
Caption: open there um don't try and read the
Caption: text it's not particularly interesting
Caption: or relevant um but what i'm going to do
Caption: is i want to break down the core
Caption: features of the text editor
Caption: across the top we have the the title bar
Caption: and that's where you your menu systems
Caption: are like every application under the sun
Caption: has got a title bar of some description
Caption: but the interesting thing about the vs
Caption: code one is that
Caption: it's highly customizable in fact like
Caption: everything in vs code is highly
Caption: customizable so at the top it's got
Caption: things like there the file name um of
Caption: the file that we've currently got open
Caption: it's got the the um information about
Caption: the
Caption: repo
Caption: this is connected to i'm connected to a
Caption: remote vs code instance so i'm using it
Caption: with wsl so it's got that information in
Caption: there but you can actually edit that and
Caption: change you know strip out information
Caption: you don't think is going to be needed or
Caption: you don't want to display in there and
Caption: this can be really uh really useful some
Caption: someone that has um maybe some attention
Caption: uh issues or some um some neurodiversion
Caption: in that regards i can strip out the
Caption: stuff that isn't like i don't need to
Caption: have it there i don't need to tell me
Caption: i'm in vs code because i know i'm in vs
Caption: code um for example you can you can
Caption: modify it to be the editor that you need
Caption: it to be
Caption: we have the sidebar um on the left hand
Caption: side um i actually hit mine on the right
Caption: hand side and no i'll show you uh why
Caption: when uh jump into actually editor but
Caption: this is where we have like our files and
Caption: our folder structure that's all there
Caption: it's where we get to the debugger we get
Caption: to source control so we can um like make
Caption: our commits into the git repo or um
Caption: is there any other source control that
Caption: people still use i'm like it's like
Caption: svn
Caption: oh now now am i really dating myself cvs
Caption: anyone anyone cbs
Caption: yeah
Caption: um
Caption: but so the other thing with the sidebar
Caption: is that uh extensions that you can add
Caption: to vs code um can also introduce things
Caption: in here uh so i've got a couple of
Caption: additional icons down the bottom there
Caption: the azure extension a docker extension
Caption: and a few things like that so that um
Caption: there's functionality specific to that
Caption: and a
Caption: complex extension like the azure one
Caption: that allows you work with azure
Caption: resources
Caption: it's all there and i can do it with
Caption: inside of the editor so the actual goes
Caption: beyond just being a
Caption: text editing
Caption: place it's also a more complex tool
Caption: there are seats up the front feel like
Caption: you don't feel like you need to
Caption: awkwardly stand around the back
Caption: um down the bottom we have our status
Caption: bar and this is again showing just a
Caption: whole bunch of uh like little quick
Caption: quick pieces of information um things
Caption: like what branch we on in the the git
Caption: repo that we've got open are there any
Caption: errors or warnings in the project that
Caption: i've got open um you know what's the
Caption: what's the lining coatings because
Caption: that's a painful thing there are still
Caption: seats please do come in um
Caption: don't you don't feel like you need to
Caption: stand in the doorway
Caption: um no uh and like what what uh language
Caption: service is being used so this is it's a
Caption: html file that's got open so terminates
Caption: html but i can change that to what and
Caption: that indicates then and that can be
Caption: useful if you you've uh working with
Caption: multiple languages that uh maybe uh more
Caption: esoteric than uh kind of just
Caption: your common run-of-the-mill sort of
Caption: stuff but again you can turn as much of
Caption: this stuff off as you want because again
Caption: you might not want that information you
Caption: might not need it there because you know
Caption: it's contextually irrelevant to you or
Caption: you find it distracting to have that
Caption: kind of stuff all there
Caption: then we've got our terminal across the
Caption: bottom so there's an integrated terminal
Caption: in vs code um
Caption: that we can we can open up we can open
Caption: up as many terminal windows as we can um
Caption: when i'm working i tend to have just vs
Caption: code open and i don't even have a
Caption: separate terminal app running anymore i
Caption: just pop the terminal up
Caption: run my npm commands or run my git
Caption: installs oh sorry get my commands and
Caption: stuff like that um all within here also
Caption: interestingly um if you do run like a
Caption: node uh command so like an um npm start
Caption: to
Caption: how to run a web server from the vs go
Caption: terminal it will automatically attach a
Caption: debugger for you you don't even have to
Caption: like do anything extra to get debugging
Caption: running for like a node application
Caption: yeah npm start there's your debugger
Caption: already ready to go
Caption: um and then there's actually a text
Caption: editing surface as well
Caption: like
Caption: it's been like five minutes and i
Caption: haven't talked about the fact that you
Caption: can edit a text document
Caption: in a text editor
Caption: but i mean you can it's it's obviously
Caption: the core feature um
Caption: it does all the things you'd expect from
Caption: a text editor it does syntax
Caption: highlighting um i have like errors and
Caption: stuff like that will appear if the
Caption: language service that you're using is um
Caption: is surfacing that information up um
Caption: and then this is a html file
Caption: it's got a variety of colors in there to
Caption: indicate the different things inside of
Caption: that
Caption: and lastly we have our mini map view of
Caption: the file so there's like a 10 000 view
Caption: of the file that you're in um and this
Caption: is not a particularly long file so it's
Caption: all condensed up the top and you can see
Caption: even like the colorization appears there
Caption: but this can be useful if you're
Caption: scrolling through a
Caption: thousand long thousands of like a file
Caption: that's like a thousand lines long
Caption: not that anyone's writing like single
Caption: files that are like
Caption: like several thousands lines no no one
Caption: does that do they
Caption: no i see some i see some awkward uh
Caption: awkward nodding of the head there
Caption: um
Caption: all right so that's vs code in a very
Caption: quick nutshell uh and kind of like all
Caption: like all the different aspects obvious
Caption: code and the things that are in there so
Caption: let's now
Caption: talk about like how can we use it to be
Caption: productive and for me being productive
Caption: means keyboard like i'm i'm a keyboard
Caption: user i i
Caption: don't have an external mouse like when
Caption: i'm when i'm using my laptop i don't use
Caption: an external mouse i don't use an
Caption: external mouse at home because i have a
Caption: desktop
Caption: but i so i've done everything i can to
Caption: try and memorize as many keyboard
Caption: shortcuts as i can
Caption: um i know a scary amount of word
Caption: shortcuts
Caption: so like
Caption: i can power using my way through
Caption: microsoft word um but yeah also in vs
Caption: code um
Caption: and
Caption: let's jump over
Caption: there's enough slides for a moment let's
Caption: jump over and actually have a look at vs
Caption: code and some stuff that we've got in
Caption: here so i'm i've got a a couple of
Caption: different vs codes this is open um
Caption: the the you should be able to read the
Caption: text but again don't worry about the
Caption: text in there this is mostly my notes so
Caption: feel free to read ahead and just then
Caption: zone out to me uh because this is what
Caption: i'm going to be covering uh but
Caption: if there is only one shortcut key in vs
Caption: code that you learn
Caption: it is control p
Caption: this brings up um the defaults to the
Caption: file picker so i can use this to find
Caption: the readme file hit enter it opens the
Caption: file i'm currently in um but we can also
Caption: use uh this to say type a question mark
Caption: and here are all the other things that
Caption: we can get from this um
Caption: it moves on from being just a file a
Caption: file picker to being a command palette
Caption: so i could do a greater than symbol and
Caption: then these are all the things like the
Caption: actions i can form within
Caption: this code i can
Caption: open the settings or i can go
Caption: to
Caption: uh like so i've actually traveled on a
Caption: thing called screencast mode uh so as i
Caption: type the keyboard shortcuts uh they'll
Caption: pop up quickly on the screen so you know
Caption: i'm like here's the keyboard shortcut
Caption: you're like i can't see the keyboard
Caption: aaron you're up there and there's a
Caption: screen um so i've got that turned on so
Caption: you can see uh so
Caption: ctrl p comes to the file picker control
Caption: shift p
Caption: if i hit the correct keys um go straight
Caption: to the actions so uh this is just like
Caption: it's a quick one because this is
Caption: probably the most common thing that you
Caption: tend to do from the file picker uh so
Caption: from from the the command palette
Caption: um other things i like like if i type
Caption: view and get to the sidebar um on the
Caption: right hand side there oh if i fall to
Caption: the left-hand side i move it to the
Caption: right-hand side because
Caption: if i expand it and collapse it
Caption: it pops in and out if i have it on the
Caption: left let's see if i can remember how to
Caption: move it to the left
Caption: i actually can't remember how to move it
Caption: to the left it's somewhere in settings
Caption: it's been so long since i've done that
Caption: oh was it
Caption: ah
Caption: excellent there we go um control b hides
Caption: and shows it but this is really annoying
Caption: for me because you now you your your
Caption: focal point is um is shifting because
Caption: the the editor's surface is moving so
Caption: that's why i move mine to the right
Caption: um anyway so ctrl p view and then i can
Caption: go to explorer pop up into this bit or
Caption: control b p view uh debug
Caption: and get to the debug section
Caption: um so i don't have to maybe like
Caption: memorize um the shortcut keys i think
Caption: that's well
Caption: f5 i think might get you to that i
Caption: forget but i just do control p view um
Caption: but also then i can say in explorer
Caption: if i was in explorer i can then go to
Caption: like the uh the folders or the outline
Caption: view or um you know so i can actually
Caption: navigate the sub menus within all the
Caption: subsections with inside of um the the
Caption: sidebar um using the command palette
Caption: again just all off the off the keyboard
Caption: there
Caption: other one um term for uh quick access to
Caption: anything to do with terminals
Caption: and create a new terminal
Caption: that one's to be down there i'm going to
Caption: turn
Caption: whoops
Caption: and then i can create
Caption: another terminal
Caption: and then i can swap between them
Caption: um but with terminals
Caption: they're all called zsh because that's
Caption: the shell that i'm using in this case uh
Caption: but it's like well which one which one's
Caption: which how do i easily know that well
Caption: ctrl shift p
Caption: command palette and then we're going to
Caption: go terminal rename and we'll call this
Caption: one we'll call this git because i'm
Caption: going to use that for my git operations
Caption: and now if i go control p term i can
Caption: type git
Caption: and jump to that particular terminal so
Caption: this is usually if you've got a couple
Caption: opens maybe you're maybe you're building
Caption: an application that's got a like a front
Caption: end and a back end and you've got a
Caption: couple of terminals open ones running
Caption: the back end like the npm command to run
Caption: the back end the others uh the the front
Caption: end web application so you've got
Caption: multiple um terminals running node
Caption: processors well you can rename them so
Caption: that you can jump back and forth and you
Caption: can see the uh
Caption: which one like the log messages from the
Caption: right one um easily
Caption: from there
Caption: all right um
Caption: so
Caption: yeah uh control p probably like the
Caption: number one shortcut to take away and to
Caption: remember from this
Caption: now
Caption: i'm talking about screencast mode which
Caption: i've got turned on and we can get to
Caption: that from settings control comma we'll
Caption: get to settings we type screen
Caption: casts
Caption: and i have that turned on here you can
Caption: actually hide terminals uh control
Caption: backtick will collapse the terminals um
Caption: area at the bottom
Caption: hide and show short backtick uh and so
Caption: control b to collapse that um so with uh
Caption: with screencast mode um
Caption: this can be good for pair programming as
Caption: well uh so you're uh whether you're
Caption: doing it like as a um like a remote pair
Caption: programming session or you've just got
Caption: someone um that's sitting next to you
Caption: and you don't want them kind of
Caption: breathing down your neck trying to work
Caption: out well i see what you're doing um and
Caption: just tonguing it on can be a useful
Caption: thing but you can you know it can be a
Caption: little bit annoying because like every
Caption: key stroke is getting captured in here
Caption: but i can change that
Caption: and say that i only want it to show just
Caption: like the commands so if i'm using the
Caption: command or i'll sort those kind of keys
Caption: it'll just show those up
Caption: and that can be a bit more useful i
Caption: guess if you're doing demos and stuff
Caption: like that
Caption: change font size change styling all that
Caption: kind of stuff there
Caption: another useful
Caption: mode of
Caption: vs code is zen mode control k zed
Caption: yeah you just like you you want to kind
Caption: of turn off as many of the distractions
Caption: as you've got because you you know you
Caption: you're in you're in the moment like
Caption: you're trying to you know get through a
Caption: bug or whatever the case may be
Caption: um this
Caption: as you can see it's hidden pretty much
Caption: everything we've hit in the sidebar
Caption: we've hidden the status bar um the the
Caption: top menus um hidden like we don't even
Caption: have the you can't even see the
Caption: different files we've got open i only
Caption: have one file open at the moment anyway
Caption: but like you would you can control tab
Caption: to get between the the files but yeah
Caption: this is like you know it's a it's a
Caption: focus mode like we've hidden everything
Caption: that could be a potential distraction
Caption: just so we can focus on the thing that
Caption: we're currently trying to do
Caption: uh ctrl k said to get back out of that
Caption: uh there are a bunch of settings for zen
Caption: mode as well so let's say that it's
Caption: actually maybe a little bit too
Caption: aggressive i do still want to have uh
Caption: line numbers in here i can
Caption: say that well no don't hide the line
Caption: numbers
Caption: go back into z mode
Caption: so i can still have my line numbers in
Caption: there because i like i find now useful
Caption: so i can navigate up and down or i know
Caption: where uh where i'm at and things like
Caption: that
Caption: customize it for the way that you want
Caption: to use it it's not just the it's not
Caption: just trying to be an editor that is
Caption: generic and you like it it forces you to
Caption: work in a particular way now you
Caption: customize it for the needs that you've
Caption: got
Caption: uh and i'm just going to turn that back
Caption: on
Caption: so that my zen mode is nice
Caption: clean
Caption: um
Caption: from
Caption: uh from an accessibility standpoint uh
Caption: there's been a lot of work in vs code to
Caption: make that uh
Caption: an easy editor to use um and something
Caption: that
Caption: i think that people don't consider um
Caption: too much and and what and i know i
Caption: didn't consider this for a long time but
Caption: i used to work with a colleague who um
Caption: has albinoism and he had very poor
Caption: eyesight as a result of that so he had
Caption: to have his font um incredibly large so
Caption: that he could read it and and that kind
Caption: of stuff but
Caption: that can be a problem when you're
Caption: working on code files because we tend to
Caption: well
Caption: i'm lazy so i just you know write things
Caption: as long as i can like i've got a giant
Caption: screen at home and a reasonable enough
Caption: eyesight so i'm quite content to have
Caption: you know hundreds and hundreds of
Caption: characters spread across a 32 inch
Caption: monitor because that's like that's my
Caption: working
Caption: experience but that might not be great
Caption: for everyone
Caption: on the team so we can turn on editor
Caption: rules in uh
Caption: vs code whoops let me just control
Caption: control k control u to comment and
Caption: uncomment um so control uh yeah control
Caption: k is there okay you is uncommon control
Caption: k c is to comment um but there we go so
Caption: i've turned on some editor rules um and
Caption: so you can see these uh lines there or
Caption: you can maybe make it a bit like get
Caption: that real retro experience and just have
Caption: a whole heap of scan lines across the
Caption: screen
Caption: i mean you then customize the colors for
Caption: the minute and it can be useful it's
Caption: like oh well we want to keep to it like
Caption: an 80 character width because you know
Caption: we know that there's someone on our team
Caption: that
Caption: that's kind of the the width of
Caption: code that they can show at any point in
Caption: time so we just want to be mindful of
Caption: that so we you know we have an indicator
Caption: in there or you know you're you're
Caption: working on something that's got to be
Caption: shipped to a mainframe and it is
Caption: actually like an 80 character width uh
Caption: terminal that they're going to be
Caption: working with so so you want to know
Caption: where 80 characters is or you're one of
Caption: those people that is militant about no
Caption: it doesn't matter that we can have a
Caption: curved 49-inch monitor around us i am
Caption: going to have a fixed width of 80
Caption: characters in my text editor because
Caption: that's that's what i grew up with uh
Caption: coding um but yeah it's just like it's
Caption: it's kind of one of those random little
Caption: features that i think
Caption: um can be useful particularly when
Caption: you're uh considering
Caption: uh how other people
Caption: are also going to be working on um
Caption: by a code base or or something like that
Caption: for you um but we'll turn them off
Caption: because they might be a little bit
Caption: distracting
Caption: uh another kind of actually i should
Caption: have kept that open ctrl shift t
Caption: open the last file
Caption: another thing that uh is um
Caption: is is useful and
Caption: uh i tend to forget to to turn it on
Caption: because i i add it for like the demos
Caption: that i do then i take it out because um
Caption: i
Caption: don't try to clean up my uh my workspace
Caption: beforehand and then forget to have it
Caption: put it back in uh they're called code
Caption: actions on save so you want to perform
Caption: something when uh when the file is being
Caption: saved
Caption: that's what code action's on save code
Caption: action on save
Caption: and
Caption: we can get it to do a variety of
Caption: different things so what
Caption: control space one of those is organize
Caption: imports
Caption: so we're going to hit set that to true
Caption: so let's say that we're working on like
Caption: a javascript file
Caption: one here uh and we've got a like a
Caption: a linkedin rule where we have to we want
Caption: to keep the order of our imports in an
Caption: alphabetical banner that's a it's a
Caption: fairly common olympic rule well i i've
Caption: got them a bit uh backwards here um
Caption: because i want the distractor imports at
Caption: the very top
Caption: so i can go ctrl shift p and then uh
Caption: organize imports
Caption: or shift alt o is the default shortcut
Caption: key for that one
Caption: i can hit it and it's going to do that
Caption: for me or with code actions on save
Caption: now as soon as i hit ctrl s to save the
Caption: file
Caption: it's going to just run that for me you
Caption: know it just like it's a useful little
Caption: thing particularly if like those are the
Caption: sorts of things that you're putting in
Caption: your like your lending rules um there's
Caption: also another one in there for uh for fix
Caption: all um so it'll uh if you've got a like
Caption: a linter installed that is going to be
Caption: applying um fixing rules uh it can try
Caption: and run those for you so like eslimps um
Caption: it'll try and apply those fixes to the
Caption: file as you hit save so yeah just like
Caption: little quality of life improvements that
Caption: are there
Caption: let's come back um
Caption: oh uh the last one from a setting
Caption: standpoint that could be useful is this
Caption: default editor language um
Caption: what it will do is it will attempt to
Caption: work out from the workspace
Caption: what is the most common programming
Caption: language of the files that are in there
Caption: and when you do control n to create a
Caption: new file it will assign that language
Caption: service to the new file so you
Caption: immediately get your
Caption: code completion turned on for the file
Caption: you immediately get the correct color
Caption: like syntax highlighting and
Caption: colorizations and stuff like that um but
Caption: you can actually override that setting
Caption: uh so yeah no i want new files in this
Caption: repo to be always defaulted to mark now
Caption: for example i do that for my
Caption: my blog is rendering markdown so i
Caption: default the files to always be marked
Caption: down unless i change the
Caption: the the file with control k m
Caption: ctrl k m not control k control n control
Caption: k m and that's how we can change the
Caption: language of a file um
Caption: so yeah but you can you can set you can
Caption: let vs code attempt to figure out what
Caption: should be the default language for a new
Caption: file or you can force that uh with
Caption: settings
Caption: um active active editor language is the
Caption: default that's there
Caption: right
Caption: we'll come back to slides for a minute
Caption: because i want to talk about extensions
Caption: vs code has a huge amount of
Caption: extensibility um and
Caption: out of that has grown a massive
Caption: extensions ecosystem everyone's going to
Caption: have their favorite extension that you
Caption: should have installed
Caption: that they believe is the it's going to
Caption: change the way that you use vs code
Caption: and there are literally thousands of
Caption: extensions so i am not going to cover
Caption: them all off in here i'm just going to
Caption: talk about a couple that i think
Caption: are really useful and that i've got
Caption: installed on my machine um and they're
Caption: generic ones they're not um
Caption: they're not specific to a particular
Caption: programming language or anything like
Caption: that so these are these are six um top
Caption: ones for me um editor config for vs code
Caption: so editor config if you're unfamiliar
Caption: with it is a file that you can put into
Caption: a repo that we're that you use to define
Caption: the
Caption: set default things about a file like
Caption: what is the default line encoding how
Caption: many are we using tabs or spaces now
Caption: what's the default indentation depth and
Caption: you can then set that for um uh like
Caption: different for different files so maybe
Caption: your your your bash files um they need
Caption: to have an lf as the default line
Caption: encoding whereas other files you might
Caption: want to have a crlf as the the line
Caption: encoding and then you can and so that
Caption: that one's a useful one just to enforce
Caption: standardization with inside of a code
Caption: base
Caption: uh
Caption: get up pull requests and issues uh just
Caption: manage all your github stuff uh what
Caption: pull requests and issues aspects of
Caption: github from within vs code don't have to
Caption: jump out to the website don't have to
Caption: jump out to the the github
Caption: desktop application or anything like
Caption: that um just do it from vs code um rest
Caption: client if you're doing anything that
Caption: involves calling apis rest client is
Caption: so useful um it's the same as like
Caption: postman and insomniac and all those
Caption: sorts of tools so it allows you to
Caption: invoke http um requests
Caption: but the advantage of rest client is that
Caption: you create a file um and then
Caption: you just execute the things out of that
Caption: file so you can have you know your
Caption: examples of how to call an api as a file
Caption: then you just check in part of your git
Caption: repo
Caption: and then you like it's it's all there
Caption: it's all in one location and you can
Caption: then execute those from within sort of
Caption: vs code uh peacock this was actually
Caption: written by a colleague of mine at
Caption: microsoft uh and it's it's what a uh
Caption: what it does is it changes the colors of
Caption: like the borders of vs code so you
Caption: would have seen uh the one that i had uh
Caption: where is it
Caption: it's my lovely background
Caption: uh so see how this has got the green
Caption: around it uh peacock's done that so if
Caption: you've got a couple of vs code instances
Caption: open maybe you want to um you set
Caption: different colors on them so you know
Caption: which one it is as you're all tabbing um
Caption: between your uh between your windows
Caption: uh
Caption: code spell checker
Caption: funny story was uh when i was working
Caption: for a company a number of years ago we
Caption: were
Caption: we were building a custom crm and we
Caption: needed to keep track of uh person name
Caption: history uh
Caption: because if someone changed their name we
Caption: needed to track that so we created a
Caption: table called person name history
Caption: well so we thought that's what we named
Caption: the table
Caption: it wasn't until several months later
Caption: that we realized that we'd actually
Caption: named the table person named his troy
Caption: we'd also written custom orm it had
Caption: generated a whole bunch of c sharp code
Caption: from the database so we had all these
Caption: classes called person name his troy
Caption: uh you would get back person
Caption: collection a person named his troyes uh
Caption: and all that kind of stuff um
Caption: it was then
Caption: like this was then in in testing and it
Caption: was just it was too hard to go back and
Caption: fix it so we're like oh well we're
Caption: shipping to production with person name
Caption: his choice
Caption: you want an extension like this one like
Caption: code spell check to
Caption: make sure you don't do that
Caption: um i i and i'm just horrendously bad at
Caption: spelling it at the best of times so i
Caption: use that on my blog and it just like
Caption: it's just so nice and uh that i could
Caption: just not have to worry about that
Caption: uh and then the last one is to do
Caption: highlight
Caption: so to do highlight actually like to use
Caption: with uh the github uh one so where you
Caption: put like whack i'll like put a comment
Caption: in you know to do i'm totally gonna fix
Caption: this code later i can and you totally
Caption: got to come back and do that right um
Caption: what what to do highlight will do is it
Caption: will actually find all those and give
Caption: you a list of that like you can see that
Caption: with inside of vs code like here's all
Caption: the tools you've got with inside of the
Caption: solution
Caption: but then i combine that with the github
Caption: full request and issues uh so that you
Caption: can just select that to do uh and then
Caption: immediately create a github issue out of
Caption: that so that it's not just in the code
Caption: base that you're totally gonna fix it
Caption: later it's also in your github issues
Caption: that you're totally gonna come back and
Caption: fix
Caption: and it just gets de-prioritized down the
Caption: back
Caption: um yeah uh
Caption: these sticks are like yeah they're ones
Caption: that i find really useful and like i
Caption: said these aren't specific to any kind
Caption: of programming like whether you're
Caption: writing markdown or python or net or
Caption: whatever these can all help out there
Caption: but i'm a web developer at heart so i
Caption: want to talk about a couple of um my
Caption: favorite uh web developer or javascript
Caption: developer extensions um
Caption: and i linked my animations are not quite
Caption: right uh so um
Caption: prettier so uh if you're if you're doing
Caption: javascript uh projects prettier is kind
Caption: of like it's the de facto standard i
Caption: think at the moment for doing um code
Caption: formatting uh for javascript
Caption: applications it also does like html and
Caption: css and i think a couple other languages
Caption: markdown and stuff like that uh there is
Caption: an extension for vs code so that uh like
Caption: you don't have to um do anything it just
Caption: uh it includes it and then it you can
Caption: set that as the default format formatter
Caption: for fi for the right files are your
Caption: javascript files so when you um in vs
Caption: code you tell it to format the file it
Caption: will execute prettier for you
Caption: um combine that with eslint so then you
Caption: can get your linting
Caption: rules uh the the linking information
Caption: surfaced up with inside of the editor so
Caption: you can quickly jump around and find
Caption: those without having to wait until the
Caption: ci build has failed because you didn't
Caption: run uh npm no you didn't run your lintel
Caption: before pushing
Caption: uh npm um this is a just a useful
Caption: extension uh for working with npm it
Caption: will like when you're working a package
Caption: json file uh you can do control space uh
Caption: on the version and we'll show you the
Caption: the version um
Caption: versions available for that package and
Caption: also give you like the december um
Caption: syntax for it so like do you want the
Caption: the the hat or do you want a
Caption: star or whatever the case may be um so
Caption: yeah you can uh
Caption: make sure you're locking packages at the
Caption: right point uh and the last one is um uh
Caption: we we shipped uh for vs code a bunch of
Caption: extent an extension for uh edge so that
Caption: you can do um like work with the browser
Caption: from vs code and i'm gonna have a crack
Caption: at actually testing that one out now
Caption: because i totally didn't just try and do
Caption: this before okay before i came to uh
Caption: into the room for the session i totally
Caption: this was all pre-planned and done um
Caption: this is the dna perth website
Caption: i put it down um let's do npm start
Caption: and we'll see
Caption: if that works there we go
Caption: um and i do have the edge extension
Caption: installed so the edge extension i think
Caption: it also works with chrome to a degree so
Caption: because it's chromium browsers
Caption: but
Caption: this is
Caption: not working fantastic
Caption: all right um well the
Caption: [Music]
Caption: oh i had to do like npm build i think
Caption: npm run build
Caption: i totally didn't read that readme either
Caption: so i was just like i can clone this run
Caption: npm install and yeah like everything
Caption: will be fine
Caption: yeah yeah
Caption: that might not be fine that's gonna take
Caption: a while um uh
Caption: let's try uh i'll show i'll show us um a
Caption: slightly different uh one of it uh that
Caption: does work
Caption: but not quite as much as i wanted there
Caption: uh so oh another one from there task and
Caption: then these are uh scripts that i've
Caption: already got inside of my repo that i can
Caption: run uh this is my this is my blog i'm
Caption: just going to
Caption: run the the little web server for that
Caption: it's open and now i'm going to use the
Caption: edge extension which i've got installed
Caption: here
Caption: and there it is
Caption: i have my website there and i want to
Caption: hit
Caption: open there we go
Caption: i do apologize that it is going to be
Caption: very cramped because it's all zoomed in
Caption: for the editor but
Caption: there's my there's my website on one
Caption: side and there's a dom inspector on the
Caption: other side so i could go hey let's find
Caption: that element
Caption: so i can like i can ins like
Caption: all that dom inspectory goodness that's
Caption: there i have the the css um information
Caption: there uh you probably can't read that
Caption: unless you're in the front few rows but
Caption: uh i'm actually using sas
Caption: to instead of like raw css so i'm
Caption: compiling that down to css and that's
Caption: telling me this is uh banner.scss file
Caption: um and
Caption: if i
Caption: wasn't using it in the way that i'm
Caption: using it i could actually click through
Caption: to that file and we'll go to the file
Caption: and disk unfortunately it's not working
Caption: in this particular vs code instance
Caption: because i'm
Caption: connected to a remote machine uh and it
Caption: doesn't like so it can't access the file
Caption: system uh properly to do that password
Caption: that's why i was trying to get this one
Caption: up and running and it's a good idea i
Caption: didn't wait for that because it's still
Caption: building um but like if if you're
Caption: working with it just like directly on
Caption: your mac or windows machine or linux
Caption: machine then um like like you can click
Caption: through to that file if you edit in the
Caption: styles editor with inside of um this
Caption: extension here it will actually push
Caption: those to the file on disk um so like
Caption: just like full real-time uh feedback
Caption: loop that you get there
Caption: yeah it's a it's a really nifty
Caption: extension and i'm not just trying to
Caption: pimp it because i work for microsoft and
Caption: i think edge is actually a decent
Caption: browser um like being able to like have
Caption: like having everything contextually in
Caption: the one location i find is quite useful
Caption: all
Caption: right now
Caption: i did consulting work for nearly a
Caption: decade before joining microsoft and
Caption: something that was always frustrating
Caption: when i was doing my consulting work was
Caption: that i would come to a new client
Caption: and like cool um welcome um here's your
Caption: machine
Caption: boom big pile of paper uh that's the
Caption: setup guide for your machine we'll see
Caption: you at the end of the week who's who's
Caption: experienced something like that i've
Caption: seen i've seen a lot of heads nod yeah
Caption: it and you're just like
Caption: i feel bad because like i know how much
Caption: i'm billing for you to be here and
Caption: you're telling me it's going to take me
Caption: a week before i can be productive
Caption: because i've got to you know like and
Caption: you go through it and then it doesn't
Caption: work anyway oh yeah sorry it turns out
Caption: that um no we're actually using the the
Caption: the newer version of red sorry just not
Caption: like not the old version that's listed
Caption: in there can you actually download the
Caption: new can you can you upgrade that or um
Caption: oh yeah we we forgot to add this step or
Caption: actually
Caption: can you go talk to
Caption: this person on the other side of the
Caption: room because they're going to have to
Caption: help you um because yeah we haven't
Caption: documented some of the new stuff that
Caption: they've added to the uh the environment
Caption: and
Caption: it's just it's so frustrating um but
Caption: with vs code um
Caption: one of the one of the things we can do
Caption: with that is uh i mentioned before like
Caption: editor config and things like that just
Caption: to enforce them like code
Caption: standardization but you can even do that
Caption: to the point of like editor
Caption: standardization
Caption: where
Caption: um where we can have inside of our dot
Caption: vs code folder uh we can include things
Caption: like
Caption: settings so settings that are specific
Caption: for this repo so when you open this repo
Caption: in vs code these settings are going to
Caption: be applied so like if if you've got
Caption: like a you know
Caption: default file extension you want to set
Caption: you can set that just for this project
Caption: so that you opened up you're not having
Caption: to set this on a machine wide wide
Caption: config
Caption: um another one i don't have it in this
Caption: one but i think i might have it in
Caption: actually i'll have it in here maybe
Caption: i have so many oh there's so many things
Caption: open
Caption: uh whoops let's collapse that now
Caption: uh you can also include uh
Caption: i don't have extensions in this one
Caption: either
Caption: ah but i know where it was i did see one
Caption: earlier
Caption: inside of this vs code folder
Caption: extensions so these are recommended
Caption: extensions that you should have to work
Caption: on this particular project so they're um
Caption: they encourage you to install the chrome
Caption: debugger which ironically is actually
Caption: deprecated
Caption: um they're recommending that you install
Caption: editor config and printer and
Caption: uh eslint so what will happen is when
Caption: you open up this uh this folder in vs
Caption: code if you don't have those extensions
Caption: installed you'll get a notice saying
Caption: there are recommended extensions would
Caption: you like to install them
Caption: so that way you can make sure that
Caption: everyone's kind of got that same sort of
Caption: development experience
Caption: but
Caption: let's go back into the slides
Caption: in a moment there we go
Caption: but there's another level we can take
Caption: this to and that's with a feature of vs
Caption: code uh called uh dev containers
Caption: so
Caption: a dev container is a way to dockerize
Caption: the development environment that you're
Caption: working in or
Caption: dockerize the
Caption: yeah the thing that you're you're
Caption: building with uh and
Caption: then because it's in a your
Caption: environment's in a docking container you
Caption: can control what's there so you can
Caption: pre-install like the correct version of
Caption: node or net or go or whatever
Caption: runtime you're working with you can
Caption: pre-install like a database yeah um and
Caption: i'm gonna i'm gonna keep just dropping
Caption: in and out of my slides
Caption: uh so
Caption: this project yep this one here so this
Caption: is one of my open source projects it's a
Caption: f sharp project if anyone wants to talk
Caption: f sharp come see me i'm like probably
Caption: the only person here that actually cares
Caption: about that but it's awesome and if
Caption: you're a dotnet developer learn f sharp
Caption: um but this is a project for working
Caption: with uh cosmos db
Caption: uh from f sharp but for local
Caption: development well i don't have to spin up
Caption: an azure resource for for cosmos db or
Caption: if someone wants to come along
Caption: and contribute a fix to it or a feature
Caption: or anything like that i don't want them
Caption: to have to stand up an azure account
Caption: stand up of a cosmos instance inside of
Caption: there so i have a dev container that
Caption: does that for you um this one is using
Caption: docker compose so it has the environment
Caption: that you're going to be actually
Caption: developing with inside of so this will
Caption: preinstall the net
Caption: runtime for you the correct version
Caption: because i'm working on.net six um so
Caption: that'll all be pre-installed for you
Caption: plus um a few tools make uh for working
Caption: with f sharp um but then i have a
Caption: another docker container that started up
Caption: next to it which is going to be the
Caption: cosmos dvd emulator i then also so when
Caption: i open nvs code it detects this dev
Caption: container says hey do you want to run
Caption: this as a dev container
Caption: you do that it will start this all up
Caption: um it will start up the the docker
Caption: container side by side and now i i can
Caption: do full local development and i haven't
Caption: had to install anything other than
Caption: docker and vs code um and then if i when
Caption: i'm finished working on this delete the
Caption: repo off my machine and i don't have to
Caption: uninstall
Caption: the cosmos emulator i don't have to when
Caption: i saw the net framework or anything like
Caption: that it's all isolated uh and what this
Caption: means is that yeah like it's very easy
Caption: to come across as like an open source
Caption: contributor pick up a project clone it
Caption: open it and have all this like all the
Caption: environment ready to go you haven't had
Caption: to read like a
Caption: massive contributing guide or anything
Caption: like that
Caption: um the the next kind of power of this is
Caption: that if you're working with github code
Caption: spaces uh
Caption: when you open it in code spaces it will
Caption: detect the dev container and provision
Caption: the code space
Caption: through those specifications for you um
Caption: the the github folks um over the the
Caption: booth actually have this running uh with
Caption: another project of mine where it is
Caption: running a cosmos dba emulator and uh a
Caption: docking container side by side inside of
Caption: code spaces and they're running that
Caption: from a raspberry pi so you're like doing
Caption: full development with two running docker
Caption: containers off a raspberry pi um but
Caption: dev containers are really useful for
Caption: doing um
Caption: is yeah like this remote uh so this
Caption: pre-provisioned environment and it can
Caption: save so much time you know having to you
Caption: know install this
Caption: keep these docs up to date this is the
Caption: right version of whatever the dependency
Caption: is that we need to install you have it
Caption: all there um uh pre-built and combined
Caption: into this one folder
Caption: um all right
Caption: we've got about
Caption: um i'm gonna leave some time for
Caption: questions at the end um so uh we'll go
Caption: for about probably i think like 10
Caption: minutes left i think
Caption: yeah
Caption: i'm getting some vagueness on that i'm
Caption: also the thing that's standing between
Caption: everyone and lunch so uh
Caption: um
Caption: i talked a bit about code spaces but
Caption: there is
Caption: one other thing that i will
Caption: show off because i think it is super
Caption: cool particularly in um
Caption: in the fact that a lot more of us are
Caption: working from home now i've got to find
Caption: the right vs code instance that i have
Caption: open
Caption: where is it here here and
Caption: i have so many vs codes where are all
Caption: the vs codes it's not that
Caption: one was it this one
Caption: no no i don't have it on any of them um
Caption: there's an extension that i'm going to
Caption: install called live share
Caption: and this should actually install pretty
Caption: quickly because i already have it done
Caption: live share there we go okay so liveshare
Caption: is a extension that uh
Caption: it's it's a
Caption: i guess you'd call it a product um
Caption: we created microsoft for uh
Caption: doing um
Caption: uh remote
Caption: pair programming i guess it's probably a
Caption: good way to do it a good way to describe
Caption: it so with live share i'm going to hit
Caption: share now that i've installed that
Caption: and what it's going to do is it's going
Caption: to start up a collaboration session from
Caption: my machine and
Caption: uh it's going to this is probably going
Caption: to
Caption: not go as fast as i would like it to go
Caption: and that's going to be very depressing
Caption: but by by doing this i can i'll then end
Caption: up with a url that i can give out to you
Caption: know someone that i might be pair
Caption: programming with and they can connect
Caption: from their machine uh to
Caption: essentially by vs code instance
Caption: but they don't actually have to have vs
Caption: code installed they can do it directly
Caption: from the browser uh they could open it
Caption: up in full visual studio uh and
Caption: liveshare actually works with um
Caption: visual studio as well as vs code um
Caption: let's hit share again ah there we go oh
Caption: cool we're gonna do a sign-in dance
Caption: everyone's going to learn my password to
Caption: github
Caption: nope i should be already authenticated
Caption: uh so it's done okay
Caption: um
Caption: it's collaboration session come on there
Caption: we go okay so
Caption: that is open
Caption: uh
Caption: we don't need that i want to grab the
Caption: url
Caption: when it starts
Caption: here we go okay
Caption: session details
Caption: copy link
Caption: excellent now
Caption: i'm going to paste this into the browser
Caption: and
Caption: it's going to start
Caption: vs code in the browser
Caption: so here we go
Caption: uh and it's going to take a few minutes
Caption: uh or hopefully not a few minutes it's
Caption: going to take a little bit of time
Caption: because what it's doing is it's talking
Caption: into my laptop which is actually going
Caption: i'm going to continue on the web which
Caption: is going over the 5g connection on my
Caption: phone continuous anonymous
Caption: yeah we'll call that guest user uh and
Caption: they are going to be able to uh see like
Caption: all the files on my machine they're also
Caption: going to be able to connect to the
Caption: locally running web server that i've got
Caption: so they can
Caption: view the the website well which happens
Caption: to be my blog
Caption: there we go so there's all the files
Caption: starting to come in
Caption: i can open up
Caption: let's just pick a random file let's pick
Caption: this package json
Caption: it's going to have syntax highlighting
Caption: and colorization
Caption: and all that kind of stuff in there
Caption: but then as the as the host of this
Caption: collaboration session i can see here's
Caption: guest user seven they're on that file in
Caption: that line i can go follow participant
Caption: let's just close off some of these okay
Caption: that's it oh sorry focus participant no
Caption: follow to the side
Caption: and there we go i can see that's where
Caption: guest user is now there's a little
Caption: purple
Caption: carrot here which is uh where they are
Caption: put these side by side-ish
Caption: and
Caption: where let's go come on let's need more
Caption: space on my screen
Caption: so zoomed in uh okay and
Caption: you can see as that guest user clicks
Caption: around we can see what they're doing
Caption: uh and then if i was to come into let's
Caption: go into here i want to come into
Caption: my graphql file
Caption: here we go
Caption: so i i can like
Caption: remotely that person like i can see in
Caption: real time what's happening um if i'm
Caption: making changes in one uh
Caption: in one editor those will be reflected so
Caption: uh if we yeah if if i was to do that
Caption: like that those changes be reflected
Caption: across i said they get full debugging um
Caption: they can set breakpoints and all that
Caption: sort of stuff um which is really useful
Caption: if you're doing like yeah remote stuff
Caption: um
Caption: pair programming pull requests reviews
Caption: you just jump on a call using whatever
Caption: conference calling platform your choice
Caption: and just be like hey can we walk through
Caption: this together here's a live share link
Caption: actually live chat has built-in audio
Caption: support as well so you don't even need a
Caption: separate conference calling platform but
Caption: yeah it's like let's just walk through
Caption: this code together show me how that fix
Caption: is applied and all that kind of fun
Caption: stuff
Caption: and
Caption: the very last thing about vs code that i
Caption: want to tell you is that they have a
Caption: tick tock account i don't know what that
Caption: is because i am too old for tick tock
Caption: but there it is
Caption: uh yeah
Caption: yep um tick tock.com
Caption: uh vs code uh yeah
Caption: for for the younger people in the room
Caption: you might enjoy that i said i'm just too
Caption: old for for tick tock uh but it's there
Caption: i've watched a bunch of the videos like
Caption: they're pretty funny um but there's also
Caption: a bunch of like really uh useful
Caption: informative things in there like um
Caption: did you know
Caption: i learned from watching one of their
Caption: tick tocks that you can change the
Caption: scroll back history in the terminal um
Caption: by default it's like a thousand lines
Caption: but if you're uh doing something that
Caption: you know might be outputting
Caption: more than that um you can change the
Caption: scroll back depth uh and you can you
Caption: know and i learned that from tick tock
Caption: yeah i'm like so hip and cool and young
Caption: and look there's a thousand one other
Caption: things that you can do with vs code but
Caption: i'm just about out of time
Caption: i want to gain thank you our sponsors
Caption: for making sure that ddd perth could
Caption: happen again this year um i'm i'm glad
Caption: to be back uh at adida event i'm glad to
Caption: be back at in person conferences even
Caption: though i'd forgotten just how exhausting
Caption: they are um i'm pretty sure my voice
Caption: will give out before the end of the day
Caption: but
Caption: we've got a couple of minutes for
Caption: questions um or you can run off and grab
Caption: lunch early at the very least thanks for
Caption: coming to my session today i hope you've
Caption: learned a couple of tips and tricks for
Caption: working with vs code um and do feel free
Caption: to reach out after the session as well
Caption: if you want yeah thank you
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: yes uh any any questions or do we want
Caption: to run
Caption: okay cool yeah come if you've got
Caption: questions come up
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: foreign
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what mark where are you mark open you
Caption: turn your camera on um
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah
Caption: yeah we can see you
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerd's nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our poses
Caption: like my dream come true i've always
Caption: wanted to join scott hanselman's
Caption: what do you want
Caption: [Music]
Caption: so
Caption: we got a little problem
Caption: as you know our motto is you need a
Caption: professional bodyguard delivered to your
Caption: door in less than half an hour you've
Caption: got it buddy but without an app ain't no
Caption: bodyguard getting delivered nowhere so
Caption: where are we with that uh the app is
Caption: almost ready uh we just need
Caption: three
Caption: more days we need it asap
Caption: okay team what's the status on the app
Caption: we're good to go except our login
Caption: experience is a
Caption: disaster we need something to keep our
Caption: users data private
Caption: and to keep the hackers out
Caption: and it needs to work flawlessly because
Caption: because i don't want to lose one single
Caption: customer i hear you so let's use off
Caption: zero off what now off zero it's an
Caption: identity platform fast easy logins just
Caption: what the boss wants can we make our own
Caption: authentication service come on the
Caption: ultimate key master you know we don't
Caption: have that kind of time we need to
Caption: confirm identities with passwords
Caption: fingerprint scans whatever the users
Caption: like to zero can do that yeah but it
Caption: needs to be secure we can't have our app
Caption: compromised by breaches not a problem
Caption: and it needs to scale if we get hit with
Caption: a ton of traffic and if it stalls or
Caption: freezes up i will get fired we can do
Caption: this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: could you guys stop that's really
Caption: distracting
Caption: we did it it's done already yep i think
Caption: our customers are gonna love it we got a
Caption: real app now folks
Caption: you know what i want a bodyguard
Caption: hey we got a customer
Caption: cool app my name's steven
Caption: what's up steven
Caption: we can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: so
Caption: right
Caption: nice
Caption: [Music]
11957.6
Caption: all foreign
Caption: [Music]
Caption: foreign
Caption: mark where are you mark open you turn
Caption: your camera on um
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah
Caption: yeah we can see you
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerd's nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our poses
Caption: like my dream come true i've always
Caption: wanted to join scott hanselman's
Caption: what do you want
Caption: [Music]
Caption: ambition is a fearless hunger for
Caption: success it drives us to challenge the
Caption: way things are to pursue what seems
Caption: insurmountable to keep going when others
Caption: would stop ambition is how a global
Caption: manufacturer is using ai to empower
Caption: employees with disabilities ambition is
Caption: how a company managed an overnight
Caption: transition to remote work for 100 000
Caption: teammates ambition is how a children's
Caption: hospital built an app to reduce stress
Caption: for families ambition is how a law firm
Caption: rallied against a malware attack to
Caption: reclaim control and prevent a
Caption: devastating breach of client confidence
Caption: at insight we know the power of ambition
Caption: we've grown from a small technology
Caption: provider founded by two young brothers
Caption: to a fortune 500 company offering it
Caption: services and solutions for all for more
Caption: than 30 years
Caption: people have trusted us to turn ambitious
Caption: projects into meaningful outcomes
Caption: what will your ambitious story be
Caption: now is the time to do big things
Caption: together now is the time to be ambitious
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: my name is carol i'm a test engineer
Caption: my call sign is special case you might
Caption: be familiar with it you see it in cereal
Caption: boxes it's my call sign because i like
Caption: eating i eat a lot when people see me
Caption: they always see me eating and they
Caption: always ask me carol why are you eating
Caption: and i think that when they see when they
Caption: see the cereal box they say okay that's
Caption: carol
Caption: hi i'm joshni i'm a test engineer they
Caption: call me gesture because i always have a
Caption: smile on my face whatever situation i'm
Caption: in
Caption: my name is jaden i'm an automation
Caption: engineer here at planet my call sign is
Caption: digit because i'm a huge huge maths nerd
Caption: uh
Caption: it is it is it is my primary major um
Caption: but i often get called out
Caption: on how i never never ever ever stop
Caption: talking about maths
Caption: i just love maths
Caption: i am
Caption: cassandra i am a test automation
Caption: especially
Caption: pinkberry
Caption: as you can tell by the accent i am
Caption: french very very prominent accent so the
Caption: direct completely makes sense as for the
Caption: ping no matter the client no matter
Caption: where i was working it always was
Caption: a pink background with
Caption: hello kitty riding a unicorn
Caption: it does not reflect who i am outside
Caption: clearly but i think it brings a little
Caption: bit of
Caption: sparks and enjoy and so yeah so being
Caption: very it is
Caption: my name is kong i'm consultant here at
Caption: planet it's when people ask me how to
Caption: pronounce my name i always say
Caption: i'm not the king but the kong
Caption: but after joining planet
Caption: i am the king and i'm the kong
Caption: work to inspire is very something that
Caption: we live by i believe we definitely see
Caption: how much passion we are for quality and
Caption: how much we want to convey this as a
Caption: client we don't just go for
Caption: target we always try to go a little bit
Caption: further and we try to inspire each other
Caption: by learning new skills having new
Caption: challenges and taking them and i think
Caption: it's very inspiring we better build
Caption: better personally i always try to be
Caption: better than yesterday
Caption: that's always been me
Caption: so i'm better than yesterday and i'll be
Caption: better tomorrow but i also got a lot of
Caption: training opportunities and planning
Caption: because there's a vast
Caption: library of training courses available
Caption: that i can just access anytime before i
Caption: join planet like when you want to learn
Caption: something google first right and then
Caption: when you google something you always
Caption: have to pay for something and that's not
Caption: that's not what i want to do so it's
Caption: really it's really good that planet
Caption: offers these free courses for me and i
Caption: don't have to feel pressured about
Caption: buying something just so i can improve
Caption: my skills and use them for work
Caption: planet always encourages learning and
Caption: learning is a good way to just
Caption: accelerate your career growth top 10 of
Caption: testing is um
Caption: it's awesome
Caption: it's it's really cool to be around
Caption: people who are so passionate so driven
Caption: to do what they do
Caption: and who always want to
Caption: want to learn and get better i think
Caption: that's really important and i think it's
Caption: going to be a driving factor
Caption: going forward in in the it industry in
Caption: general
Caption: top one is the best of the best and for
Caption: me it's
Caption: if you want to grow up in your carrier
Caption: you are at the right place because we
Caption: have got all the training materials
Caption: right people and right opportunities
Caption: yeah whatever you need to progress in
Caption: your carrier you have got everything in
Caption: here
Caption: to boost your experience and boost your
Caption: personality everything in a compact pack
Caption: that's what planet is for me
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: uh
Caption: [Music]
Caption: mark where are you mark open you turn
Caption: your camera on um
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerd's nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our pockets
Caption: like my dream come true i've always
Caption: wanted to join scott hanselman
Caption: what do you want
Caption: [Music]
Caption: tell me the best thing that's happened
Caption: while i was gone i made your dad ate
Caption: healthy like you said he even tried the
Caption: broccoli eat it
Caption: then i helped him make his work much
Caption: better
Caption: and we found the perfect outfit to wear
Caption: to my party
Caption: but i really needed to wind down before
Caption: bed so i turned my hand into a starfish
Caption: my best friend is you being back
Caption: [Music]
Caption: by applying market leading technology
Caption: solutions through our lifecycle services
Caption: we help clients realize business
Caption: outcomes through our advice integration
Caption: and operational services
Caption: moq digital helps clients to fully
Caption: understand their it needs adopt the
Caption: right solution and provide ongoing
Caption: support to maximize their investment
Caption: [Music]
Caption: bye
Caption: tonight
Caption: [Music]
Caption: god
Caption: what mark where are you mark open you
Caption: turn your camera on uh
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my
Caption: this office nerd's nerding what we're
Caption: doing is we're talking to people all
Caption: over the world because we're stuck in
Caption: our pockets
Caption: like my dream come true i've always
Caption: wanted to join scott held someone's
Caption: what do you want
Caption: [Music]
Caption: we got a little problem
Caption: as you know our motto is you need a
Caption: professional bodyguard delivered to your
Caption: door in less than half an hour you've
Caption: got it buddy but without an app ain't no
Caption: bodyguard getting delivered nowhere so
Caption: where are we with that uh the app is
Caption: almost ready uh we just need
Caption: three
Caption: more days we need it asap
Caption: okay team what's the status on the app
Caption: we're good to go except our login
Caption: experience is a disaster
Caption: we need something to keep our users data
Caption: private
Caption: and to keep the hackers out
Caption: and it needs to work flawlessly because
Caption: because i don't want to lose one single
Caption: customer i hear you so let's use off
Caption: zero off what now off zero it's an
Caption: identity platform fast easy logins just
Caption: what the boss wants can we make our own
Caption: authentication service come on the
Caption: ultimate key master you know we don't
Caption: have that kind of time we need to
Caption: confirm identities with passwords
Caption: fingerprint scans whatever the users
Caption: like to use observer can do that yeah
Caption: but it needs to be secure we can't have
Caption: our app compromised by breaches not a
Caption: problem and it needs to scale if we get
Caption: hit with a ton of traffic and if it
Caption: stalls or freezes up i will get fired we
Caption: can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: could you guys stop that's really
Caption: distracting
Caption: we did it it's done already yep i think
Caption: our customers are gonna love it i got a
Caption: real app now folks
Caption: you know what i want a bodyguard
Caption: hey we got a customer
Caption: cool app
Caption: my name's stephen
Caption: what's up steven
Caption: we can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: so
Caption: right
Caption: [Music]
Caption: so
Caption: god
Caption: [Music]
Caption: foreign
Caption: what mark where are you mark open you
Caption: turn your camera on um
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: [Music]
Caption: this is nerds nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our houses
Caption: like my dream come true i've always
Caption: wanted to join scott handsome
Caption: what do you want
Caption: [Music]
Caption: ambition is a fearless hunger for
Caption: success it drives us to challenge the
Caption: way things are to pursue what seems
Caption: insurmountable to keep going when others
Caption: would stop ambition is how a global
Caption: manufacturer is using ai to empower
Caption: employees with disabilities ambition is
Caption: how a company managed an overnight
Caption: transition to remote work for 100 000
Caption: teammates ambition is how a children's
Caption: hospital built an app to reduce stress
Caption: for families ambition is how a law firm
Caption: rallied against a malware attack to
Caption: reclaim control and prevent a
Caption: devastating breach of client confidence
Caption: at insight we know the power of ambition
Caption: we've grown from a small technology
Caption: provider founded by two young brothers
Caption: to a fortune 500 company offering it
Caption: services and solutions for all for more
Caption: than 30 years people have trusted us to
Caption: turn ambitious projects into meaningful
Caption: outcomes
Caption: what will your ambitious story be
Caption: now is the time to do big things
Caption: together now is the time to be ambitious
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: my name is carol i'm a test engineer
Caption: my call sign is special case you might
Caption: be familiar with it you see it in cereal
Caption: boxes it's my call sign because i like
Caption: eating i eat a lot when people see me
Caption: they always see me eating and they
Caption: always ask me carol why are you eating
Caption: and
Caption: i think that when they see when they see
Caption: the cereal box they say okay that's
Caption: carol
Caption: hi i'm joshini i'm a test engineer they
Caption: call me gesture because i always have a
Caption: smile on my face whatever situation i'm
Caption: in
Caption: my name is jaden i'm an automation
Caption: engineer here at planet my call sign is
Caption: digit because i'm a huge huge math nerd
Caption: it is it is it is my primary major um
Caption: but i often get called out
Caption: on how i never never ever ever stop
Caption: talking about maths
Caption: i just love maths
Caption: i am
Caption: cassandra i am a test automation
Caption: especially
Caption: pink beret
Caption: as you can tell by the accent i am
Caption: french very very prominent accent so the
Caption: barrack completely makes sense as for
Caption: the ping no matter the client no matter
Caption: where i was working it always was a pink
Caption: background with
Caption: hello kitty riding a unicorn
Caption: it does not reflect who i am outside
Caption: clearly but i think it brings a little
Caption: bit of
Caption: sparks and enjoy and so yeah so being
Caption: better it is
Caption: my name is kong i'm a consultant here at
Caption: planet it's when people ask me how to
Caption: pronounce my name i always say
Caption: i'm not the king but the kong
Caption: but after joining planet
Caption: i am the king and i'm the kong
Caption: work to inspire is very something that
Caption: we live by i believe we definitely see
Caption: how much passion we are for quality and
Caption: how much we want to convey this as a
Caption: client we don't just go for
Caption: target we always try to go a little bit
Caption: further and we try to inspire each other
Caption: by learning new skills having new
Caption: challenges and taking them and i think
Caption: it's very inspiring we better build
Caption: better personally i always try to be
Caption: better than yesterday
Caption: that's always been me so i'm better than
Caption: yesterday and i'll be better tomorrow i
Caption: also get a lot of training opportunities
Caption: and planning because there's a vast
Caption: library of training courses available
Caption: that i can just access anytime before i
Caption: join planet like when you want to learn
Caption: something google first right and then
Caption: when you google something you always
Caption: have to pay for something and that's not
Caption: that's not what i want to do so it's
Caption: really it's really good that planet
Caption: offers these free courses for me and i
Caption: don't have to feel pressured about
Caption: buying something just so i can improve
Caption: my skills and use them for work
Caption: planet always encourages learning and
Caption: learning is a good way to just
Caption: accelerate your career growth top down
Caption: of testing is um
Caption: it's awesome
Caption: it's it's
Caption: really cool to be around people who are
Caption: so passionate so driven
Caption: to do what they do
Caption: and who always want to want to learn and
Caption: get better
Caption: i think that's really important and i
Caption: think it's going to be a driving factor
Caption: going forward in in the it industry in
Caption: general
Caption: top 1 is the best of the best and for me
Caption: it's
Caption: if you want to grow up in your carrier
Caption: you are at the right place because we
Caption: have got all the training materials
Caption: right people and right opportunities
Caption: whatever you need to progress in your
Caption: career you have got everything in here
Caption: to boost your experience
Caption: and boost your personality everything
Caption: in a compact pack that's what planet is
Caption: for me
Caption: so
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: uh
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what mark where are you mark open you
Caption: turn your camera on uh
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah we can see you
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerd's nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our houses
Caption: like my dream come true i've always
Caption: wanted to join scott hanselman's
Caption: what do you want
Caption: [Music]
Caption: tell me the best thing that's happened
Caption: while i was gone i made your dad ate
Caption: healthy like you said he even tried the
Caption: broccoli eat it
Caption: then i helped him make his work much
Caption: better
Caption: and we found the perfect outfit to wear
Caption: to my party
Caption: but i really needed to wind down before
Caption: bed so i turned my hand into a
Caption: starfish my best friend is you being
Caption: back
Caption: [Music]
Caption: by applying market leading technology
Caption: solutions through our lifecycle services
Caption: we help clients realize business
Caption: outcomes through our advice integration
Caption: and operational services
Caption: mlq digital helps clients to fully
Caption: understand their it needs adopt the
Caption: right solution and provide ongoing
Caption: support to maximize their investment
Caption: [Music]
Caption: bye
Caption: foreign
Caption: all right
Caption: [Music]
Caption: um
Caption: mark where are you mark open you turn
Caption: your camera on um
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerd's nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our poses
Caption: this is like my dream come true i've
Caption: always wanted to join scott held
Caption: someone's
Caption: what do you want
Caption: [Music]
Caption: let's go
Caption: we got a little problem
Caption: as you know our motto is you need a
Caption: professional bodyguard delivered to your
Caption: door in less than half an hour you've
Caption: got it buddy but without an app ain't no
Caption: bodyguard getting delivered nowhere so
Caption: where are we with that uh the app is
Caption: almost ready uh we just need
Caption: three
Caption: more days we need it asap
Caption: okay team what's the status on the app
Caption: we're good to go except our login
Caption: experience is a disaster
Caption: we need something to keep our users data
Caption: private
Caption: and to keep the hackers out
Caption: and it needs to work flawlessly because
Caption: because i don't want to lose one single
Caption: customer i hear you so let's use off
Caption: zero off what now off zero it's an
Caption: identity platform fast easy logins just
Caption: what the boss wants can we make our own
Caption: authentication service come on the
Caption: ultimate key master you know we don't
Caption: have that kind of time we need to
Caption: confirm identities with passwords
Caption: fingerprint scans whatever the users
Caption: like to use zero can do that yeah but it
Caption: needs to be secure we can't have our app
Caption: compromised by breaches not a problem
Caption: and it needs to scale if we get hit with
Caption: a ton of traffic and if it stalls or
Caption: freezes up i will get fired we can do
Caption: this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: could you guys stop that's really
Caption: distracting
Caption: we did it it's done already yep i think
Caption: our customers are gonna love it i got a
Caption: real app now folks
Caption: you know what i want a bodyguard
Caption: hey we got a customer
Caption: cool app
Caption: my name's steven
Caption: what's up steven
Caption: we can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: bye
Caption: uh
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what mark where are you mark open you
Caption: turn your camera on um
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah
Caption: yeah we can see you
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: [Music]
Caption: this is nerds nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our poses
Caption: like my dream come true i've always
Caption: wanted to join scott held someone's
Caption: what do you want
Caption: [Music]
Caption: ambition is a fearless hunger for
Caption: success it drives us to challenge the
Caption: way things are to pursue what seems
Caption: insurmountable to keep going when others
Caption: would stop ambition is how a global
Caption: manufacturer is using ai to empower
Caption: employees with disabilities ambition is
Caption: how a company managed an overnight
Caption: transition to remote work for 100 000
Caption: teammates ambition is how a children's
Caption: hospital built an app to reduce stress
Caption: for families ambition is how a law firm
Caption: rallied against a malware attack to
Caption: reclaim control and prevent a
Caption: devastating breach of client confidence
Caption: at insight we know the power of ambition
Caption: we've grown from a small technology
Caption: provider founded by two young brothers
Caption: to a fortune 500 company offering it
Caption: services and solutions for all for more
Caption: than 30 years people have trusted us to
Caption: turn ambitious projects into meaningful
Caption: outcomes
Caption: what will your ambitious story be
Caption: now is the time to do big things
Caption: together now is the time to be ambitious
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: my name is carol i'm a test engineer
Caption: my call sign is special case you might
Caption: be familiar with it you see it in cereal
Caption: boxes it's my call sign because i like
Caption: eating i eat a lot when people see me
Caption: they always see me eating and they
Caption: always ask me carol why are you eating
Caption: and
Caption: i think that when they see when they see
Caption: the cereal box they say okay that's
Caption: carol
Caption: hi i'm joshini i'm a test engineer they
Caption: call me gesture because i always have a
Caption: smile on my face whatever situation i'm
Caption: in
Caption: my name is jaden i'm an automation
Caption: engineer here at planet my call sign is
Caption: digit because i'm a huge huge math nerd
Caption: it is it is it is my primary major um
Caption: but i often get called out
Caption: on how i never never ever ever stop
Caption: talking about maths
Caption: i just love maths
Caption: i am
Caption: cassandra i am a test automation
Caption: especially
Caption: pinkberry
Caption: as you can tell by the accent i am
Caption: french very very prominent accent
Caption: so the barrack completely makes sense as
Caption: for the ping no matter the client no
Caption: matter where i was working it always was
Caption: a pink background with
Caption: hello kitty riding a unicorn
Caption: it does not reflect who i am outside
Caption: clearly but i think it brings a little
Caption: bit of um sparks and enjoy and so yeah
Caption: so being better it is
Caption: my name is kong i'm a consultant here at
Caption: planet it's when people ask me how to
Caption: pronounce my name i always say
Caption: i'm not the king but the kong
Caption: but after joining planet
Caption: i am the king and i'm the kong
Caption: work to inspire is very something that
Caption: we live by i believe we definitely see
Caption: how much passion we are for quality and
Caption: how much we want to convey this as a
Caption: client we don't just go for
Caption: target we always try to go a little bit
Caption: further and we try to inspire each other
Caption: by learning new skills having new
Caption: challenges and taking them and i think
Caption: it's very inspiring we better build
Caption: better personally i always try to be
Caption: better than yesterday that's always been
Caption: me so i'm better than yesterday and i'll
Caption: be better tomorrow i also get a lot of
Caption: training opportunities and planning
Caption: because there's a vast
Caption: library of training courses available
Caption: that i can just access anytime before i
Caption: join planet like when you want to learn
Caption: something google first right and then
Caption: when you google something you always
Caption: have to pay for something and that's not
Caption: that's not what i want to do so it's
Caption: really it's really good that planet
Caption: offers these free courses for me and i
Caption: don't have to feel pressured about
Caption: buying something just so i can improve
Caption: my skills and use them for work
Caption: planet always encourages learning and
Caption: learning is a good way to just
Caption: accelerate your career growth
Caption: of testing is um
Caption: it's awesome
Caption: it's it's really cool to be around
Caption: people who are so passionate so driven
Caption: to do what they do
Caption: and who always want to want to learn and
Caption: get better
Caption: i think that's really important and i
Caption: think it's going to be a driving factor
Caption: going forward in the it industry in
Caption: general
Caption: top one is the best of the best and for
Caption: me it's
Caption: if you want to grow up in your carrier
Caption: you are at the right place because we
Caption: have got all the training materials
Caption: right people and right opportunities
Caption: whatever you need to progress in your
Caption: career you have got everything in here
Caption: to boost your experience and boost your
Caption: personality everything in a compact pack
Caption: that's what planet is for me
Caption: so
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: um
Caption: [Music]
Caption: do
Caption: what mark where are you mark open you
Caption: turn your camera on uh
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerd's nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our houses
Caption: my dream come true i've always wanted to
Caption: join scott held someone's
Caption: what do you want
Caption: [Music]
Caption: tell me the best thing that's happened
Caption: while i was gone i made your dad ate
Caption: healthy like you said he even tried the
Caption: broccoli eat it
Caption: then i helped him make his work much
Caption: better
Caption: and we found the perfect outfit to wear
Caption: to my party
Caption: but i really needed to wind down before
Caption: bed so i turned my hand into a starfish
Caption: my best friend is you being back
Caption: [Music]
Caption: by applying market leading technology
Caption: solutions through our lifecycle services
Caption: we help clients realize business
Caption: outcomes through our advice integration
Caption: and operational services
Caption: mlq digital helps clients to fully
Caption: understand their it needs adopt the
Caption: right solution and provide ongoing
Caption: support to maximize their investment
Caption: so
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: night
Caption: [Music]
Caption: foreign
Caption: um
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what mark where are you mark open you
Caption: turn your camera on um
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah
Caption: yeah we can see you
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerd's nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our houses
Caption: like my dream come true i've always
Caption: wanted to join scott handsome
Caption: what do you want
Caption: [Music]
Caption: let's go
Caption: we got a little problem
Caption: as you know our motto is you need a
Caption: professional bodyguard delivered to your
Caption: door in less than half an hour you've
Caption: got it buddy but without an app ain't no
Caption: bodyguard getting delivered nowhere so
Caption: where are we with that uh the app is
Caption: almost ready uh we just need
Caption: three
Caption: more days we need it asap
Caption: okay team what's the status on the app
Caption: we're good to go except our login
Caption: experience is a disaster
Caption: we need something to keep our users data
Caption: private
Caption: and to keep the hackers out
Caption: and it needs to work flawlessly because
Caption: because i don't want to lose one single
Caption: customer i hear you so let's use off
Caption: zero off what now off zero it's an
Caption: identity platform fast easy logins just
Caption: what the boss wants can we make our own
Caption: authentication service come on the
Caption: ultimate key master you know we don't
Caption: have that kind of time we need to
Caption: confirm identities with passwords
Caption: fingerprint scans whatever the users
Caption: like to use observer can do that yeah
Caption: but it needs to be secure we can't have
Caption: our app compromised by breaches not a
Caption: problem and it needs to scale if we get
Caption: hit with a ton of traffic and if it
Caption: stalls or freezes up i will get fired we
Caption: can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: could you guys stop that's really
Caption: distracting
Caption: we did it it's done already yep i think
Caption: our customers are gonna love it i got a
Caption: real app now folks
Caption: you know what i want a bodyguard
Caption: hey we got a customer
Caption: cool app
Caption: my name's steven
Caption: what's up steven
Caption: we can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: um
Caption: [Music]
Caption: mark where are you mark open you turn
Caption: your camera on um
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah
Caption: yeah we can see you
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what we're doing is we're talking to
Caption: people all over the world because we're
Caption: stuck in our houses
Caption: this is like my dream come true i've
Caption: always wanted to join scott handsome
Caption: do you want
Caption: [Music]
Caption: ambition is a fearless hunger for
Caption: success it drives us to challenge the
Caption: way things are to pursue what seems
Caption: insurmountable to keep going when others
Caption: would stop ambition is how a global
Caption: manufacturer is using ai to empower
Caption: employees with disabilities ambition is
Caption: how a company managed an overnight
Caption: transition to remote work for 100 000
Caption: teammates ambition is how a children's
Caption: hospital built an app to reduce stress
Caption: for families ambition is how a law firm
Caption: rallied against a malware attack to
Caption: reclaim control and prevent a
Caption: devastating breach of client confidence
Caption: at insight we know the power of ambition
Caption: we've grown from a small technology
Caption: provider founded by two young brothers
Caption: to a fortune 500 company offering it
Caption: services and solutions for all for more
Caption: than 30 years
Caption: people have trusted us to turn ambitious
Caption: projects into meaningful outcomes
Caption: what will your ambitious story be
Caption: now is the time to do big things
Caption: together now is the time to be ambitious
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: my name is carol i'm a test engineer
Caption: my call sign is special case you might
Caption: be familiar with it you see it in cereal
Caption: boxes it's my call sign because i like
Caption: eating i eat a lot when people see me
Caption: they always see me eating and they
Caption: always ask me carol why are you eating
Caption: and i think that just when they see when
Caption: they see the cereal box they say okay
Caption: that's carol
Caption: hi i'm joshni i'm a test engineer they
Caption: call me gesture because i always have a
Caption: smile on my face whatever situation i'm
Caption: in
Caption: my name is jaden i'm an automation
Caption: engineer here at planet my call sign is
Caption: digit because i'm a huge huge maths nerd
Caption: it is it is it is my primary major um
Caption: but i often get called out
Caption: on how i never never ever ever stop
Caption: talking about maths
Caption: i just love maths
Caption: i am
Caption: cassandra i am a test automation
Caption: especially
Caption: pinkberry
Caption: as you can tell by the accent i am
Caption: french very very prominent accent
Caption: so the barrack completely makes sense as
Caption: for the being no matter the client no
Caption: matter where i was working it always was
Caption: a pink background with
Caption: hello kitty riding a unicorn
Caption: it does not reflect who i am outside
Caption: clearly but i think it brings a little
Caption: bit of
Caption: sparks and and joy and so yeah so being
Caption: better it is
Caption: my name is kong i'm a consultant here at
Caption: planet when people ask me how to
Caption: pronounce my name i always say
Caption: i'm not the king but the kong
Caption: but after joining planet
Caption: i am the king and i'm the kong
Caption: work to inspire is very something that
Caption: we live by i believe we definitely see
Caption: how much passion we are for quality and
Caption: how much we want to convey this as a
Caption: client we don't just go for
Caption: target we always try to go a little bit
Caption: further and we try to inspire each other
Caption: by learning new skills having new
Caption: challenges and taking them and i think
Caption: it's very inspiring we better build
Caption: better personally i always try to be
Caption: better than yesterday
Caption: that's always been me
Caption: so i'm better than yesterday and i'll be
Caption: better tomorrow i also get a lot of
Caption: training opportunities and planning
Caption: because there's a vast
Caption: library of training courses available
Caption: that i can just access anything before i
Caption: join planet like when you want to learn
Caption: something google first right and then
Caption: when you google something you always
Caption: have to pay for something and that's not
Caption: that's not what i want to do so it's
Caption: really it's really good that planet
Caption: offers these free courses for me and i
Caption: don't have to feel pressured about
Caption: buying something just so i can improve
Caption: my skills and use them for work
Caption: planet always encourages learning and
Caption: learning is a good way to just
Caption: accelerate your career growth top note
Caption: of testing is um
Caption: it's awesome
Caption: it's it's really cool to be around
Caption: people who are so passionate so driven
Caption: to do what they do
Caption: and who always want to
Caption: want to learn and get better
Caption: i think that's really important and i
Caption: think it's going to be a driving factor
Caption: going forward in in the it industry in
Caption: general
Caption: top one is the best of the best and for
Caption: me it's
Caption: if you want to grow up in your carrier
Caption: you are at the right place because we
Caption: have got all the training materials
Caption: right people and right opportunities
Caption: whatever you need to progress in your
Caption: career you have got everything in here
Caption: to boost your experience and boost your
Caption: personality everything
Caption: in a compact pack that's what planet is
Caption: for me
Caption: [Music]
Caption: hi
Caption: so
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: um
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what mark where are you mark open you
Caption: turn your camera on um
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah
Caption: and i was told to give you a tour of my
Caption: office
Caption: this is nerd's nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our houses
Caption: like my dream come true i've always
Caption: wanted to join scott held someone's
Caption: what do you want
Caption: [Music]
Caption: tell me the best thing that's happened
Caption: while i was gone i made your dad ate
Caption: healthy like you said he even tried the
Caption: broccoli eat it
Caption: then i helped him make his work much
Caption: better
Caption: and we found the perfect outfit to wear
Caption: to my party
Caption: but i really needed to wind down before
Caption: bed so i turned my hand into a starfish
Caption: my best friend is you being back
Caption: [Music]
Caption: by applying market leading technology
Caption: solutions through our lifecycle services
Caption: we help clients realize business
Caption: outcomes through our advice integration
Caption: and operational services
Caption: moq digital helps clients to fully
Caption: understand their it needs adopt the
Caption: right solution and provide ongoing
Caption: support to maximize their investment
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: god
Caption: [Music]
Caption: foreign
Caption: uh
Caption: [Music]
Caption: mark where are you mark open you turn
Caption: your camera on uh
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah
Caption: yeah we can see you
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerds nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our puzzles
Caption: this is like my dream come true i've
Caption: always wanted to join scott held
Caption: someone's
Caption: what do you want
Caption: [Music]
Caption: let's go
Caption: we got a little problem
Caption: as you know our motto is you need a
Caption: professional bodyguard delivered to your
Caption: door in less than half an hour you've
Caption: got it buddy but without an app ain't no
Caption: bodyguard getting delivered nowhere so
Caption: where are we with that uh the app is
Caption: almost ready uh we just need
Caption: three
Caption: more days we needed asap
Caption: okay team what's the status on the app
Caption: we're good to go except our login
Caption: experience is a disaster
Caption: we need something to keep our users data
Caption: private
Caption: and to keep the hackers out
Caption: and it needs to work flawlessly because
Caption: because i don't want to lose one single
Caption: customer i hear you so let's use off
Caption: zero off what now off zero it's an
Caption: identity platform fast easy logins just
Caption: what the boss wants can we make our own
Caption: authentication service come on the
Caption: ultimate key master you know we don't
Caption: have that kind of time we need to
Caption: confirm identities with passwords
Caption: fingerprint scans whatever the users
Caption: like to use observer can do that yeah
Caption: but it needs to be secure we can't have
Caption: our app compromised by breaches not a
Caption: problem and it needs to scale if we get
Caption: hit with a ton of traffic and if it
Caption: stalls or freezes up i will get fired we
Caption: can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: could you guys stop that's really
Caption: distracting
Caption: we did it it's done already yep and i
Caption: think our customers are gonna love it i
Caption: got a real app now folks
Caption: you know what i want a bodyguard
Caption: hey we got a customer
Caption: cool app
Caption: my name's steven
Caption: what's up steven
Caption: we can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: so
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: uh
Caption: [Music]
Caption: oh mark where are you mark open you turn
Caption: your camera on uh
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah
Caption: yeah we can see you
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what we're doing is we're talking to
Caption: people all over the world because we're
Caption: stuck in our houses
Caption: this is like my dream come true i've
Caption: always wanted to join scott held
Caption: someone's
Caption: what do you want
Caption: [Music]
Caption: ambition is a fearless hunger for
Caption: success it drives us to challenge the
Caption: way things are to pursue what seems
Caption: insurmountable to keep going when others
Caption: would stop ambition is how a global
Caption: manufacturer is using ai to empower
Caption: employees with disabilities ambition is
Caption: how a company managed an overnight
Caption: transition to remote work for 100 000
Caption: teammates ambition is how a children's
Caption: hospital built an app to reduce stress
Caption: for families ambition is how a law firm
Caption: rallied against a malware attack to
Caption: reclaim control and prevent a
Caption: devastating breach of client confidence
Caption: at insight we know the power of ambition
Caption: we've grown from a small technology
Caption: provider founded by two young brothers
Caption: to a fortune 500 company offering it
Caption: services and solutions for all for more
Caption: than 30 years people have trusted us to
Caption: turn ambitious projects into meaningful
Caption: outcomes
Caption: what will your ambitious story be
Caption: now is the time to do big things
Caption: together now is the time to be ambitious
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: my name is carol i'm a test engineer
Caption: my call sign is special case you might
Caption: be familiar with it you see it in cereal
Caption: boxes it's my call sign because i like
Caption: eating i eat a lot when people see me
Caption: they always see me eating and they
Caption: always ask me carol why are you eating
Caption: and
Caption: i think that when they see when they see
Caption: the cereal box they say okay that's
Caption: carol
Caption: hi i'm joshni i'm a test engineer they
Caption: call me gesture because i always have a
Caption: smile on my face whatever situation i'm
Caption: in
Caption: my name is jaden i'm an automation
Caption: engineer here at planet my core sign is
Caption: digit because i'm a huge huge maths nerd
Caption: it is it is it is my primary major um
Caption: but i often get called out
Caption: on how i never never ever ever stop
Caption: talking about maths i just love maths
Caption: i am
Caption: cassandra i am a test automation
Caption: especially
Caption: pinkberry
Caption: as you can tell by the accent i am
Caption: french very very prominent accent
Caption: so the barrack completely makes sense as
Caption: for the being no matter the client no
Caption: matter where i was working it always was
Caption: a big background with
Caption: hello kitty riding a unicorn
Caption: it does not reflect who i am outside
Caption: clearly but i think it brings a little
Caption: bit of
Caption: sparks and enjoy and so yeah so being
Caption: better it is
Caption: my name is kong i'm a consultant here at
Caption: planet and it's when people ask me how
Caption: to pronounce my name i always say
Caption: i'm not the king but the kong
Caption: but after joining planet
Caption: i am the king and i'm the kong
Caption: work to inspire is very something that
Caption: we live by i believe we definitely see
Caption: how much passion we are for quality and
Caption: how much we want to convey this as a
Caption: client we don't just go for
Caption: target we always try to go a little bit
Caption: further and we try to inspire each other
Caption: by learning new skills having new
Caption: challenges and taking them and i think
Caption: it's very inspiring we better build
Caption: better personally i always try to be
Caption: better than yesterday
Caption: that's always been me
Caption: so i'm better than yesterday and i'll be
Caption: better tomorrow i also get a lot of
Caption: training opportunities and planning
Caption: because there's a vast
Caption: library of training courses available
Caption: that i can just access anytime before i
Caption: join planet like when you want to learn
Caption: something google first right and then
Caption: when you google something you always
Caption: have to pay for something and that's not
Caption: that's not what i want to do so it's
Caption: really it's really good that planet
Caption: offers these free courses for me and i
Caption: don't have to feel pressured about
Caption: buying something just so i can improve
Caption: my skills and use them for work
Caption: planet always encourages learning and
Caption: learning is a good way to just
Caption: accelerate your career growth top-notch
Caption: testing is um it's awesome
Caption: it's it's really cool to be around
Caption: people who are so passionate so driven
Caption: to do what they do
Caption: and who always want to want to learn and
Caption: get better
Caption: i think that's really important and i
Caption: think it's going to be a driving factor
Caption: going forward in in the it industry in
Caption: general
Caption: top one is the best of the best and for
Caption: me it's
Caption: if you want to grow up in your carrier
Caption: you are at the right place because we
Caption: have got all the training materials
Caption: right people and right opportunities
Caption: yeah whatever you need to progress in
Caption: your carrier you have got everything in
Caption: here
Caption: to boost your experience and boost your
Caption: personality everything
Caption: in a compact pack that's what planet is
Caption: for me
Caption: so
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: um
Caption: [Music]
Caption: everyone to uh i think a final session
Caption: in jakarta nagal today
Caption: withers is ryan folds he's discussing
Caption: the war on tech talent ryan is a
Caption: technical talent acquisition specialist
Caption: who has been recruiting in the perth
Caption: technology market for the last five
Caption: years
Caption: he recruits across data analytics cloud
Caption: cyber security and i.t projects pretty
Caption: much covers it all i think
Caption: they're two well-recognized recruitment
Caption: agencies he's currently the talent
Caption: acquisition specialist for serbian
Caption: a cloud and data focus company led by a
Caption: highly talented team of technical
Caption: consultants and he's also one of the
Caption: current wa chapter leads for the
Caption: australian women in security network
Caption: promoting connection support and
Caption: inspiration for women in the cyber
Caption: security industry
Caption: please welcome ryan
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: thank you very much dave and thank you
Caption: everyone for coming here to watch this
Caption: today this is my first ddd conference
Caption: first time i've been to one and first
Caption: one that i'm presenting at so please be
Caption: gentle
Caption: hands up if you've tried to hire a
Caption: software engineer in the last 12 or so
Caption: months
Caption: yep
Caption: cool
Caption: what about a data engineer in the last
Caption: 12 months
Caption: cool
Caption: and cloud engineers
Caption: they're hard yeah
Caption: so
Caption: this presentation should be pretty
Caption: relevant for everybody in the room then
Caption: my name is ryan folds um you might know
Caption: me from such places as your linkedin
Caption: message box
Caption: i've been recruiting in the perth
Caption: technology market for the last five or
Caption: so years across two large agencies
Caption: applications development data
Caption: engineering data science
Caption: devops cyber and pretty much everything
Caption: else in between
Caption: i started working as a talent
Caption: acquisition
Caption: time acquisition specialist with a
Caption: business called serbian so serbian is a
Caption: technology consulting business we're a
Caption: collection of passionate problem solvers
Caption: of technology agnostic individuals that
Caption: like really just working on cool stuff
Caption: and sharing and sort of collaborating on
Caption: some of the knowledge that we have
Caption: um so the the serbian brand it's been
Caption: pretty well known in the east coast
Caption: we've been around for about 15 years but
Caption: the perth branch has only launched in
Caption: august of 2021 so it's it's reasonably
Caption: new uh for perth at least
Caption: so the great war for technology is upon
Caption: us
Caption: and it's been upon us for some time now
Caption: but the game has definitely changed in
Caption: order to combat closed borders
Caption: restricted travel and just a
Caption: generally
Caption: adverse attitude towards changing jobs
Caption: amid a pandemic as you'd expect the
Caption: perth technology market has really had
Caption: to undergo an evolution in terms of
Caption: talent
Caption: and serbian's no different from any
Caption: other business in the room you know the
Caption: main challenge for a lot of businesses
Caption: pretty much all technology businesses in
Caption: perth is how do we attract and retain
Caption: the best possible talent in the market
Caption: as a business we're still working on
Caption: this we're still fine-tuning this
Caption: process
Caption: but there's a number of talent
Caption: acquisition strategies that we've put in
Caption: place over the last 12 or so months
Caption: to grow from a team of four to a team of
Caption: 31 technical consultants working with
Caption: some of the latest in cloud technology
Caption: i walked into the serving office in
Caption: august of 2021 um
Caption: i probably didn't do my due diligence at
Caption: the time and didn't actually realize how
Caption: small the team was so i walked into the
Caption: building
Caption: and one of the principal consultants
Caption: said yep this is it all four of us
Caption: great
Caption: um so at that point i really i knew two
Caption: things one i wasn't going to be made
Caption: redundant any time soon
Caption: and two we've got a lot of work ahead of
Caption: us
Caption: i was essentially tasked with building
Caption: the perth team from the ground up the
Caption: regional partner at the time had
Caption: basically said to me look if you can
Caption: find a couple of you know software
Caption: professionals or devops engineers in the
Caption: first 12 months great fantastic now i'd
Caption: heard along the grapevine that our
Caption: brisbane office had gone from zero to 65
Caption: technical consultants in about three
Caption: years
Caption: i was not going to let brisbane beat me
Caption: apparently recruiters by nature are very
Caption: competitive people
Caption: so yeah look you know 12 months later
Caption: we've been able to successfully build a
Caption: team of 31 technical consultants across
Caption: data engineering devops engineering
Caption: cloud engineering cyber security and
Caption: software development
Caption: so again why is this presentation to
Caption: every relevant to everybody in the room
Caption: well all we have to do is just look at
Caption: seek and look at some of the adverts
Caption: that are currently advertised
Caption: now before we get stuck in let's just
Caption: take a second to have a look at the
Caption: perth market in terms of the perth
Caption: technology market
Caption: please keep in mind that this was a
Caption: study
Caption: that i did actually with thank you to
Caption: the rob walters team who helped me with
Caption: some of the insights
Caption: but this is based on statistics that are
Caption: only available on linkedin so
Caption: if a person hasn't got their profile on
Caption: linkedin they're obviously not included
Caption: in the study
Caption: so according to linkedin we have 3241
Caption: software professionals in perth
Caption: so that's not a whole heap much to my
Caption: disappointment probably everyone's
Caption: disappointment software developers don't
Caption: grow on trees
Caption: um of the 3241
Caption: software professionals in perth in the
Caption: last 12 months we've had 749 change job
Caption: which is about 23 of the perth market
Caption: 16 of the perth software professional
Caption: market identifies female and the average
Caption: tenure with any organization is one and
Caption: a half years this is just a quick
Caption: breakdown on
Caption: the actual dynamics of the um the
Caption: software dev market so we've got
Caption: about 2 000 software developers about
Caption: 700 or so senior software engineers and
Caption: a couple of other positions in there as
Caption: well
Caption: let's have a look at data engineers
Caption: so again these stats are only based on
Caption: what's actually out there on linkedin
Caption: so you can see here that we've got a
Caption: total of 263 data engineers senior data
Caption: engineers and other related data
Caption: professional titles in the market
Caption: of the 263
Caption: 94 have changed jobs in the last 12
Caption: months which is pretty staggering that's
Caption: 35 36 percent of the entire market has
Caption: moved the job within data engineering in
Caption: the last 12 months
Caption: diversity probably fares slightly better
Caption: with 26 percent of the market
Caption: identifying as female and again the
Caption: average median temperature with any
Caption: organization is one and a half years
Caption: this is a scary one we've only got 52
Caption: senior data engineers in perth i feel
Caption: like there's something wrong with that
Caption: but
Caption: lastly we'll have a look at another
Caption: really challenging skill set to hire in
Caption: perth which is cloud professionals
Caption: so again according to linkedin the cloud
Caption: technology market tells us that there
Caption: are 253 cloud technology professionals
Caption: listed on linkedin
Caption: of the 253
Caption: 69 have changed job in the past 12
Caption: months 12 percent of the market
Caption: identifies female and again the at the
Caption: median tenure with an organization is
Caption: one and a half years
Caption: so
Caption: what does this tell us about the tech
Caption: market in perth
Caption: it's pretty tight
Caption: it's pretty tall i think that we can all
Caption: agree that
Caption: you know we're all hiring these skill
Caption: sets they're all very similar sorts of
Caption: skill sets we're all doing really
Caption: interesting projects
Caption: so naturally we're all looking for the
Caption: same sorts of professionals to help us
Caption: on that journey
Caption: so how do we overcome this challenge
Caption: maths and relationships
Caption: so
Caption: back when i first started in recruitment
Caption: um my boss at the time jody
Caption: hey
Caption: um she told me that the math doesn't lie
Caption: when it comes to recruitment now when i
Caption: was 23 years old and was six months into
Caption: recruitment didn't really believe it too
Caption: much but
Caption: looking back on it now that i've matured
Caption: a little bit more i very much believe
Caption: that effective recruitment in today's
Caption: market especially in perth consists of
Caption: two really key elements and that is
Caption: maths and
Caption: relationships but ryan how does maths
Caption: relate to recruitment don't you just
Caption: call people up and ask them about
Caption: opportunities and jobs
Caption: it's a great question
Caption: so i'd be interested to hear maybe some
Caption: stats from the people in the crowd
Caption: especially recruiters and talent
Caption: acquisition specialists in the room um
Caption: maybe at a later date but look for the
Caption: time being i'm happy to use my
Caption: statistics with serbian as a bit of an
Caption: example
Caption: so
Caption: in the last 12 months serbian perth has
Caption: had 1200 applications across a number of
Caption: different professions so software
Caption: development data engineering
Caption: devops cloud and cyber security
Caption: of those 1210 applications will take 243
Caption: through to the first round of interview
Caption: 90 will make it through to the technical
Caption: exercise that we have so we get everyone
Caption: to undergo a technical exercise
Caption: and of the 220 that take the exercise
Caption: only 118 will pass
Caption: 118 will go through to the second round
Caption: of interview which is with one of our
Caption: principal consultants
Caption: 61 making it through to the final round
Caption: of interview
Caption: so it brings us to a grand total of 39
Caption: being offered and 28 accepting
Caption: so what does the maths tell us
Caption: so look let's work it back let's let's
Caption: look at what does it take to hire 28
Caption: talented technologists across a 12 month
Caption: period
Caption: i'll need to speak to roughly
Caption: 25.521 candidates a week which is
Caption: roughly five candidates a day
Caption: i'll need to interview 5.06 qualified
Caption: candidates a week one a day
Caption: i need to have at least 2.46 candidates
Caption: at a second round interview
Caption: and 1.27 candidates at a final round
Caption: interview
Caption: so in order to hire two or three
Caption: candidates per month
Caption: that's sort of what we need to do in
Caption: terms of process from an interview and
Caption: recruitment point of view
Caption: now if you're wondering you know we've
Caption: got a talent acquisition team we've got
Caption: a recruitment team um maybe why are they
Caption: not looking at or why they're not
Caption: getting the same sorts of results from
Caption: my internal team i'd probably encourage
Caption: you just to have a look at i suppose
Caption: working at backwards and re-engineering
Caption: that process
Caption: you know looking at how efficient how
Caption: effective that process is
Caption: and hopefully the answers should lie in
Caption: there for you
Caption: now in addition to this
Caption: we've highlighted just how
Caption: tight the perth market can be
Caption: so we need to really be thinking about
Caption: how our brand is engaging with those
Caption: 3241 software developers in perth how am
Caption: i managing relationships with the 263
Caption: data engineers or how am i being
Caption: perceived by the 253 cloud professionals
Caption: in perth
Caption: so we know what the challenges are
Caption: finding talent's really hard
Caption: through the pandemic there's been some
Caption: real constraints around the movement of
Caption: human capital
Caption: and now that things are sort of returned
Caption: to a level of normality
Caption: i don't know about you but 263 data
Caption: engineers in perth is that's just not
Caption: enough as according to linkedin so the
Caption: challenge for us is how do we open up
Caption: this talent pool how do we how do we
Caption: widen the market that we currently have
Caption: so
Caption: let's explore interstate talent
Caption: perth is a pretty cool place to live
Caption: reasonably
Caption: i suppose
Caption: the standard of living is is pretty good
Caption: house prizes aren't the same as what
Caption: they are in sydney
Caption: so straight away i think we've got some
Caption: really good things going for us as a
Caption: state
Caption: i reckon i would have probably
Caption: one in ten candidates come through the
Caption: process that will come from
Caption: melbourne or sydney
Caption: and they'll come to us with the reasons
Caption: of perth is a great place to live it's a
Caption: great place to raise a family i can
Caption: afford a house
Caption: that's a really good start
Caption: in addition to that
Caption: you know let's look at maybe some of the
Caption: um the skilled migrants that we could
Caption: potentially explore
Caption: so
Caption: earlier this year the west australian
Caption: government and the federal government
Caption: put in place
Caption: some changes to the legislation around
Caption: easing of movement for skilled migrants
Caption: so the perth metro region was
Caption: essentially reclassified as a regional
Caption: area so this has really opened the door
Caption: for a number of different migrants from
Caption: all over the country who are keen to
Caption: work in australia but are obviously
Caption: limited with regards to opportunities
Caption: and
Caption: it's an interesting thing to think about
Caption: prior to this you know yes you could
Caption: potentially come and work in in perth
Caption: as a devops engineer but you'd have to
Caption: go and work in the bush which wouldn't
Caption: really make a lot of sense especially
Caption: you know when you're trying to build
Caption: collaborative teams
Caption: so
Caption: the changes made by the wa government
Caption: basically enabled priority processing of
Caption: regional visas and perth has now been
Caption: reclassified as a regional zone
Caption: in addition to that access to regional
Caption: occupations list which has obviously
Caption: been opened out so there's more jobs
Caption: that have actually been included on that
Caption: list of potential um employability
Caption: um so as a result of this i found we've
Caption: had a real influx of people looking to
Caption: actually fast track some of their visas
Caption: um you know in melbourne and sydney
Caption: people can be waiting upwards of six to
Caption: nine months for a potential visa but
Caption: with the west australian government
Caption: sending out invitations to apply for the
Caption: 190 visa they really are trying to drive
Caption: a lot of people at you know getting
Caption: across the state or getting across the
Caption: country into wa
Caption: so whilst we're on the topic of
Caption: international candidates or
Caption: people relocating
Caption: i had a really good interesting
Caption: conversation with one of our senior
Caption: devops engineers who's just joined us
Caption: not so long ago
Caption: i was asking sort of about his
Caption: experience and just a bit of context so
Caption: gcp
Caption: aws like five or six years of experience
Caption: just a brilliant guy
Caption: um you know a skill set that is really
Caption: highly in demand especially in the perth
Caption: market but really any market
Caption: and i was talking to him about his his
Caption: um how he felt about our process and
Caption: you know i put the question to him of
Caption: were you interviewing with anybody else
Caption: any other organizations in australia
Caption: when you were looking to make the move
Caption: and he said to me that he'd applied for
Caption: 51 51 positions
Caption: and he'd heard back from two
Caption: which is us
Caption: who snagged him
Caption: and there was one other organisation in
Caption: melbourne so this is a devops and cloud
Caption: professional who's applied for devops
Caption: and cloud related positions and he's
Caption: only heard back from two organizations
Caption: so
Caption: i think like this is a really
Caption: old-school way of thinking um you know
Caption: we're shutting we're we're crying out as
Caption: an industry for technologists with all
Caption: these specialized skills but
Caption: if you're not in perth then sorry you
Caption: don't get a look in
Caption: um
Caption: in serbian and perth we've recruited
Caption: five candidates from all over the world
Caption: including argentina south india guernsey
Caption: which is a little island halfway between
Caption: france and the uk
Caption: tiny little place
Caption: um
Caption: but yeah look it's it's
Caption: it's not really that hard you know you
Caption: just you get yourself partnered with a
Caption: really good migration agent who know
Caption: what they're doing i can recommend one
Caption: after this if you would like
Caption: we undertake a few processes you've got
Caption: to obviously get the right sort of
Caption: documentation together
Caption: you've got to do a market skills
Caption: market skills assessment which again
Caption: doesn't take too long
Caption: and you know you look at obviously the
Caption: um the costs as well and
Caption: yes it is a reasonably large
Caption: commitment by the business you're
Caption: forking out about thirteen or fourteen
Caption: thousand dollars for an individual on a
Caption: four year visa which is a 4.2
Caption: skills nominated visa but when we look
Caption: at this you know in the grand scheme of
Caption: things you break that 14 grand down it's
Caption: what three four thousand dollars a year
Caption: across a four year period straight away
Caption: we also
Caption: i suppose we we fight back against two
Caption: of the really key challenges that we're
Caption: facing as an industry which is
Caption: broadening out that talent pool outside
Caption: of just perth and wa
Caption: and we also beat the
Caption: median tenure with an organisation
Caption: because the market dictates people stay
Caption: with an organization for one and a half
Caption: years
Caption: the visa obviously we're investing in
Caption: them they're investing in us with us for
Caption: a period of about four years or so
Caption: so it's a really handy thing to look
Caption: into
Caption: now this is an important one
Caption: talent attracts talent
Caption: so you know in order to sort of attract
Caption: good talent we need to understand what
Caption: motivates talent now how do we do this
Caption: it's pretty easy
Caption: honest transparent conversations with
Caption: our distinguished technologists about
Caption: what they're doing what they want to do
Caption: and how we can put a road map and a
Caption: strategy together to get them where they
Caption: want to go
Caption: once we understand you know what our
Caption: people want to do in their experience
Caption: with the business we can put these
Caption: things in place and we really want to
Caption: empower them to be ambassadors for our
Caption: business
Caption: um another really important aspect of
Caption: this is being able to provide a
Caption: financial incentive
Caption: this should always come in in a monetary
Caption: form and the successful referral of
Caption: candidates to our business at all levels
Caption: of seniority attracts an 8 000 referral
Caption: bonus
Caption: which i find is well and truly enough to
Caption: motivate people to have conversations
Caption: with old colleagues
Caption: and and get people to flip me the cv and
Caption: have just a general conversation
Caption: so if we're recruiting for technologists
Caption: in perth whether we like it or not we're
Caption: in the great wall for technology talent
Caption: the landscape's ever changing and in
Caption: order to retain and grow
Caption: our teams of distinguished technologists
Caption: we've got to change with the times
Caption: so embracing visas you know empowering
Caption: our staff and looking at maths and
Caption: relationships when it comes to
Caption: recruitment um you know this is how
Caption: we've become one of the fastest growing
Caption: technical consultancies in perth in the
Caption: last 12 months
Caption: we've got an industry that are
Caption: essentially crying out for technologists
Caption: at the moment and recruiters love
Caption: telling me oh it's really hard to find
Caption: talent at the moment
Caption: i fundamentally believe this statement's
Caption: wrong it's actually not that hard it's
Caption: challenging yes it's not easy at times
Caption: but if you actually take the time to
Caption: think outside the box you know adopt
Caption: different ways of doing things
Caption: and change the way that you're
Caption: approaching the game i think you'll be
Caption: quite surprised by what you find
Caption: that's pretty much it for me i just
Caption: wanted to say thank you very much to all
Caption: the sponsors
Caption: today wouldn't be possible without them
Caption: so thank you very much
Caption: and
Caption: have a chat with me
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: all right
Caption: [Music]
Caption: foreign
Caption: what mark where are you mark open you
Caption: turn your camera on
Caption: um
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerds nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our puppies
Caption: this is like my dream come true i've
Caption: always wanted to join scott hanselman's
Caption: what do you want
Caption: [Music]
Caption: let's go
Caption: we got a little problem
Caption: as you know our motto is you need a
Caption: professional bodyguard delivered to your
Caption: door in less than half an hour you've
Caption: got it buddy but without an app ain't no
Caption: bodyguard getting delivered nowhere so
Caption: where are we with that uh the app is
Caption: almost ready uh we just need
Caption: three
Caption: more days we need it asap
Caption: okay team what's the status on the app
Caption: we're good to go except our login
Caption: experience is a disaster
Caption: we need something to keep our users data
Caption: private
Caption: and to keep the hackers out
Caption: and it needs to work flawlessly because
Caption: because i don't want to lose one single
Caption: customer i hear you so let's use off
Caption: zero off what now off zero it's an
Caption: identity platform fast easy logins just
Caption: what the boss wants can we make our own
Caption: authentication service come on the
Caption: ultimate key master you know we don't
Caption: have that kind of time we need to
Caption: confirm identities with passwords
Caption: fingerprint scans whatever the users
Caption: like to use observer can do that yeah
Caption: but it needs to be secure we can't have
Caption: our app compromised by breaches not a
Caption: problem and it needs to scale if we get
Caption: hit with a ton of traffic and if it
Caption: stalls or freezes up i will get fired we
Caption: can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: could you guys stop that's really
Caption: distracting
Caption: we did it it's done already yep and i
Caption: think our customers are gonna love it i
Caption: got a real app now folks
Caption: you know what i want a bodyguard
Caption: hey we got a customer
Caption: cool app
Caption: my name's steven
Caption: what's up steven
Caption: we can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: you